HELLO GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WE WILL START WITH ALL OF THE
TALKING POINTS WE HAVE TO GET
THROUGH PROCEDURES WHILE WE WAIT
ON. US SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES TO
GET THE DIS AND IF AND IF YOU'RE
WATCHING COLLEAGUES PLEASE COME
TO THE DICE WE CAN START HOUSING
COMMITTEE- WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE.
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ELEMENT-
COMMITTEE HEARING. TO START I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE STAFF. THE
LOVELY STAFF- THAT HAVE MADE OUR
RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TIER BILLS
POSSIBLE. DUE TO ONGOING COVER
NINETEEN SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MASKS BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED. BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR TO TELL.
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. PROBABLY IT IS
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE
THAT MEMBERS BE PROPERLY ATTIRED
FOR HEARING- FOR HEARING-
WEARING A MASK IS OPTIONAL. WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY TWO BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
WE'RE ASKING AUTHORS TO GIVE
SUCCINCT PRESENTATIONS EACH BILL
CAN HAVE TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION EACH MAIN
WITNESS GETS TWO MINUTES EACH WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO APPEAR IN PERSON
BUT WILL MAKE SOME EXCEPTIONS ON
A CASE BY CASE. CASE BY CASE
BASIS I PEOPLE WHO CANNOT TRAVEL
DUE TO ILLNESS OR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE ON POLICY
THAT CANNOT TROUBLED SACRAMENTO
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL
THEIR WITNESSES CALLING IN TO
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
YOUR BILLS THAT WE ASK YOU JUST
TO SAY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION F THE BILL IF YOU
SAY MORE THE OPERATOR WILL CUT
YOU OFF. WE WILL LIMIT COLIN
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC TO
KNOW MORE THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES
ON EACH SIDE IF YOU ARE UNABLE
TO GET THROUGH ON THE PHONE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THIS WILL BECOME PART OF
THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL
. YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN EMAIL
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF. WITH A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE ELEMENT NUMBER OF
MEMBERS. A MINIMAL. CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND ELEVEN LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE
MAINTAIN SIX FEET SPACING. WE
ARE ALSO- STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENSURE ONLY THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE IN THE
HEARING TODAY. IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
REMEMBER LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AN APPROPRIATE TIME.
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE I TESTIFYING IN RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE. SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED LIMITING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOR THE DIAL IN WITNESSES
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH- ANY- WIN THIS
CONTEST TO FIND THE BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER. FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SIX. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS- ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO.
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATE ONLINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING OR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
A BILL YOU WILL REMAIN. ON A
LIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO
YOURSELF UNTIL. YOU ARE CALLED
ON SPEAKER I ALSO WANNA NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE YOU MAY NEED TO. LIMIT
HOW LONG THE PHONE LINES ARE
OPEN FOR EACH BILL. AS RATED
TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE. THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING AND
UNDERSTANDING. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TO. YEAH WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- SO LET'S SEE.
WHERE. THIS OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
FILE ORDER- I SEE YOU MISTER
BRYANT MISTER BRIAN IS
AVAILABLE. TRY TO COME UP.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN A
BILL THAT WILL FUND. ARTICLE IN
EVIDENCE BASED SOLUTIONS TO OUR
HOMELESS PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU'VE HEARD MANY TIMES TO
THE C. CALIFORNIA HAS A SERIOUS
HOMELESS PROBLEM. AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA AN
ESTIMATED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON ANY
GIVEN DAY. AS REPORTED BY HOOD.
OF THAT TOTAL EIGHT THOUSAND AND
THIRTY MORE FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND VETERANS.
TWELVE THOUSAND WERE
UNACCOMPANIED YOUNG ADULTS. AND
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FEEDERS TO HOMELESSNESS IS OUR
SYSTEMS OF MASS INCARCERATION IN
FACT IT HAS BECOME SUCH A FEEDER
INTO HOMELESSNESS. THE CDC ARE
ESTIMATED ABOUT 20% OF ALL
PEOPLE LEAVING PRISONS WILL
LEAVE ONLY TO BECOME HOMELESS.
THEY ALSO HAVE ESTIMATED THAT
ABOUT A THIRD TO HALF OF THE
PEOPLE ON PAROLE LIVING LOS
ANGELES OR SAN FRANCISCO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. RIGHT
NOW 70% OF THE PEOPLE ON OUR
STREETS HAVE AT ONE POINT BEEN
INCARCERATED IN THE REASON IS
BECAUSE- WHEN YOU CONTACT THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM THE
LIKELIHOOD OF EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS INCREASES IN WHEN
YOU HAVE. BECOME ONE HOUSE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF CONTACTING THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM INCREASES
WELL IN LOS ANGELES OVER FOUR
YEAR PERIOD ONE AND FIVE ARRESTS
WITH SOMEBODY WHO IS
EXPERIENCING. HOMELESSNESS THIS
LINKAGE BETWEEN OUR SYSTEMS OF
MASS INCARCERATION. AND OUR
SYSTEMS OF HOUSING IN EQUITY.
OUR EXACERBATING ONE ANOTHER.
FOR THAT REASON WE BELIEVE THAT
POLICY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
CREATED PERMANENT HOUSING AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE EXITING
PRESIDENT. CURRENTLY CCR FUNDS
PROGRAMS THAT PLACE PEOPLE IN
TEMPORARY HOUSING FOR SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS. WHAT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY WILL CREATE IS A REENTRY
HOUSING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM TO DO FOR ADDITIONAL
THINGS. ONE OFFER PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
RECENT PRISON STAYS AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO LIVE IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. TO PROVIDE TENANTS WITH
SERVICES TO HELP STABILIZE THE
NEXUS WHATEVER TREATMENT THEY
MAY NEED THREE READY TENANTS FOR
THE WAGE JOBS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT COMPONENT SO TEND TO
AVENGE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE OVER
THEIR OWN RENTED FOR EVALUATE
THE OUTCOMES. SO WE KNOW WHAT IS
WORKING AND HOW WE CAN MAKE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS. THIS
MODEL IS NOT NEW SUPPORTIVE
PERMANENT HOUSING PROGRAMS HAVE
POPPED UP ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
WITH. SURPRISING AN OPTIMISTIC
AND HOPEFUL RESULTS FOR EXAMPLE
THE RETURNING HOME. OHIO PROGRAM
IN IN NEW YORK A RECORD ISLAND
PROGRAM BOTH SHOWED. A
TREMENDOUS RESULTS WHEN YOU GET
PEOPLE HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ALSO THIS BILL IS
NOT NEW TO THIS COMMITTEE. IN
ITS ORIGINAL FORM IT WAS
AUTHORED BY WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU- IN HIS ABSENCE OF
THAT HAS NOT ELIMINATED THE
PROBLEM AND THAT WE FELT
COMPELLED TO BRING IT BACK
AGAIN. WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
TWO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ONE IS
SCHON HEUTE THE INTER BOARD
CHAIR FOR THE REENTRY PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA REPOT.
AND BECKY GESTEDE THE REENTRY
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR PATH. PEOPLE
ASSISTING THE HOMELESS. FRANK IF
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU TO CHAIR WICKS VICE CHAIR
SEYARTO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
BECKY JESTER AND I'M THE RE
ENTRY PROGRAM MANAGER FOR PATH
IN SAN DIEGO I'M ON THE GROUND
EVERY DAY RUNNING EXACTLY THE
KIND OF PROGRAM AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN WOULD FIND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SO EXCITED TO CO SPONSOR
THE BELL AND GRATEFUL TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY OUR PROGRAM IN
SAN DIEGO WORKS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH BOTH THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. THE COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE THROUGH
THE COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICESAGENCY OUR PROGRAM
SUCCEEDS BECAUSE EVERY
STAKEHOLDER INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT WANTS TO STOP THE
PRISON TO STREETS PIPELINE AS A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WE CAN
STAY WITH SAY WITH CONFIDENCE
THAT'S TRUE EVERYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN OUR PROGRAM COUNTY
STAFFER FOR INDIVIDUALS TO PASS
THROUGHOUT RISK OF EXITING.
INCARCERATION INTO HOMELESSNESS
WELL AHEAD OF THEIR RELEASE
STATES THAT OUR STAFF HAS THE
TIME TO BUILD REPORT NECESSARY
TO BE THERE FOR THEM AS SOON AS
THEY'RE RELEASED. SINCE WE BEGAN
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE'VE HELPED
OVER A HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY STAY IN A SAFE
PLACE AFTER THEIR RELEASE.
RECEIVE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH OR ADDICTION
SUPPORT AND OBTAIN PERMANENT
HOUSING. SO FAR NEARLY HALF OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE ALREADY
SUSTAINING THEMSELVES IN
PERMANENT HOUSING WITHOUT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM OUR
PROGRAM. AND ALMOST THREE
QUARTERS OF OUR RECIPIENTS
HAVEN'T BEEN BOOKED INTO JAIL
FOR ANY REASON SINCE THEIR
ENROLLMENT. OUR CLIENTS ARE
GETTING THE HELP THEY NEED IN A
WAY THAT SAFER FOR THEM. AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY THAN
CARBURETION. BUT THE COUNTY'S
OWN ESTIMATE OUR PROGRAM IS MORE
THAN 20% CHEAPER THAN IT WOULD
HAVE COST TO RE ARREST AND
INCARCERATE OUR PARTICIPANTS.
REENTRY PROGRAMS DON'T JUST
LOWER THE HUMAN COST OF
INCARCERATION BUT THE FINANCIAL
COST AS WELL. WE CAN SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN WILL HELP TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS GET
THE HELP THEY NEED. TO MAKE GOOD
ON A SECOND CHANCE WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN IT'S HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL IN RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A
YES VOTE. THANK YOU NEXT ONE IS
. THE MORNING MEDICARE MEMBERS.
HI MY NAME IS JONATHAN THE
INTERIM BOARD CHAIRMAN THREE
THREE PRIVADAS ASSOCIATION.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION THAT
SUPPORTS ADVOCATE AND AN IPHONE
SECTION. THAT WORK WITH
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS TO SUPPORT.
THEIR SUCCESS. AND WE- ALSO SOME
WITHIN THE EXPERIENCE I'M A
GRANDMA BUT WITHIN THE OF MEN
RETURNING OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
UNSTABLE HOUSING AND LIVING WITH
THE REST OF HOMES WITHOUT
PERMITTED. SUPPORT EVERYDAY CAL
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE RELEASED
FROM PRISON NO PLACE TO LIVE
WITH AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
THOUSAND EXPECTED TO BE RELEASED
AND OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
THIS PRESENTS A HOMELESSNESS
PIPELINE. JEOPARDIZED OWN
STABILITY HELLO SAFELY AND WILL
BE AS WELL AS THE COMMUNITIES. A
SHORT PEOPLE HAVE STABLE AND
SECURE HOUSING TO RETURN HOME TO
IS KEY TO OUR SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
AND REINTEGRATION. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO POSITION FOR MANY
CARS READY COMMUTING THEN ALSO
FAILED. INSTEAD OF SUPPORTING
THEIR SUCCESS WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ON PAROLE ARE SEVEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO RECEIVE A
VACATION HOMELESS. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
TWENTY SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO BE UNSTABLE HOUSE OR HOMELESS
THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC. IN FACT
CALIFORNIA DALLAS DATA HAS
ESTIMATED THAT ONE THIRD TO ONE
HALF OF ALL PEOPLE ON PAROLE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS AT ANY POINT. WE
ALSO KNOW THE EVIDENCE BASED
HOUSING DECREASES RECIDIVISM
RATES BY 60% WE COMPARED TO
CONTROL GROUPS AND REDUCES
ARRESTS BY 40% AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN SUPPORTS THE SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY AND REINTEGRATION OF
FORMER INCARCERATED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BY PROVIDING PERMANENT
HOUSING SOLUTIONS AND SUPPORTS
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMMING THAT PROVIDES A
PATHWAY FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
EXCESS LIVABLE WAGE JOBS. NOT
LONG AGO I WAS IN A TRANSITIONAL
HOME. I RECEIVED A CALL ON THE
TUESDAY THAT TOLD ME MY FUNDING
WOULD BE OVER ON FRIDAY. THERE
WERE NO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT GIVEN
TO ME. THANKFULLY BY THE GRACE
OF GOD I HAD A FRIEND WHO WAS
ABLE. TO ALLOW ME TO STAY WITH
HIM. UNTIL I WAS ABLE TO GET MY
OWN HOUSE AND- UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF THAT TEMPORARY
HOUSING SOLUTION IN THE- PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE CALL WITH ME ON THAT
SAME DAY HAD TO MAKE THE CHOICE
. SEVERAL OF THEM CHOSE. TO USE
JUST ENOUGH DRUGS. TO TEST DIRTY
SO THAT THEY WOULD THEN QUALIFY
FOR THE TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS THAT
WERE AVAILABLE. BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT QUALIFY AND COULD NOT FIND
ANY PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS
SUPPORTS. SO WE'RE THANKFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RYAN FOR TAKING
UP THIS CALLS AND WE ON BEHALF
OF REPACK AND THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN IN
OUR COMMUNITY FACING THIS
PROBLEM S. FORTY FIVE OF. THE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL NOW GO TO-
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE WHO WANT TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION. AND-
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
MANAGER AND I'M SURE AND MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
DANSOMAN ON BEHALF THE REENTRY
PROVIDERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CO SPONSORED THE BILL THANK YOU
SUPPORT. HI MARKETS ALL THE ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT THANKS. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS TO DISCUSS THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ALONG
POVERTY PRODS CO SPONSORED THIS
MEASURE RICHARD I BOOK. AND MARK
STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. A DIFFICULT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
ARE LETTERS LATE BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND IT WILL NOW GO
OPERATOR TO THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU COULD OPEN UP- FOR PEOPLE
REGISTERING SUPPORT. FOR SIMILAR
BRANDS BILL AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO COMMENT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WILL NOW GO TO LINE
HADN'T. GOOD MORNING SASHA HARD
THEN WITH THE INNER CITY LAW
CENTER AND LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING SHARED MEMBERS OTHERS
FROM ALSO WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
PICKING THANK YOU. FINE. FORTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BATTLING COOPER FROM
YELP AND MARK MURDER ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. THE MORNING SHARED MEMBER
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY. BY SEVENTY
ONE. JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY ONE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING SHARON
REPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING I CROWD CO SPONSOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN URGING AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN. UNDERWATER THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU
. LINE FORTY ONE BUT- GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ZACHARY WARM ON BEHALF OF LA
FAMILY HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY. LINE.
ELEVEN THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
ANTI DEFLECTION ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING JASIM
LANCE ON BEHALF OF THE NAY LATER
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY TELL. ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I AM
HOPING FOR THE PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW THE NETWORK CALLING IN.
LINE. THIRTY SIX. ONE THIRTY SIX
SURE LINES NOW OPEN. IN A MOVE
ON TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT.
BERNICIA MEN FROM HOPE HOUSING
AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICE PROVIDER
HOPE SOLUTION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTEEN. MY NAME
IS PHYLLIS THIS IS SYLVIA
CUNNINGHAM FOR THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK AND EAST BAY
HOUSING ORGANIZATION CALLING A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
FIVE. MY NAME IS JESSICA
RICHARDS FROM THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY EIGHT.
MORNING THIS IS PROPER IN VIGO
MEN'S WITH THE RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANKS. LINE. SEVENTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBERS
MY NAME IS ERICA EVAN SAYS WE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY. FRED WILLIAMS
THE ACLU CAL ACTION CALLING AT
THE PORT THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY
SIX. MORNING ADAM TEAR. MY NAME
IS WILLIAM GOODWIN I AM A MEMBER
OF THE RESIDENTS YOU NINETY
NETWORK AND THE RESIDENT
EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM WITH HOPES
SOLUTIONS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIXING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING ON SELENITE WITH THE
RESIDENT UNITED LEXMARK LOS
ANGELES AND CHONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY THREE. I'M TOWARD YOUR
SITE WITH THE RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN.
LINE SIXTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS GERRY MCALEESE SPOKE
FROM THE RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK ORGAN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU
. WINE. FIFTY HI THIS IS DAMIEN
SCOTT FROM THE EAST BAY HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
BILL. MY NAME IS DENNIS MORGAN
I'M FROM BRAZIL UNITED NETWORK
WITH INSURANCE PROVIDERS AND BPO
NETWORK INSTEAD BE ABLE COLLEGE
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. FIND. FIVE MY
NAME IS THANK YOU PLEASANT I'M A
MEMBER OF RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN BILL.
BY THE BILL. GOOD MORNING IN THE
FROM THE RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK COLLEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY SIX. HI
MY NAME IS RONNIE BOYD FROM P.
THREE HOUSES OR ORGANIZATION M.
CALMING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR
MUCH. LINE SIXTY SIX. MY NAME IS
EVERYONE IDEA FROM IS THE HEALTH
ORGANIZATION CENTRUS ENERGY
NINETEEN THEY WERE QUOTING
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
ONE. I'M BERNARD THERE BE A
DILEMMA CALLING FROM THE
RESIDENT AT UNITED NETWORK
CALLING TO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JOYCE ROBIN FROM
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK OF SAN
DIEGO CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTEEN. HI GOOD MORNING
IS JANET THE NUMBER WITH THE
CENTER FOR LIVING AND LEARNING
AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY FOUR. MY NAME IS
WILLIE STEVENS I'M CALLING FROM
EBAY HOUSING ORGANIZATION IN
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK AND I'M
A STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. LINE TWELVE.
MY NAME IS ARGHA BARTON WITH-
THE RESIDENT EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM
WITH POPULATION. READ ARE ALSO
WITH OUR RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE EIGHTY TWO. FORTY NINE WE
SHOULD REMEMBER THAT TIME DONE
SACRAMENTO AND- I'M A STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. SIXTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GILBERT
JOHNSON WAS SIGNED ON AND THE
LOS ANGELES REGION HELD ADVISORY
COLLABORATIVE IN STRON SUPPORT
OF AB SIX THING THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
ALEXANDRA LAND REPRESENTING NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE
EIGHTY FIVE. YES HELLO I'M
CHRISTINA ROBINSON THAT
REPRESENT TIME DONE THEM WITH
COMMUNITY HEALERS AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORT BILL WE ARE THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STANDING
WYNNE AND PERENNIAL KERR LEN
FROM EBAY HELPING ORGANIZATIONS
AND RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LINE FORTY FIVE. LINE FORTY
FIVE LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PATHOLOGY
DOES NOT BE HALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTEEN ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. I. NINETY ONE. HELLO
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS SANDY
MCCASKEY I'M CALLING WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE ADVISORS NINE UNITED
NETWORK RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
AND HE'LL SAN DIEGO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. AND  FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. I'M
SURE WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST
A MOMENT. GOING TO GO TO LINE
FIFTEEN. YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
YES PLEASE RESPOND. MY NAME IS
MRS CILLIERS CUNNINGHAM FROM THE
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK AND
EAST BAY HOUSING ORGANIZATION
CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE
EIGHT ONE SIX THANK YOU. WHY
NINETY TO BUILD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RUBEN ESPINOZA WITH FEDERAL
MONEY ALSO NEEDLES AND KIND AND
DELEGATE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACK MORRISON
ST JOHN'S COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
BLACK WE ENTRY HEALTH ADVISOR
COLLABORATIVE AND I AM SUPPORT
OF AB ONE EIGHT ONE SIX. WINE.
EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO YES SIR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JOHN READY WITH
WHAT EXPERIENCE ADVISORS HILL
NETWORK AND RUN AND I AM CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT THE GAME. AT NINE NINE.
THANK GOODNESS MY NAME IS MARIA
NOT. AND ADEQUATE RUN RESIDENT
UNITED. COURT OF THE. MADAM
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE I PROCEED
LET'S THE ESTABLISH KERR. WEEKS
HERE HERE'S THE RQ CARE ACT IN
YOUR CARILLO. THIRTY A YEAR
GABRIELLE KALRA. FOR HERE KILEY
. QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA HERE
WARD YOUR WORK HERE THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY- WHEN ANY FOLKS IN THE
PUBLIC HERE ONE OF REGISTER ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE GO TO THE MIKE
. ANY OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE
CALL WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER A
POSITION PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION SB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I'M SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK THAT I SENT
HIM MR WARD WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN THE MISTER COLOR. THANK YOU
I'M WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR- BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
OBVIOUSLY- VERY CHALLENGING- BUT
IMPORTANT TO WORK ON- THE
SUBPOPULATION THAT YOU'RE
TARGETING HERE- CRITICAL THAT WE
PROVIDE THIS HOUSING ANY
SERVICES I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE USING AND FOCUSING ON
HOUSING FIRST MODELS THAT WE
KNOW WORK- AND- I WOULD JUST.
RECOMMEND GOING FOR HAPPY TO
MAKE A- MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL-
I'M ALWAYS INTERESTED TO SEE
WHAT THE POTENTIAL IMPACT WOULD
BE I KNOW THIS IS NOT A FUNDING
BILL- BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SAY. IF WE HAVE THIS GRANT
PROGRAM AND IF WE'RE ABLE TO DO
WE KNOW CERTAIN X. MILLION
DOLLARS WE CAN HELP THIS NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS. IN A BENCHMARK
THAT AGAINST YOU KNOW SORT OF
WHAT THE POPULATION IS OUT THERE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE. AND ALSO- IT NEVER NEVER
SKIP A MOMENT TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT- THE COST SAVINGS THAT WE
OTHERWISE WOULD BE SPENDING
ANYWAY- I. ALMOST ARE ABLE TO
PAY FOR THESE IF WE CAN JUST
REALLY SEE THAT MONEY AND GET
THESE PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING SO
THANK YOU FOR READING THIS BILL
I THINK IT'S GOING TO DO A LOT
OF GOOD. HAPPY TO SUPPORT CAME.
I THINK MANAGER AND THANK YOU
SUMMER BRIAN FOR BRING THIS FOR
OUR PROJECT AND AUTHOR. OF THIS
BILL AND THE YEARS THAT I WORKED
AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER- AND AS
MANY PEOPLE KNOW PUBLIC
DEFENDERS YOU OBVIOUSLY ARE
THERE TO. TO REPRESENT. THEIR
CLIENTS AND IN THE COURT BUT- WE
ALSO IN MANY WAYS SOCIAL WORKERS
IN TERMS OF. TRYING TO HELP OUR
CLIENTS. GET BACK UP ON THEIR
FEET AND THE REALITY IS THAT.
HOUSING EVEN BACK THEN WAS WAS
ALWAYS THEM. THE MAIN ISSUE AND
STRUGGLE- THAT THAT SO MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS WITH. WOULD SUFFER
THROUGH- THAT WOULD CAUSE THEM.
TO BE SUBJECT TO PROBATION
VIOLATIONS OR- OTHER. PUNITIVE
MEASURES- BUT WE'RE REALLY JUST.
IT JUST A CONSEQUENCE OF POVERTY
IN NOT. HAVING THE SUPPORT
NECESSARY- WE ARE IN A BETTER
PLACE NOW I THINK WE'RE GOING IN
THE BETTER DIRECTION. OF THANKS
TO LEGISLATION SUGGESTED LIKE
THIS- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO DO. AND I THINK ESPECIALLY
IN. WITH COVE AND- IT'S
EXACERBATED. THE ISSUE- JUST
LAST YEAR I WAS OUTSIDE THE JAIL
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY WITH THE-
A TABLE SET UP ON THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS THERE BECAUSE- WE
DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM LIKE THIS
SET UP- THEY WERE JUST PAYS
ANYONE DOES GET RELEASED AND YOU
HAVE HOUSING. YOU KNOW THE- WITH
WITH THE BUDGET BETTER SOMETHING
IDEA BUT WE'RE OUT THERE. JUSTIN
WHAT CAN WE DO IN THIS URGENT
SITUATION TO. TRY TO FIND A ROOF
OVER THIS PERSON'S HEAD BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW. THEY THEY THEY WERE.
CLOSER TO GET RELEASED. AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE LEFT IN MANY
WAYS TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES AND
GET EXPECTED TO DO SO MANY
THINGS- L. AS A CONDITION OF
THEIR PAROLE OR PROBATION. AND
YOU WANT TO BE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE ALL TO ME NOT ONLY IS
THAT GOOD FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES- IT'S GOOD FOR ALL OF
US IS GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AS
GOOD. AS SOME AWARD INDICATED.
OF IN TERMS OF COSTS. IT COSTS A
LOT LESS- TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
AND OFFER THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. THOSE WHO TO FOLLOW
THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL WHICH
WORKS. IN SO MANY APPLICATIONS
AND IT CERTAINLY WORKS. FOR
THOSE ARE INCARCERATED SO- I'M
VERY GRATEFUL. THAT THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THE SPORT INTO THE
NUMBER OF ORGAN. SHINS AND ALL
THE FOLKS A CALL IN. IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE REALITY THAT JUST THIS
BILL THROUGH- IS JUST. BY IT IS
IT'S REALLY REALLY IT'S A IT'S A
SIGNAL. TO THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY OKAY. ONCE WE GET THIS
THROUGH WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR FUNDING- I WOULD ARGUE
THAT YEAH IT'S GREAT TO GIVE.
MONEY IN REGARDS TO INCREASE
GASKELL GAS PRICES I THINK THAT.
PRETTY MONEY TO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS- IS EQUALLY IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WERE.
ACTUALLY SOLVING PROBLEMS THAT-
I HAD REALLY. BEEN WITH US FOR
DECADES- BUT WE HAVE A PATH OUT
THANKS TO THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU SIR BRENT. ANYONE ELSE OUT
MISTER SADDAM. I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- ONE OF THEM IS HOW DO
YOU PREVENT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
FROM. OVERWHELMING ITSELF IN
OTHER WORDS IT'S MEANT TO HAVE
IT'S MEANT TO BE TAILORED AROUND
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN NEED OF
HOUSING AFTERWARDS HOW DO YOU
WEED OUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
NEED VERSUS THE PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T BATES DECIDE HEY YOU KNOW
WHAT IF I CAN GET TWO YEARS OF
FREE HOUSING. I'M GONNA BE IN
NEED AND THAT HE HAS A TENDENCY
TO DO WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH A
LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE
WITH THAT ARE TAILORED TO HELP
PEOPLE IS IT OVERWHELMS THE
PROGRAM SO HOW DO WE
DIFFERENTIATE THOSE THAT ARE IN
NEED VERSUS THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
YES I THINK THAT'S A THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION- IT AND I THINK
THE GOOD NEWS FOR US IS WE'RE
TARGETING A POPULATION THAT IS
OVERWHELMINGLY AND ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY AND MEET A COMING
HOME FROM CAR SERRATION IN THE
LA TIMES OF SUPPORT EDITORIAL
WITH A HE JUST THIS QUESTION WE
GIVE PEOPLE TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
OF GATE MONEY AND WE SAY GOOD
LUCK- MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED HAD. A HOUSING AND
SECURITY PRIOR TO INCARCERATION
AT FOOD INSECURITY HAD A LIMITED
ECONOMIC MOBILITY- FROM
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY CAME FROM
AND THOSE WERE ONLY EXACERBATED
BY THE TIME THE STATE PRISON
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO HAVE PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND ARE
COMING HOME TO VIRTUALLY
NOTHING. AND AS A RESULT
DISPROPORTIONATE FALL INTO OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION SO I'M NOT A
CONCERNED AT ALL ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM BEING ABUSED BY FOLKS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED FOR YEARS
TO ACTUALLY HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TO COME HOME
TO I THINK A BY TARGETING THIS
POPULATION IN LIFTING FROM THE
BOTTOM- YOU WEED OUT PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT. OTHERWISE NOT BE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND ONE OF THE-
CONCERNS I HAVE ABOUT OUR
APPROACH I MEAN THERE'S
DEFINITELY A SPACE FOR THE-
APPROACH ON THAT SIDE WHEN THEY
GET OUT. BUT WE DON'T SPEND A
LOT OF TIME ON LOOKING AT THE
INCARCERATION SYSTEM ITSELF AND
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE TIME
THAT PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN THEY DO COME
OUT. THEY ARE DRUG FREE THEY
HAVE BEEN REHABILITATED IT FOR
INACTIVE FOR LENGTH OF TIME THAT
WILL TRULY MAKE A DIFFERENCE-
THIRTY DAYS DOES NOT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THIRTY DAYS IS THIRTY
DAYS OF DRY AND THEN GET OUT AND
FIND. WHAT YOU WERE DOING BEFORE
AND THEN THEY GO RIGHT BACK TO
IT- IF WE'RE SPENDING ALL OUR
MONEY ON THIS SIDE AND NOT
SPENDING ANY MONEY ON THE OTHER
SIDE TO REFORM THAT PART OF IT
SO THAT PEOPLE THAT CAN BE
REHABILITATED TRULY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE REHABILITATED
. THEY CAN BE JOB TRAINED. THEY
CAN BE DRUG FREE AND THEY CAN
HAVE A PIPELINE INTO THE
MILLIONS OF JOBS THAT ARE OUT
THERE THEIR ON FIELD. THAT WILL
HELP SUPPORT THEM IN A LESS TIME
THAN WORKERS SAYING THAT THIS
THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM WOULD DO.
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE IF A EIGHT A
MORE BALANCED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. AND
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE BEFORE
THEY GET OUT WHILE THEY'RE DOING
THEIR TIME WHILE THEY'RE SERVING
THEIR TIME. SO THAT WHEN THEY
COME OUT WE DON'T GET STE WE
WERE NOT IN THE SITUATION WHERE
THEY NEED DRUG COUNSELING. MARK
AND ALL THESE AND JOB TRAINING
THEY SHOULD ALREADY HAVE THAT
DONE AND IF WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
THAT'S OUR FAILURE. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY REALLY
NEED TO ADDRESS IT FOR ACTUALLY
GOING TO MAKE AN IMPACT. ON
THESE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WE'RE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO FIND
ENOUGH HOUSING. FOR THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IS OUT THERE. AND A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE ON A-
VOLUNTARY BASIS WILL NOT COME
IN. FOR DRUG TREATMENT. MADE
THEY SIMPLY WILL GO BACK TO
BEING HOMELESS INSTEAD OF NOT
TAKING. YOU KNOW TO NOT HAVING
THEIR DRUGS. SO I HAVE A LOT AND
I MEAN THIS IS A VERY VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE. AND AND SO I
JUST HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT. MORE
MORE PROGRAMS TO TRY TO DO. WORK
ON ONE SIDE WITHOUT TRYING TO
FIX THE OTHER SIDE- SO ANYWAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL IN THERE
THE ATTEMPTS THAT YOU'RE MAKING
TO TRY TO. ADDRESS THE AT LEAST
THE ONE SIDE NO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND THERE IS AN IN REACH
COMPONENT TO OUR BILL TO START
LOOKING FOR SOME THESE HOUSING
MY FOLKS ARE STILL. INCARCERATED
IN AND WERE IN FULL AGREEMENT
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE BEFORE
AND I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S EVEN A
THIRD SIDE. AND THAT'S PRIOR TO
FOLKS EVER BEING INCARCERATED TO
BEGIN WITH RIGHT THERE'S A LOT
WE HAVE TO DO TO BUILD UP OUR
SOCIAL. AND PUBLIC AND CIVIC
INFRASTRUCTURES THAT PEOPLE
DON'T FALL INTO THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM AT ALL- INCLUDING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HOUSING-
IN OTHER STRUCTURES AND SO
THAT'S. DEVON SOMETHING I'D LOVE
TO WORK ON TOGETHER- IN THE LAW
RUN- THANK YOU. I MISSED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANNA COME IN
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES- FROM
MURRIETA WHO'S ADVOCATING FOR
MORE FUNDING FOR REHABILITATION
WITHIN CDC ARE I THINK THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- WHICH
SHOWS THE BIPARTISAN NEED AND
NECESSITY TO ENSURE THAT
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE COMING OUT.
OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM OR A SOFT
AND SAY OUR INJUSTICE SYSTEM UP
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO SUCCEED-
MY DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND IS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GENTRIFYING DISTRICTS
WITHIN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
AND WITHIN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HISTORIC COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF WHOM- MY FRIENDS FROM
HIGH SCHOOL HAD BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM THEMSELVES IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM HIMSELF
COMING BACK OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND NOT ABLE TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO LIVE THERE WHICH ONLY
CREATES MORE ENCAMPMENTS AND
LESS OPPORTUNITIES AND SO I'M
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH A BUDGET
AND THIS PAST YEAR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES WHICH IS A WORLDWIDE
RECOGNIZED ORGANIZATION THAT
DOES. EXACTLY THIS TYPE OF WORK
AS WELL AS AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED CROP WHICH IS CREATING
RESTORATIVE OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROGRAMS WHICH DOES EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE ADVOCATING FOREIGN A AND
YOUR ADVOCATING A MUCH LARGER
SCALE SO I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO IT MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AS WELL AS
GETTING AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN THE
BUDGET. TO INSURE THAT WE MOVE
THIS FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO-
REALLY THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- AND
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON THE
MANTLE OF ARE THE PREVIOUS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE MR CHIU WHO WE
MISS. TERRIBLY AND ON THE IN
THIS BODY- AND JUST YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND YOUR TIRELESS
ADVOCACY IT'S CRITICAL I THINK
THIS IS A PERFECTLY TAILORED
PROGRAM TO HELP IT
CONSTITUENCIES PEOPLE WHO. WE
KNOW NEED THE HELP AND THIS IS
WHAT GOVERNMENT IS FOR IS TO DO
EXACTLY JUST THAT SO. I'D LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR-
AND I KNOW WE HAVE- A MOTION AND
A SECOND- BEFORE WE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THAT THANK YOU WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU AS A CO AUTHOR AND
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS AND
TO THE WITNESSES TESTIFYING
TODAY. WE DO A LOT TO TRY TO GET
FOLKS OFF THE STREETS AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE TO DO MORE-
BEFORE WE HAVE WE GET OFF
THERE'S A HANDFUL THAT FALLS
INTO IT. AND PART OF THE HANDFUL
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN SOCIETY INCLUDING
PEOPLE THAT HAVE PAID THEIR-
THEIR DEBTS TO SOCIETY. AND WHAT
THIS PROGRAM IS LOOKING TO DO
IS. IS TO ALLEVIATE THAT
ALLEVIATE WITH HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IMMOBILITY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS WEEKS.
WICKS I SAY ARE DON'T KNOW. THEY
ARE NO. CARILLO RELY GABRIEL.
KALRA AYE KILEY. QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD MORE TIGHT.
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS GARCIA YOU ARE UP.
OKAY THANK YOU I'LL BE BRIEF AND
LET MY WITNESS FILIN. AB
NINETEEN TEN GIVES US ANOTHER
TOOL KIT ANOTHER TON THERE TO
LOOK AT TO TRY TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING ISSUES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED OVER ONE
POINT THREE MILLION UNITS TO BE
BUILT IN ORDER TO MEET OUR METER
RENO NUMBERS IN HIGHLY DENSE
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF SPACE. LEFT WE HAVE
BROWN FIELDS AND GOLF COURSES
AND SO THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM FOR MUNICIPALLY OWNED
GOLF COURSES FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT WANT TO LOOK AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF CONVERTING THEM
INTO A COMBINATION OF OPEN SPACE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING TOP
ADDRESS TO DIRE NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WILL ALLOW
MY WITNESSES TO. FILL IN THE
REST. THANK YOU YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. HELLO ESTEEMED
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALEX
MELENDREZ AYE AND THE ORGANIZING
MANAGER FOR PENINSULA FOR
EVERYONE AND YOU'LL BE ACTION
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINETEEN NINETEEN TEN
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT MAKE
PUBLICLY OWNED GOLF COURSES
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING AND
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE.
A GOLF COURSE GOLF COURSES A
LARGE PARCELS SO WE CAN
INTEGRATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INTO A LARGER HOUSING AND OPEN
SPACE PLANS TO CREATE NEW
NEIGHBORHOODS IT'S AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE DO NOT GET
WHEN WE TRY TO SQUEEZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON TO
INDIVIDUAL AND FOUR PARCELS THAT
MIGHT BE IN AN INDUSTRIAL AREA
ORNOT NEAR A RESIDENTIAL AREAS
THERE'S A LOT OF PLANNING AN OUT
REACH THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR
COMMUNITIES. ARE AT SOME OF THIS
FUNDING CAN BE USED TO THAT
ACTUAL AVERAGE INCLUDING
RENDERINGS PICTURES OF WHAT IT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE- AND WITH ASK
OURSELVES. HOW ARE WE USING OUR
PUBLIC RESOURCES WE WANT OUR
PUBLIC LANDS TO SUBSIDIZE. AN
EXPENSIVE HOBBY FOR A FEW. OR DO
WE WANT TO PROVIDE NEW HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MANY PEOPLE.
INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SHUT OUT OF HIGH OPPORTUNITY
AREAS WHERE GOLF COURSES
TYPICALLY ARE- THE PROGRAM IS
OPTIONAL EXPE RESPECTS LOCAL
CONTROL OF COUNCILS DON'T WANTS
TO REDEVELOP THEIR- OF GOLF GOLF
COURSES NO PROBLEM. BUT CITIES
AND COUNCILS THAT DO GOLF
COURSES OFFERAN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE NEW
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES A-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S ABOUT AN
OPTIONAL TOOL THAT CITIES CAN
USED TO UNLOCK POTENTIAL NEW
ABANDONED HOMES ON PUBLIC LAND.
REWARDING CITIES WITH POSITIVE
INCENTIVES TO DO SO CAN GO A
LONG WAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU ANY OTHER- WHAT
IS ON THE PHONE OR. FOR THE ROOM
NO OKAY I WILL GO TO A FOLKS IN
THE ROOM A NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MANAGER
MANAGER MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
VERY CREATIVE BILL THANK YOU.
JORDAN PLAN A COROLLA ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT.
TOM DAVID ON THE HAVE A HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT. AN
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU COULD OPEN UP
LANES FOR FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE PRESS
BUTTONS THERE ON YOUR PHONE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT.
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. BUT I MOVE ON TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS ARM CUT
THEM DIRECT THEY POLICY A PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN TEN AND
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EYES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
. PINE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DAVID BARBOZA ON BEHALF
OF ABUNDANT HOUSING LA WERE CUT
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. LINE.
EIGHTY EIGHT. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. DOT.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO CAN PLACE. BERNIE
WOODALL DECLINE SHOULD BY EACH.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT AT PAULA JUDGE
IF YOU COULD START AGAIN PLEASE.
YES THIS IS JOHN BRADY WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE ADVISORS AND
SAN DIEGO AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. MANAGER THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO A PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU KNOW EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. I THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON
WICKS AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICK BAILEY
I SERVICE THE SERVER VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PGA SECTION AND I'M
AUTHORIZED TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR GOLF. I AM ALSO A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE WHO GREW UP
PLAYING THIS BALL GOLF COURSES
WITH MY GRANDPARENTS IN THE BAY
AREA. THE ALLIANCE HAS FILED A
LENGTHY LETTER WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THAT COVERS A NUMBER
OF. NUMBER OF ISSUES BOTH
FACTUAL AND LEGAL AND STRAW IN
STRONG FAVOR OF THIS BILLS
REJECTION. SINGLING OUT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLICLY OWNED GOLF
COURSES FOR SUBSIDIZED
DEVELOPMENT RAISES SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT SETTLED
CALIFORNIA LAW. DEPLETES GREEN
SPACE IN PRECISELY THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALREADY DEEMED PARK
POOR EXCOMMUNICATED OFF FROM THE
PARK AND RECREATION FAMILY FOR
WHICH IT HAS BEEN A PART OF FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS.
PROMISES CAN'T HOUSING AT A VERY
HIGH COST AND DOES ALL OF THIS
PURPOSES ABOUT PUBLIC GOLF IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE FALSE. GOLF
COURSES PROVIDER PRESERVE OPEN
SPACE SEQUESTER CARBON PROVIDE
ALLOW RAIN WATER TO GET INTO THE
GROUND WHERE. GROUNDWATER BASINS
AND IN TIMES OF GLOBAL WARMING
AND RECORD HIGH TEMPERATURES
GOLF COURSES REDUCE TEMPERATURES
IN THE SURROUNDING AREAS.
PUBLICLY ON GOLF COURSES PROVIDE
THESE BENEFITS ALMOST ENTIRELY
IN DENSELY PACKED URBAN
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THEY ARE MOST
NEEDED. CONVERTING THEM TO
HARDSCAPE EXACERBATE EXACERBATES
BOTH PROBLEMS. AB NINETEEN TEN
BECAUSE IT'S CONSIDERABLY MORE
HARM THAN ANY POSSIBLE HOUSING
GOOD. THAT MIGHT COME FROM IT.
CALL HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT OUTLET FOR RECREATION
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
PARTICIPATION CONTINUES TO GROW
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE OF THESE
FACILITIES. PLEASE JOIN
CALIFORNIA'S THREE AND A HALF
MILLION GOLFERS IN REJECTING IT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NIKKI GATCH I AM PRESIDENT OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GOLF
ASSOCIATION A ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF TWELVE
HUNDRED GOLF CLUBS. AND A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS I SPEAK ON
THEIR BEHALF TODAY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB NINETEEN TEN. AB NINETEEN
TEN SINGLES OUT GOLF AMONG ALL
OTHER PARK FUNCTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CONVERSION TO
HOUSING YES MUNICIPAL GOLF
COURSES ARE PARKS AT LEAST SO
SAY CALIFORNIA'S COURTS. AND IT
SINGLES GOLF OUT PROCLAIMS THE
GAME IS IN DECLINE MUNICIPAL
GOLF COURSES ARE SUBSIDIZED AND
ITS USERS ARE SOMEHOW NOT THE
SAME PERSONS WHO USE THE STATE'S
OTHER PARK LAND AMENITIES. THE
NATIONAL GOLF FOUNDATION WHICH
IS FILED A SEPARATE LETTER IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN TEN.
REPORTS THE FOLLOWING MORE
ROUNDS OF GOLF OR PLAYED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAN ANY OTHER
YEAR IN AMERICAN HISTORY. OVER
THREE MILLION PEOPLE TOOK UP THE
SPORT FOR THE FIRST TIME. OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. 37% OF THOSE
PEOPLE WERE FEMALE. AND 31%
PERSONS OF COLOR. 70% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOLF COURSES ARE
PUBLIC 22% OF THEM OWNED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES AND MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF THOSE WHO PLAY GOLF IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE MEDIAN INCOMES
BELOW THE FIFTIETH PERCENTILE.
WITH RESPECT TO SUBSIDIES IT'S
THE OTHER WAY AROUND. MUNICIPAL
GOLF PROGRAM SUBSIDIZED URBAN
PARK BUDGETS TO THE TUNE OF
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND LOS ANGELES. FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES SIX MILLION IN LONG
BEACH AND JUST UNDER TEN MILLION
IN SAN DIEGO ALL WHILE FOR GOING
PUBLIC FUNDING FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS. AB NINETEEN TEN
AIMS AT GOLF BUT IT HITS EVERY
OTHER ACTIVE RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITY BY CREATING A PRECEDENT
FOR PEACE MAILING EVERYONE OF
THEM OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S PARK
FRATERNITY. AND LEAVING THE
STATE'S URBAN AREAS EVEN MORE
PARK POOR THAN THEY ARE NOW.
GIVE THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WHO WISH TO REGISTRADAS
SESSION NAME ORGANIZATION
IMPOSITION PLEASE. HI SUSAN
KIRSCH CATALYST FOR LOCAL
CONTROL OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. JIM PERRIN PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR GOLF STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN TEN
THANK YOU. AN OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD GO TO THE PHONE LINES IF
WE HAVE FOLKS REGISTERING
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN TEN
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES AND
AGAIN JUST NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. CAN I GO TO. WE'RE GONNA
START WITH BLIND THIRTY. REALLY
I CAN'T PRESIDENT OF HARDING
PARK WOMAN CALLS CLOSE STRONGLY
OPPOSED. NINE ONE OH FOUR. OUR
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OPPOSE. LINE ONE OH SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS RICHARD HARRIS
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
GOLF ALLIANCE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NINE FORTY TWO. AND
ARE YOU COULD BE GOLD COAST
GUARD AVIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE GOT THEIR
SECRETIVE BECAUSE HE'S GOT SEVEN
CALIFORNIA INSTRUMENTALIST AB
NINETY TWO. FIND. ONE HUNDRED.
YES MY NAME IS TOM ADDISON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PGA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PJ IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED. TO NINETEEN TEN. LINE
ONE OH SEX. HI MY NAME IS
MATTHEW CARI I AM CALLING FROM
SAN DIEGO I STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B. ONE NINE ZERO. BEIN FIFTY ONE
. ELIZABETH BURKE SORT OF LOS
ANGELES ADOPTED BY THREE
COMMITTEE OPPOSED. TO NINETEEN
TEN. AND A FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE OH
THREE. YES THIS IS RAY LORBER
WITH CATALYST I STRONGLY OPPOSE
A. B. NINETEEN TEN. I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE SHOULD
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DYESS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
THIS QUIRK-SILVA. YES I SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUT I DO WANT TO JUST
GIVE THE SUMMARY AGAIN BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF-
CONCERN WHEN THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES AND AS THE CENTER OF
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
FACILITATE THE CONVERSATION. OF
MELISSA PULLEY BONE GOLF COURSES
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO LET'S
RESTATE WHAT THAT MEANS THAT
MEANS TO HAVE A CONVERSATION THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MEANING THE
CITIES WOULD BE ABLE TO PURSUE
THIS OR NOT PURSUE IT- THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO OPEN IT UP
FOR A CONVERSATION IF THEY'RE-
COUNCIL DOES NOT THINK THIS IS
WORTHY OF A- CONVERSATION. SO
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT FEELS LIKE A
KIND OF LIKE WHY US VERSUS YOUR
LOCAL PUBLIC PARK. THE REASON IS
THAT MANY MANY GOLF PLACES
FULLER TEN HOUSING MINISTER POKE
GOLF UP YOU HAVE TO PAY TO PLAY
YOU DON'T JUST GET TO GO ON TO
THE COURSE AND KIND OF HAVE A
PICNIC WITH YOUR FAMILY- AND
AGAIN THIS DOES NOT MEAN. THERE
THERE ISN'T A GOOD USE. FOR
GOLF- PLACES THERE'S ALSO VERY
PRIVATE PLACES IN MANY CITIES
BUT THIS IS A CONVERSATION THAT
CITY WOULD A TUB PARTAKEN IF
THEY CHOOSE THEY DO NOT NEED TO
. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU. SO I'M GONNA
PROMISES ARE BY PURPOSES WITH
THE- GOLF COURSES A LOT OF
PUBLIC COURSES ARE LONG ALONG
FREEWAY ROUTES OR UNDER AIR THAT
AIR TRAFFIC ROUTES AND THE
REASON THEY'RE THERE IS BECAUSE
THE THAT WAS LANDED A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO MAYBE
DEVELOP BECAUSE OF THE- J.
SENSE- IMPACTS FROM NOISE AND-
AIR POLLUTION ETCETERA.
PREVIOUSLY IT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
IN THIS HOUSE- THE CONCERNS
ABOUT BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- ALONG AREAS THAT ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY IMPACTED IN OUR
EFFORTS TO AND PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE THAT A LOT OF THE
PUBLIC COURSES THAT ARE
ALONGSIDE THE FREEWAYS IN IN
AREAS THAT ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY
IMPACTED- HOW DO WE IMPORTANT
ARE THOSE COMMUNITIES GOING TO
BE EXCLUDED FROM A GRANT
PROGRAM- BASED ON THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE- FOCUS. OR
ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE I HAD A
YEAR- INTERESTED IN THE E. J.
CLEAN AIR OF PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATION BUT I LOVE TO WORK
ON AND I WAS LISTENING TO THEM
AND HOW YOU DID IT DOESN'T MEAN
I'M INTERESTED BECAUSE ACTUALLY
THOSE THOSE THINGS ALONG THE
FREEWAY ARE MORE ACTUALLY
SUITABLE FOR COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WOULD
ELIMINATE A LOT OF THE GREEN
SPACE THAT WE HAVE. SO I'LL LET
YOU ANSWER THAT FIRST AND THEN I
HAVE ANOTHER FOLLOWING AND I
ACTUALLY I LIVE UP OF THOSE
FREEWAYS THAT MOVE ALL THE BITS
OF MANSON TRAFFIC DEFINES MY
LIFE I HAVE SIX FREEWAYS THAT
TOOK MY DISTRICT I DO NOT HAVE A
LOT OF GOLF COURSES ALONG THE
FREEWAY BUT I DO HAVE EIGHT GOLF
COURSES WITHIN A SEVEN MILE
RADIUS OF MY HOUSE FOR A REALLY
IRVINE COMMUNITY. KIND OF THE
ONLY SPACE WE HAVE ½T
THERE SO I WORK ON A REGULAR
BASIS TO CLEAN UP OUR ERROR-
WHETHER THAT'S ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE- CLEAN ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION- MONITORING AND
OTHER WAYS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
OUT THERE ON A REGULAR BASIS FOR
THE CJ COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM IF COMMUNITIES
FEEL THAT THIS IS NOT SUITED FOR
THEM AND WHAT THEY HAVE THERE'S
A BETTER USE THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
USE THIS PROGRAM THIS MAINTAINS
LOCAL CONTROL AND ALLOW THE
COMMUNITY. TO DICTATE HOW BEST
TO YOU SPACES IN THAT COMMUNITY
FEEL THAT IT'S A BETTER USE TO
REPURPOSE UP OF COURSE WE WANT
TO HELP INCENTIVIZE THAT
SPECIALLY FOR CONTRACT CITIES
LIKE THE METHOD I HAVE THAT
DON'T HAVE OFTENTIMES THE
BUDGETS TO PARTAKE THIS UP TO GO
DOWN THIS THIS ROAD ON THEIR OWN
OUT THERE BUT IF THEY DO ARE
THEY GOING TO BE DENIED THAT
OPPORTUNITY. BASED ON THE E. J.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SAYS BASED
ON THE J. THE COMMERCE. OF THE-
WOULD BE HAVING THEIR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS ABOUT A
PROPERTY AT THAT THEY ARE
SUBSIDIZING AND THEY'RE PAYING
FOR THEIR TAX DOLLARS SO. ONE A
ONE OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER TO THAT ONE OF THE-
COMMENTS IT IS ABOUT- THE- THE-
USE OF AN EXPENSE YOU KNOW IT
DOES SOME SOME PEOPLE DO HAVE TO
PAY TO PLAY. AND GOLF COURSES
BUT- I KNOW ONE GUY CHESTER
WASHINGTON A GOLF COURSE DOWN
THERE AND- JUST OUTSIDE OF-
HAWTHORNE. IN SOUTH CENTRAL LA.
HEAVILY USED AND THEY ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF PROGRAMS FOR THE USE
THAT ARE IN THAT COMMUNITY. AND
I FEAR THAT LOSING. SPACE LIKE
THAT FOR THEM. WILL BE IMPACTING
THEIR LIVES BECAUSE IF IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE AT CHESTER- WASHINGTON
AND THAT'S TURNED INTO HOUSING
INSTEAD- THEN THEY'RE NOT GOING-TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE TRAVELING FOR
TEN TO FIFTEEN MILES. HAD TO GO
TO ANOTHER COURSE- TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SO HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
HELP THOSE USE CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT THEY'RE DOING. I WOULD
CONJECTURE THAT THOSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE POLY ACTIVITY- AND
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH THEIR
LOCAL ELECTED- TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR- SPACE AND SAID THIS.
CREATE A PROCESS TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE A- OFFERS
THAT I PASS BY EVERY DAY HAVE
BEEN PASSING BAD ALL MY LIFE
THAT'S GATED- THAT HAS VERY FEW
OF THE USERS AND IT. AND ON A
REGULAR BASIS MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ASKING FOR THAT
SPACE TO PLAY SOCCER- THEY'RE
ASKING VETS BASE TO THINK ABOUT
IT AT AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE
A LOT OF HOUSING INSECURITY IN
MY COMMUNITY AS WELL. THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE ASKING FOR
THAT THE COUNCIL MEMBERS TRYING
TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS. WHEN YOU
HAVE A GENERAL FUND OF NINE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. IT'S
HARD TO PARCEL OUT- THE MONEY
STEVEN BEGIN THAT PROCESS. I'M
AT I'M BEING RESPONSIVE TO THOSE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE OTHER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. LOVE THEIR
GOLF COURSES IN THEIR COFFERS
ARE GONNA STAY THERE BECAUSE
THAT THAT CONVERSATION WITH DICK
LOCAL LIKE THIS IT'S ALSO CLEAR.
THAT THE SENATE ELIMINATE IT
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGES THAT
PURCHASE STATION FOR THE
COMMUNITY. TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
WITH THEIR LIKE THIS ABOUT HOW
TO BEST USE. THE SPACE IN SOME
FOR SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT
THE ONLY SPACE THAT'S LEFT. J.
TRANCERS THANK MISTER KALRA
THANK YOU ADAM SHERIDAN THANK
YOU THE AUTHORITY YOU BEEN LIKE
THE ENERGIZER BUNNY. BUT ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE- AND AGAIN
JUST. I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE ASKED ME WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU'RE NOT THE
WHOLE POINT IS THAT YOU CAN
ANSWER THAT BECAUSE- THIS IS A
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LETTING THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. MAKE THAT DECISION
SOUNDS THAT WE HAVE THREE PUBLIC
GOLF COURSES IN RECENT YEARS THE
COUNCIL HAS HAD THAT
CONVERSATION THEY'VE OPTED TO
KEEP THEM AT THE END OF THE DAY.
TEN YEARS NOW THEY OPTED. NOT
KEEP ONE OF THEM THAT AGAIN WILL
BE A LOCAL CONVERSATION THAT IF
THEY CHOOSE TO GO THAT DIRECTION
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME
IS AN ASSAULT IS A BIGGER CITY
WITH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUDGET
BUT TO YOUR POINT. SOME OF THE
SMALLER JUST I JUST CAN'T EVEN
CAN'T EVEN GO DOWN THAT ROAD
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT WHAT HAVE YOU SO I
THINK THIS REALLY JUST
FACILITATES ALL CONTROL. UP ON
THIS ISSUE IF THERE'S A HEAVILY
USED GOLF COURSE- IN THE
COMMUNITY I THINK THE COMMUNITY
WILL STEP FORTH SO YOU KNOW WHAT
A LOT OF OUR KIDS GO THERE THE
HIGH SCHOOL PROJECT. WHATEVER IT
IS OF COURSE IS NOT BEING USED A
LOT LESS THAN THEY CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THERE'S DEFINITELY WE HAVE SO
COMPLY PRISTINE ALL THAT IN
THERE AND DON'T. THEY THEY MAKE
THE ARGUMENT OF THE CITY COUNCIL
AS TO WHAT THE USE OF THOSE
COURSE SHOULD BE ANNOUNCED LATE
IT SHOULD BE RATIONALLY. BRING
IN THAT CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THAT'S WHAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION IT ISN'T A TOP DOWN
WHAT IT IS THAT LOOK. IF YOU
DECIDE TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION
WILL HELP FACILITATE IT AND WILL
HELP GIVE YOU INCENTIVES TO MOVE
THAT DIRECTION- IF THERE'S OF
COURSE THAT. YEP THERE IS A-
DISTRICT. THEY DON'T TO SPEND
THE- TO FIX IT UP OR- IS NOT.
USED BY THERE'S TWO OR THREE
OTHER ARE BEING HELD. USUALLY
KNOW WE'LL KEEP. AND THIS ON.
ONE THAT'S HAD THAT KIND. SO I
THINK YOU'VE- IN ALL OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS WE MOVE THIS IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION. I UNDERSTAND
THAT MAYBE SOME FOLKS THE GULF
COMMITTEE AWAIT ABOUT A SLIPPERY
SLOPE BUT- THIS IS REALLY JUST
ABOUT. ALLOWING ALL THE OPTIONS
ON THE TABLE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO HAVE
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS FOR
THAT I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
I WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. UP MR GABRIEL I
THINK WHEN HE WANTS TO CLOSE OUR
ANY ANYONE ELSE. ON THAT ICE
OKAY- MY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AGAIN I
SUPPORT IT LAST TIME IT MADE IT
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE- SIXTY.
TO VOTE I BELIEVE- SO HERE WE
ARE AGAIN AND ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WORK I KNOW YOU'RE VERY
COMMITTED TO THAT AND I WAS
DISCUSSED HERE- AND I WILL ALSO
SAY THIS BILL I THINK OF IT.
ALLOWS FOR MORE LOCAL CONTROL SO
I WOULD ASSUME LOCAL CONTROL.
SUPPORTERS WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS BILL- SO I'M HAPPY TO-
HOPEFULLY GET THIS BLOOD
COMMITTEE TODAY- BEFORE WE DO
ROLE I THINK WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND. WE GOT IT. WE DID
OKAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY. WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WICKS
I. SEYARTO NO THE ARSENAL.
CORREO REAL I GABRIEL GABRIEL
CALL. ALL RIGHT HI. QUIRK-SILVA
HI QUIRK-SILVA WARD WARD I THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER SEA
OF. NEXT WE HAVE MISSED YOUR
CURRENT. GOOD MORNING WHAT A MAN
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE LEGISLATION TO SPEED
AFFORDABLE HOME RECONSTRUCTION
IN THE WAKE OF A DECLARED
EMERGENCY CALIFORNIA'S RECENT
NATURAL DISASTERS HAVE
DEVASTATED COMMUNICATE
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVED THROUGH THEM MANY OF WHOM
ARE STILL REBUILDING THEIR HOMES
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD YOU KNOW THE
WILDFIRES OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN DESTROYED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES IN
THE COUNTIES OF BUTTE COLUSA
GLENN LAKE MENDOCINO NAPA SANTA
BARBARA SHASTA CINEMA TRINITY
AND VENTURA. THE DEADLY CAMPFIRE
ALONE DESTROYED THE ENTIRE TOWN
OF PARADISE IN NEARLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES KILLED EIGHTY
FIVE PEOPLE WAS THE DEADLIEST
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. AND
FIVE OF THE SIX BIGGEST FIRES IN
THE TOTAL ACREAGE IN TOTAL
ACREAGE OCCURRED IN TWENTY
TWENTY WITH THE LOSS OF TEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STRUCTURES
MORE THAN THIRTY LIVES AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF DAMAGE.
FEDERAL DISASTER FUNDING
TRADITIONALLY THE MAJOR SOURCE
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR NATURAL
DESERVE DISASTERS IS
INSUFFICIENT AND IT TAKES YEARS
TO OBTAIN. IT TOOK NEARLY TWO
YEARS AFTER THE DISASTROUS FOR
HAD TO SIGN OFF ON ANY OF THE
STATE'S PROPOSALS TO RESPOND TO
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES AND IT WAS FOUR YEARS
BEFORE THE FUNDS WERE DEPLOYED
AS A RESULT RECOVERY HAS BEEN
SLOW AND MOST IN NEED OF HELP.
DO NOT GET IT UNTIL LONG AFTER
THE DISASTER AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE WOULD ETABLISH AN
AFFORDABLE DISASTER HOUSING
REVOLVING DEVELOPMENT AND
ACQUISITION PROGRAM TO FUND THE
PRE DEVELOPMENT EXPENSES
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION RECKON
RECONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION OF PROPERTY TO
DEVELOP OR PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE STATE'S FEDERALLY
DECLARED. DISASTER AREAS THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCE DAMAGE AND LOSS
OF HOMES OCCUPIED BY OR
AFFECTING LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO APPLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING. AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FOR
FUNDING TO MAKE SHORT TERM OR
LOANS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
CONSUMERS. THE FUNDS COULD BE
USED FOR A VARIETY OF HOUSING
RELATED POST DISASTER RECOVERY
EFFORTS INCLUDING ACQUISITION
REHABILITATION AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION. THE SHORT TERM
LOANS WOULD BE REPAID THROUGH
THE FEDERAL DISASTER RECOVERY
FUNDING IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
APPROVED PLAN OF ACTION WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTING THEIR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
R. BRIAN GUSTER RIVER.
CALIFORNIA COLDEST COALITION OF
RURAL HOUSING AND LARRY FLORIN-
CEO AND PRESENT THE BURBANK
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
GO AHEAD GERMAN OF FIVE MINUTES
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU EXCELLENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- YOU.
BRINING US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING AND THE RURAL COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE CORPORATION. WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES ARE
ORGANIZATIONS WORK CLOSELY WITH
THOSE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND
FOR EXAMPLE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPFIRE WHICH THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED- ORGANIZATIONS RCC
THROUGH ITS T. A. M. ROLE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ROMANCES
HERE H. ITS MEMBERS AS PROVIDERS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARE
WORKING CLOSELY ON THE
REBUILDING EFFORT. THEY'RE PART
OF THAT ONGOING EFFORT THE MONEY
THAT WAS APPROVED BY CONGRESS
AND CDBG DR- ALLOCATION SHORTLY
AFTER THAT DISASTER STRUCK IS
JUST NOW ARRIVING SO. THREE PLUS
YEARS LATER WE'RE FINALLY SEEING
THAT MONEY HELP US DELIVER
HOUSING HELP US DELIVER
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE URBAN
INSTITUTE DID A STUDY OF HOW THE
C. B. G. D. R. PROGRAM ROLLS OUT
ACROSS STATES AND FOUND THAT ON
AVERAGE IT TAKES TWENTY MONTHS.
AND FEMA ASSISTANCE USUALLY ENDS
AFTER EIGHTEEN AND OBVIOUSLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE SEEING
EVEN LONGER THAN THAT SO THERE'S
AN ENORMOUS GAP AB FORTY NINETY
FIVE SOLVES THAT PROBLEM CREATES
A REVOLVING LOAN FUND IT'S A
MODEL THAT'S BEING USED IN OTHER
STATES RIGHT NOW. SUCCESSFULLY
AND IT'S ALSO A MODEL THAT WE
HAVE USED SUCCESSFULLY IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE GHOST
ACQUISITION FUN TO WORK WITH
COMEDIC ELEMENTS FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO QUICKLY DEPLOY
RESOURCES THAT NEED TO GET OUT
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THAT'S IT
IT'S A WORKING MODEL THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS WOULD
REPLICATE IT TO DELIVER DISASTER
ASSISTANCE AND WE THINK SOLVE
MANY OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND FOR THAT WE WOULD
URGE AND ABOUT. THANK YOU RYAN
MY NAME IS LARRY FLORIN THE CEO
OF BURBANK HOUSING WE'RE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NONPROFIT
BASED IN SANTA ROSA. WE'VE BUILT
OVER FIVE THOUSAND HOMES IN
SONOMA AND NAPA COUNTIES SINCE
WE WERE FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE FORMER OWNER OF THE
JOURNEY'S END MOBILE HOME PARK.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
NORTH BAY WILDFIRES THE PARK WAS
DEVASTATED BY THE FIRES FOR THE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO TRAILERS.
DESTROYED AND FIVE PEOPLE SHOULD
BE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO TRAILERS
JUST TRY TO FIVE PEOPLE DIED IN
THE FIRES. I'M IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I WAS PART OF A
DELEGATION THAT TRAVELED TO
WASHINGTON TO ADVOCATE FOR
DISASTER RELIEF FUNDING. WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN SECURING A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING FOR THE COUNTIES
IMPACTED BY THE FIRES. IN THE
FORM OF CDBG DISASTER RELIEF
FUNDING THE FIRST TIME I SHOULD
NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVE
SUCH FUNDING. UNFORTUNATELY
LARGELY BECAUSE OF FEDERAL
PROCESS HE'S IT IS TAKEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME TO
ACCESS THE FUNDS. THE PROJECT
HAS THE FULL SUPPORT OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND WENT THROUGH
THE ENTITLEMENT PROCESS IN AN
AMAZINGLY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
FOR SUCH A COMPLICATED PROCESS.
WE ACTUALLY EARLIER THIS YEAR A
LATE LAST YEAR ACTUALLY WITH THE
FIRST PROJECT TO ACCESS THESE
DISASTER RELIEF FUNDS AND CLOSED
ON THE CDBG DR. CONSTRUCTION OF
FUNDING AND STARTED CONSTRUCTION
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR. FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS AFTER THE FIRES
AND TWO YEARS AFTER WE WERE SEE
FULL ENTITLEMENTS OR OTHERWISE
READY TO GO. WITH AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH CONSTRUCTION TIMELINE WILL
BE CLOSE TO SIX YEARS BEFORE THE
RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO MOVE BACK
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY LONG
TIME FOR SOMEONE DISPLACED BY
NATURAL DISASTERS. ACCESS TO
THESE FUNDS WOULD ALLOW US TO
HAVE CUT OVER TWO YEARS OFF THE
PROCESS- I SHOULD ALSO COME INTO
ONE'S PERMANENT FINANCING CAME
THROUGH. IT WILL ALLOW US TO
REPAY WHATEVER FUNDS WOULD HAVE
BEEN. PUT FORWARD FOR THE
PROJECT TO PRE DEVELOPMENT. SO
WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. Q. WE WILL NOW BRING
INTO THE ROOM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION
A POSITION. OR STATUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RACHEL SMITH ALKO SPONSOR WITH
WORLD COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT. TODD DAVID WITH A
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. DEBORAH CARLTON THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR FOLKS
WISHING TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
A BI NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE MIN ZERO. MANY GO TO LINE
NINETY SIX. GOOD MORNING TRACY
RIGHT WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF. COUNTIES
IN THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING JAN THIRTY WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE ADVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU AND DO WE HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
THINK SO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WANT TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION. OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE PHONE WHO JUST
WISH TO REGISTER OPPOSITION FOR
AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THERAPY WAS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THERE IS NO
ONE WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK EIGHT WILL BRING IT
BACK HERE TO THE DYSON MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS. OKAY
DO WE HAVE OVER THE BILL MOTIONS
ASIDE WITH A MOTION A SECOND. I
WANT TO- THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BEFORE YOU HAVE
QUITE THE COALITION OF SUPPORT
HERE AND YOU KNOW OPPOSITION-
WHICH MEANS IT'S PART I KNOW IT
HAS BEEN TO YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY. IN THE SPACE AND WITH
THAT- BEFORE WE DO REAL CULTURE
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST WANT TO SAY
YOU KNOW ON ALL OF US HAVE A
ROOF OVER OUR HEAD AND IT'S SO
DEVASTATING WHEN A FIRE GOES
THROUGH SOMEONE'S HOUSE HOUSE
AND YOU GO THERE AS A- AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF YOUR DISTRICT
AND YOU SIT AND CRY WITH PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES. I'M STILL
SITTING AND CRYING WITH PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL ARE NOT IN THEIR
HOMES FORTY FIVE SIX YEARS FROM
NOW A SINCE THEN SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY ASSEMBLY ASK YOU
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
SEPARATELY CALL THE ROLL. MOTION
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WICKS. HI GUYS
THEY ARE TOO HIGH. HI CORREO.
RELY GABRIEL GABRIEL I CALLED.
ALL RIGHT I KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I WORK FOR TI. THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NEXT WE HAVE MISSED
THREE OF US- YOU KNOW WHAT
ACTUALLY WE'RE GONNA DO THE
CONSENT AGENDA WE HAVE A MOTION
. THIRD GRADE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THANK. THE ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTEEN KING-
MOTION NEEDS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN HUMAN SERVICES
NUMBER- ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY NINETY FOUR ROBERT RIVAS
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WICKS HI WICKS I SEYARTO I DON'T
KNOW WHY CARILLO. RELY GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA. ALL RIGHT KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA NIGHT
WARD WARD HI THANK YOU CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUT AND WE WILL MOVE
ON NOW TO MISS REAVIS. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO START BY THANKING IN THE
CHAIR FOR PROVIDING REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR MY WITNESSES
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM LATER.
AND OF COURSE TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
ANALYSIS. AB TWENTY TWO OH THREE
WILL EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS BY PROHIBITING
HOUSING PROVIDERS FROM REQUIRING
CREDIT CHECKS FOR APPLICANTS
WITH PUBLICLY FUNDED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. THE BILL WILL ALSO
ELIMINATE THE APPLICANT FEES
SUBSIDY HOLDERS. AB TWO WHICH IS
THE FEE IS USED TYPICALLY USED
FOR CREDIT CHECKS. CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE GREAT EFFORTS TO
REDUCING RENTAL ASSISTANT
BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN SB THREE
TWENTY NINE AUTHORED BY FORMER
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL
PROHIBITED HOUSING PROVIDERS
FROM REFUSING. TO RENT TO
SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY USE A
HOUSING SUBSIDY TO AFFORD THEIR
RENT. UNFORTUNATELY RENTAL
APPLICANTS APPLICANTS WITH
HOUSING SUBSIDIES ARE BEING
REJECTED BASED ON POOR CREDIT
HISTORY EVEN THOUGH THE
GOVERNMENT DIRECTLY PAYS FOR ALL
OR MOST OF THE RENT. THE STATE
DOES NOT PROHIBIT A HOUSING
PROVIDER FROM CONDUCTING A
CREDIT CHECK ON AN APPLICANT
USING A HOUSING SUBSIDY NOR DOES
THE STATE PROHIBIT REJECTING AN
APPLICANT BASED ON THE RESULTS
OF THEIR CREDIT CHECK. A RECENT
OP SACBEE ARTICLE CHRONICLED TO
MEL BROWN WHO WAS UNDER HOUSE TO
FOR TEN YEARS BEFORE RECEIVING A
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER OVER THE
COURSE OF FIVE MONTHS BROWN
APPLIED TO OVER THIRTY
APARTMENTS THAT REQUIRED A FORTY
DOLLAR APPLICANT FEE. EACH TIME
SHE IS STILL HOMELESS. HOUSING
PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
HOUSING SUBSIDIES BY REJECTING
THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE SHAKY
CREDIT. TYPICALLY INDIVIDUALS
WHO QUALIFY FOR HOUSING
SUBSIDIES ARE LOW INCOME OR HAVE
LOW OR NO CREDIT AT ALL.
THEREFORE ASSESSING  RENTAL
APPLICANTS ELIGIBILITY THROUGH
CREDIT CHECKS CAN EASILY RESULT
IN AN APPLICATION DENIAL AS
PEOPLE WITH HOUSING SUBSIDIES
OFTEN HAVE LOW CREDIT SCORES
POOR CREDIT OR NO CREDIT HISTORY
. BY ELIMINATING THIS BARRIER
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WITH LOW
OR NO CREDIT CAN ACCESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT A
RISK OF PUTTING UP MONEY FOR THE
APPLICATION FEES JUST TO GET
DENIED. TODAY I HAVE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF STRONGER WOMEN UNITED
CALLIE WRITER AND DEBORAH CRAFT
PROVIDING TESTIMONY STRONGER
WOMEN UNITED OUR COLLECTIVE OF
WOMEN WITH LIVED EXPERTISE AND
HOUSING DISPLACEMENT. DOWNLOAD
AN OPERATOR SORRY THE DURING MY
PHONE IS THAT RIGHT YES YOUR
FIRST FIRST WITNESSES TURNING MY
PHONE OF COURSE. A PARTICULAR
LINE. YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU IF YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIRWOMAN REX ERIN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CALLIE
RATHER I FOUNDING MEMBER OF
STRONGER WINNING UNITED TO
SPONSORED SEARCH YOU AB TWO TWO
OH THREE. STRONGER WOMEN UNITED
AS A COLLECTIVE AND HOUSED AND
FORMERLY AND HAUSMAN AND ALLIES-
I'M LEAVING IN HOUSING JUSTICE
IS GENDER CLASS THAT. WE USE OUR
VOICES AND OUR HARD EARNED
EXPERTISE TO CREATE POSITIVE
CHANGE. FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND I WAS I'M
HOUSE NEAR. TWO FROM YEARS WHILE
WAITING A WHILE ON THE WAITING
LIST FOR THE STANDARD SUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. DURING THIS
TIME I WORKED SPORADICALLY UNTIL
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER I
SURVIVED CANCER TREATMENTS WHILE
LIVING IN CROWDED MASS SHELTERS
MY CREDIT SCORE DROP TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE POINTS WHILE I
WAS ANNOUNCED MOSTLY BECAUSE OF
MY LACK OF INCOME. AFTER TWO AND
A HALF YEARS I REPEAT THE
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
VOUCHER I THOUGHT HOUSING WITHIN
MY REACH HOWEVER I COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN MORE WRONG. HOUSING
PROVIDERS REJECTED MY
APPLICATION EIGHTEEN TIMES IN A
ROW EVEN THOUGH I HAD A VOUCHER
AND HAND. MOST OF THE TIME THE
HOUSING PROVIDERS REJECTED MY
APPLICATION. BECAUSE OF MY LOW
CREDIT SCORE EACH TIME I AM
APPLYING FOR AN APARTMENT MY
HOPES SOARED ONLY TO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE GROUND. I KNEW
THAT I HAD TO USE MY VOUCHER AND
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS OR
LOSE THAT AS IT BECAME OBVIOUS
THAT MY CREDIT HISTORY WAS
PREVENTING ME FROM USING MY
VOUCHER I BECAME INCREASINGLY
DISCOURAGED PARENTS. PANIC
ANXIOUS DEPRESSED AND SCARED I
FEAR THAT THE VOUCHER WAS JUST
ANOTHER BROKEN PROMISE AND I
WOULD REMAIN LESS. WHILE
SEARCHING FOR AN APARTMENT I
SPENT AROUND SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY DOLLARS ON RENTAL
APPLICATIONS I HAD TO CUT DOWN
ON FOOD AND GAS IN ORDER TO PAY
THOSE FEES AND I WAS LUCKY. NOT
EVERYONE CAN AFFORD THAT. AB TWO
OH TWO WOULD BE THE BARRIER
FIRST. SUPPORT HOUSING. FOR
THESE THREE STRUGGLED UNITE-
YOUR OF ON THIS CRUCIAL THEY'LL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DRIVEN
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESS. YES I
BELIEVE WE DO MADAM CHAIR JUST A
MOMENT. DEBORAH CRAFTED PARDON
ME JUST A MOMENT. CRAP YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. OKAY HI GOOD
MORNING CHAIRWOMAN WALKS.
MEMBERS I AM DEBORAH CRAFT A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF STRONG WOMEN
UNITED. COOPER AND EIGHTY TWO
TWO ZERO THREE. I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU AFTER TO STICK-
THAT IS THE LARGEST DATA THAT WE
COULD FIND. REGARDING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. 65% APPROXIMATELY 65%
OF WOMEN BECOME AND HOW DO YOU
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I WAS ONE
OF THESE WOMEN. I HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO CREATE MY VIOLATE
PARTNERS HOUSE WITH NOWHERE TO
GO I HAD TO LEAVE OUR HOME
QUICKLY WITH ONLY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. BEHIND HIDDEN AWAY AND
ZERO CREDIT. ACTIVITY YOUR OWN
PERMANENTLY DISABLED WOMAN I HAD
TO RESTART MY ENTIRE LIFE. JUST
TO SAVE MY LIFE. MY AND- WITH
ABUSED. AND WITH NOTHING BUT
BECOMING MY BACK HE HAD RUINED
MY CREDIT DURING MY TRAINING.
AND I'D SPENT OVER YEARS BEING
AN EXCELLENT TENANT PAYING MY
BILLS ON TIME AND I HAD LEFT
EVERY HOME THAT I'D EVER LIVED
IN. BETTER THAN I HAD FOUND IT.
THAT IS WHO I REALLY AM BUT MY
CREDIT SCORE DOES NOT CLEARLY
REFLECT THAT. AFTER LEAVING MY
ABUSIVE PARTNER. I LIVED IN MY
CAR AND YOU JUMP YOUR FAR LEFT
SEVEN YEARS. I WAS WAITING FOR
THE PROMISE OF- THE GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING. I DIDN'T
KNOW AFTER FINALLY RECEIVING MY
VOUCHER THAT LANDLORDS WITH STAN
. HE SCRUTINIZING ITS CREAMY
BASED ONLY ON MY CREDIT HISTORY
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I AM A MUCH
BETTER FINANCIAL RISK AND MY
FUTURE NEIGHBORS WHOSE RANKING
NOT BACKED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. I BELIEVE IN A
SUBSIDY AND THE PROMISE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EIGHTY TWO
TWO ZERO THREE WITH ELIMINATE
THIS BARRIER FOR AND HOW CAN
HOUSING INSECURE PEOPLE IT WOULD
ALLOW A FOLLOW THROUGH OF THE
PROMISE TO FINALLY OBTAIN
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITHOUT UNFAIR AND ARBITRARY.
SCREENING CRITERIA. EIGHT TWO
TWO WOULD ALSO ALLOW. TO PROCESS
ITS FOR SCHOOL SOLVE- PULL. THEY
CONTINUE TO KEEP. BONOBO ON HOW
MUCH PEOPLE. AND HOW. PLEASE
STOP WASTING PRESSURE VOUCHER
AND KEEP THE WHOLE FACE
DESPERATELY NEED. PLEASE DO THE
RIGHT THING AND VOTE I ON THIS
VERY AND THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION FOR SUPPORT AND I'M
SURE AMERICA RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THEAIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IS HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. SKINNER IS ALWAYS
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. ON A LAWLER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND THE NATIONAL
HOUSING LAW PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
TODD DAVID OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOT GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE PHONE WHO WISH TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO ZERO THREE. THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SHERIN
REPORT WHICH A CORPORATION TRIPS
PROPOSING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE. ONE OH NINE. ONE ONE OH
NINE YOU'RE GOING TO SNOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING JOHN BRADY
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE ADVISORS
AND SUPPORT. LINE. ONE ELEVEN.
ONE ONE ELEVEN YOUR MIND IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S RICHARD
GALLO I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT. HELLO AS A FORMER
ADVOCATE AND HOUSING HELPING
SENIORS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
VETERANS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. I HAVE
SEEN THE HARDSHIP ON THE- BLIND
LEADING ONE. I WOULD THINK THAT
THE ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. EMPIRE ME ONE LAST
TIME ONE EIGHTY ONE THE LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ONE ONE FOURTEEN. ONE
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN. MY NAME IS
TRENCHING ANDRADE HALF SUPPORT.
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN. MY NAME IS NADIA AT
THAT LAST. I DON AND AFFORDABLE
AND HOW WAS THE LEADING AND I
BELONG TO BASED ON THEIR WARMIND
UNITED A LONG IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO OR. THREE VERY A FAMILY.
MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE OUT
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU AND WILL BRING
IT BACK HERE TO THE ROOM- WE
HAVE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
GOOD WHATEVER I'M KAREN MEMBERS
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AFTER TWO
YEARS- DEBRA CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. TO THE
LEGISLATION THERE MAY BE SOME
OTHER ANSWERS HERE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- WE OBJECT TO A-
APPS MAKING A LANDLORD HAVE TO
BLINDLY ACCEPT AN INDIVIDUAL
WHAT THE SIDE EFFECTS WILL BE
HERE. IS THAT IF YOU CANNOT USE
A CREDIT CHECK A RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER WILL REQUIRE EXTENSIVE
DOCUMENTATION- THEY WILL
PROBABLY REQUIRE BANK RECORDS
TAX RECORDS CREDIT CARDS YOU
NAME IT THEY'RE REQUIRE IT
PERHAPS EVEN A- INDIVIDUAL TO
GUARANTOR WHICH IS A POSITIVE
THING IN THESE CASES TO ENSURE
THAT SOMEBODY CAN GET HOUSING.
REMEMBER ALSO THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE. PASSED RENT OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS- REPORTED TO
CREATE REPORTS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LAW THAT SAYS THAT WILL NOT
APPEAR ON THE ON THE CREDIT
REPORT- YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S AT
SENATORS STEVE RADFORD HAD A
PRAGMATIC APPROACH WE BELIEVE
WITH S. B. O. ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND THAT LAW REQUIRES. THAT
LANDLORDS OF ASSISTING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS OFFER TENANTS THE
OPTION TO HAVE THEIR RENT
REPORTED- YOU TO THEIR THEIR
POSITIVE RENT REPORTED TO CREDIT
AGENCIES AND THEN THERE'S ALSO-
BENEFICIAL SERVICES TODAY THAT
HELP INDIVIDUALS BUILD THEIR
CREDIT REPORTS. SUCH AS EXPERIAN
BOOST- FIGHT COKE I CHIME CREDIT
REPAIR AND ALL THOSE OTHER
EXAMPLES ARE OUT THERE I THINK
TO HELP INDIVIDUALS BUILD THEIR
CREDIT WE ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND
AND- AND HEARD THE OPPOSITION.
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE ALSO TO FIND SOME
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS. BUT WE
DON'T SEE THAT RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS WILL BLINDLY- HAND OVER
HOUSING I'M WITHOUT ADDED
DOCUMENTATIONS IF THEY CAN'T
OBJECTIVELY LOOK AT A CREDIT
REPORT SO FOR THOSE REASONS. WE
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR FOLKS WISHING TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
TWO OH THREE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WHEN YOU GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTEEN. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS KATE BELLAMY HAPPY
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. LINE
SEVEN DAY. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR PAT MORAN WITH THERE AND
READ THE SOCIUS REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS WYSOCKI AND BEHALF OF
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. BLIGNAUT. NINE GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DICE MR GABRIEL. I THINK YOU ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND I APPRECIATE THE COURTESY I
WOULD HAVE TO STEP OUT A MOMENT
FOR. A PHONE CALL I'D AND I WANT
TO. THANK THE OTHER FOR THE BILL
I HAD A FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT IT
AND AS I SHARED WITH HER M. I'M
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT WITH THE
BILL I HAVE A I HAVE AN AUTHOR
PROBLEM HERE WHICH IS THAT I
REALLY RESPECT AND ADMIRE THE
AUTHOR. AND THINK THAT SHE DOES
A LOT OF WONDERFUL PUBLIC POLICY
PARTICULAR IN THIS AREA YOU'VE
BEEN A REAL LEADER IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON THIS- BUT I AM SO
YOU KNOW I DUG INTO THE ANALYSIS
IN THERE SOME PARTS OF THIS THAT
I THINK MAYBE THEY'RESTRUGGLING
TO UNDERSTAND- OR OR OR I'M NOT
SURE THAT I'M FULLY COMFORTABLE
WITH AND SO I'M JUST GOING TO
LAY IT OUT THERE AND WOULD LOVE.
FOR YOU TO RESPOND TO AND THEN
MAYBE IF- PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WHEN THIS WANTS TO CHIME IN AS
WELL- SO BE A FIRST I THINK IF
YOU SEE IT ON A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE HERE WHICH IS THAT IT'S
WAY TOO HARD FOR FOLKS TO GET
VOUCHERS AND TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- AND I DON'T REALLY
THINK THAT THAT'S A CONTESTED
ISSUE. I'M WHAT I'M WONDERING
WITH IS A COUPLE THINGS HERE I'M
AND ONE IS MAYBE JUST TO MAKE
SURE I'M UNDERSTANDING TO ME.
THIS ISN'T AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF THIS REALLY
REINFORCES SOURCE OF INCOME
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORK THAT
WE DID WITH SENATOR MITCHELL'S
BELL BECAUSE TO ME THIS IS
ABOUT. IF IT'S ALL OF THE
UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE OUR FOLKS ARE
RECEIVING VOUCHERS WERE REALLY
PICKING BETWEEN CHU CHU LOW
INCOME FOLKS HERE RIGHT IT'S NOT
THAT WE'RE DISCRIMINATING IN
FAVOR AGAINST A LOW INCOME
PERSON IN FAVOR OF A HIGH INCOME
PERSON WE'RE TALKING THE
UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE HERE. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS LOW INCOME
FOLKS ONE OF MY MISS
UNDERSTANDING THAT. YEAH THIS
BILL. ALL APPLY. TO INDIVIDUALS
THAT. HAVE A HOUSING VOUCHER OF
PUBLICLY FUNDED HOUSING VOUCHER.
I'M THEY CAN BE APPLYING. FOR A
HOUSING UNIT. AND IT COULD BE
SOMEONE LIKE ME ALSO APPLYING
FOR THAT SAME HOUSING UNIT.
RIGHT IT'S NOT LIKE. THAT
HOUSING UNIT. HASN'T ALL. OF
PUBLICLY. FUNDED VOUCHER
RECIPIENTS. APPLYING FOR THE
SAME UNIT. AND SO IN THAT
SITUATION THEY'D BE ABLE TO ASK
THE- AND THE PERSON WITHOUT THE
VOUCHER FOR CREDIT SCORE THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO ASK THE
PERSON WITH THE HOUSING ABOUT.
OKAY I GUESS WHAT I'M WONDERING
ABOUT THAT IS THAT ARE WE
INADVERTENTLY- MAKING IT HARDER
FOR THAT PERSON TO GET THE UNIT
AND I YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW ARE WE GONNA
MAKE THE LANDLORD MORE RELUCTANT
TO ACTUALLY LEASED TO A PERSON.
WHO IS LOW INCOME IN WHO HAS THE
VOUCHER BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO SEE THE CREDIT
SCORE. END OF ALTERNATIVELY ARE
WE JUST SORT OF REPLACING ONE
BARRIER WITH ANOTHER I MEAN I
WAS READING IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT THAT THEY'LL ASK FOLKS FOR
TAX RECORDS AND BANK RECORDS AND
EMPLOYMENT RECORDS AND THOSE. AT
LEAST AS I THINK ABOUT IT AND
I'M OPEN TO BEING PERSUADED
OTHERWISE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
COULD TAKE A LONG TIME TO GO
COLLECT RIGHT IF YOU HAVE TO GO
TO YOUR EMPLOYER AND ASK FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS WORTH OF- PAY
STUBS IF YOU HAVE TO GO TO YOUR
BANK CAN GET BANK STATEMENTS IF
YOU HAVE TO GO. AND PICK UP YOUR
TAX RECORDS OR WHATEVER IT MAY
BE- I THINK THOSE COULD
POTENTIALLY POSE BERRIES AND YOU
KNOW WHAT I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WE HAVE CREDIT
SCORES RIGHT AS ITS- AGGREGATES
ALL THAT INFORMATION QUICKLY SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF YOU COULD.
SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE PART OF OUR-
OF REQUIRING A CREDIT CHECK
THERE'S ALWAYS A FEAT THAT GOES
TOWARD- GETTING THE CREDIT
REPORT- AS I SAID IN MY-
STATEMENT. BOB THESE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE APPLYING
SOMETIMES IT'S USED TYPICALLY
FORTY TO FIFTY DOLLARS FOR A
CREDIT CHECK. AND THEY'RE
APPLYING FOR MULTIPLE- RENTAL
UNITS RIGHT AND THERE THEY GET
REJECTED FROM ALL OF THEM
SPENDING FIVE TO SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND SO. THIS IS NOT ONLY
A BARRIER TO FOR THEM TO GET
THE GOVERNMENT
RIGHT IF SOMEONE HAS A HOUSING
SUBSIDY THE LANDLORD KNOWS
THEY'RE GOING TO GET PAID. RIGHT
AND SO WHY ARE WE PUTTING THIS
BARRIER THERE RIGHT THE OTHER-
ITEMS THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT
WILL BE COLLECTED IT DOESN'T
COST. ANYTHING TO COLLECT THAT
SHOW IS SO THEN THE CREDIT CHECK
I CAN'T I CAN'T YOU CAN'T
PROVIDE A CREDIT CHECK IF THE
LANDLORD HAS TO PAY A SERVER S.
TWO. TO COLLECT THAT CREDIT
REPORT. DOWN TO THE NEW ISSUE
HERE I GUESS I'M UNDERSTANDING
IS IT'S LESS THE INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THE CREDIT REPORT
IT'S MORE THE FEE. TO RUN THE
CREDIT REPORT. I THINK IT'S BOTH
OKAY. AND ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE.
THAT HAVE LITTLE TO NO CREDIT
HISTORY RIGHT THEY CAN BE PAYING
FOR A CREDIT REPORT. AND IT
COMES BACK WITH VERY LITTLE. UP
CREDIT HISTORY- I KNOW YOU KNOW
MY FAMILY. DIDN'T GET A CREDIT
CARD UNTIL I WAS A TEENAGER.
RIGHT ON I AM. VERY GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAD PLACE TO LIVE- WHEN
I WAS A KID. BUT YOU KNOW
SOMEONE LIKE MY MOM WHICH WAS A
SINGLE MOTHER. DIDN'T HAVE
CREDIT CREDIT HISTORY SO
COULDN'T APPLY. FOR AN APARTMENT
UNIT RIGHT WE HAD TO RELY. ON
HOMES WHERE THEY WERE RENT TÍNH
AND- EIGHTY YOU IN THE BACK
RIGHT WHERE. THE LANDLORD WAS
LESS LIKELY TO. REQUIRE A CREDIT
REPORT. ARE YOU KNOW LIKE ARE
THE OPPOSITION MENTIONED- THE
BRADFORD BUILD THE SENATE BILL
THAT. WOULD HAVE ALLOWED SOMEONE
WITH LITTLE TO NO CREDIT. TO
OUR- INCLUDE THESE THESE RENT
PAYMENTS AS PART OF THEIR CREDIT
STRUM. I'M IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE CREDIT
YOU'LL NEVER HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. RIGHT IF YOU CAN
GET INTO A UNIT. BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NO CREDIT. ANNUAL YOU'RE
HAVING TO PAY THESE FEES YOU'LL
NEVER HAVE. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD A CREDIT HISTORY- VIA YEAR
OLD. RENTAL PAYMENTS MADE ON
TIME. I KNOW THE YOU YOU BEEN A
LEE. IN YOU KNOW PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS KEEPING PEOPLE
HOUSED- IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THIS IS ONE WAY TO DO IT
IT'S NOT THE ONLY WAY. RIGHT
IT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE ALL OF
OUR ISSUES ON HOMELESSNESS BUT-
WE'RE SPENDING. OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND A UNIT. YOU
KNOW FOR HOMELESS TO FOR UNITS
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
HEAR PEOPLE THAT. QUALIFIED FOR
VOUCHER. WANT TO RENT A UNIT AND
ARE NOT AND THERE'S A BARRIERS
TO GETTING MEN. ARE I WOULD
RATHER THEM GET IN AND THAT WAY
IT SAVES US FUNDS FOR OTHERS YOU
KNOW AND IT KEEPS THEM HOUSE
STE. YEAH NO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK THE INTENTIONS HERE
ARE ARE TOTALLY SPOT ON I AM I
THINK I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AS I SAID IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE- I'M JUST
TRYING TO. GREAT GRAPPLE WITH
THE FACT ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS-
WHAT I THINK THE BEST WAY TO GET
AT THAT ISSUE IS CAN I ASK MADAM
CHAIR A QUESTION OF THE
OPPOSITION- SO- HOME. GIVE HER A
MOMENT TO MAKE HER WAY UP HERE-
ET I I'D HER JUNIOR TESTIMONY
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE- AB
WITH SOME SYMPATHY TO WHAT THE
AUTHOR WAS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE AND THERE MIGHT E OTHER
WAYS TO GET OUT THIS AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU REFERRING TO.
THE FEE OF THE CREDIT CHECK
OTHER INFORMATION SO I'M JUST
WONDERING YOU KNOW TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT A LITTLE BIT WHAT ARE
SOME OTHER WAYS THAT YOU THINK
MAYBE. WE COULD ACCOMPLISH SOME
OF THESE OBJECTIVES CERTAINLY
WELL WE KNOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT PAY ALL OF YOUR RENT
DOESN'T PAY YOUR BILLS EXCEPT
TRACK- THERE COULD BE A FUNDING
PROGRAM TO HELP- WITH THE
ACCUMULATION OF THE CREDIT
REPORT THERE'S THIRD PARTY CIVIL
HOW'S YOUR CREDIT REPORT- ON AN
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM- I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING WITH A SOME MEMBER WARD
ABOUT OPTIONS LIKE THAT. SO THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY EVERY
SINGLE TIME BUT THAT ONLY SOLVED
PART OF YOUR ISSUE RIGHT I THINK
THE I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON WHEN
YOU INDICATED THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO COLLECT ALL THIS
DATA IF THEY CAN'T- THEIR CREDIT
REPORT IS NOT AVAILABLE- AND BY
THEN THE- THE UNITS RENTED. SO I
THINK THAT THAT IS A BARRIER SO
I THINK WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAYS OF IT'S JUST
ABOUT I THINK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REDUCE ADULTS ABOUT TWO THINGS
IT'S THE COST OF THE CREDIT
REPORT- AND IT'S ABOUT THE
CREDIT SCORE NOW IN TALKING WITH
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THEY SAY
THE CREDIT SCORE IS NOT THE ONLY
THING THEY USE. THEY USE
EVERYTHING- DURING THE LAST
FORECLOSURE CRISIS EVERYBODY
BECAME SEEM LIKE EVERYBODY THAT
CAME TO APPLY HOW TO FOR CLOSURE
ON THE RECORD SO LANDLORDS
SHOULD STOP USING THAT SCORE
IT'S JUST NOT A SCORE THAT IS
NECESSARILY DEPENDABLE ANYMORE.
SO THEY HAD TOLD ME THAT THEY
DON'T USE JUST THE CREDIT SCORE
BUT A LOT OF OTHER INFORMATION.
LANDLORDS CAN ASK FOR BANK
RECORDS. AT FOR ANY OF US BUT-
FINE. YOU KNOW I. RECENTLY
APPLIED FOR A UNIT AND I HAD TO
SUBMIT. RECORDS THAT DID TAKE ME
AWHILE TO COLLECT RIGHT IN OF IT
YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T MEAN BECAUSE
AND THEY OF COURSE I HAD TO PAY
A FEE FOR A CREDIT SCORE- BUT
THIS THIS BILL IS VERY NARROW
IT'S ONLY FOR THOSE. THAT HAVE A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY RIGHT IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW I DON'T AGREE THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD NOT GET YOU KNOW
SHOULD NOT PAY FOR A CREDIT
REPORT- ONLY FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE. THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
VOUCHERS YEAH NO THANK YOU
THAT'S HELPFUL I WILL TELL YOU
PART OF WHAT GOT ME THINK ABOUT
THIS AS CANDIDLY AS YOU KNOW WE
JUST REFINANCED OUR HOME IT WAS
SUCH A PAIN IN THE **** TO GO
AROUND AND COLLECT ALL THE
DIFFERENT DOCUMENTS MANY TOOK
US. SO MANY DAYS TO JUST GOT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PLACES YOU
FORGET YOUR PASSWORD YOU GOT TO
RESET YOUR PASSWORD AND LOG ON
AND PULL THAT DOCUMENT- YOU KNOW
REALLY IT REALLY STIMULATED MY
THINKING ABOUT. THE KIND OF
BARRIERS THAT WE MIGHT SET UP SO
I APPRECIATE THE INTENT.
APPRECIATE WHAT I HEARD FROM YOU
I THINK THERE- I'M VERY
INTRIGUED BY WHAT YOU MENTION I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
MEMBER WHITE HOUSE THAT BILL
BUT- RUNNING SO MUCH CREDIT
CHECK ONCE AND THEN HAVING THAT
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO KEEP PAYING
THE FORTY DOLLARS FEE OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN BECAUSE
THAT. THAT DID CATCH MY
ATTENTION AS A REAL ISSUE FOR
LOW INCOME FOLKS WHO ARE
SEARCHING FOR SOMEWHERE TO USE
THIS VOUCHER. AND ALMOST LIKE
TEASING THEM BY SAYING HERE'S A
VOUCHER AND THEN THEY CAN'T. YOU
KNOW THE CAN'T GET A PLACE TO
LIVE SO- APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS ON BOTH SIDES. AND IF
YOU ALREADY COLLECTED. YOUR
RECORDS FOR THE FIRST
APPLICATION. BY THE TENTH ONE
YOU ALREADY HAVE THEM. SO THAT
TIME THAT YOU'RESAYING IS A
BARRIER. RIGHT YOU ALREADY HAVE
COLLECTED ALL OF THEM. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISS
CARILLO AND THEN MISSED
QUIRK-SILVA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL
I THINK WOULD- MY COLLEAGUE ALSO
BRINGS UP IN TERMS OF.
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING- A CREDIT SCORES FROM
OR YOUR BILL FOR POTENTIALLY
NOT- REQUESTING. AS COURSE FROM
REALLY IT'S REALLY AN ISSUE IT'S
A PIVOTING OF TRYING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN US VERSUS
THEM THERE'S NOT ENOUGH ALREADY.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED I THINK
EVEN A MINUTE THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS THAT THE
SYSTEMS THAT WERE IN PLACE
BEFORE DIDN'T WORK. AND SO WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT YOU HAVE I
THINK YOU KNOW SAID IT REALLY
WELL IN TERMS OF. INDIVIDUALS
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CREDIT
WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE IN A CYCLE
OF POVERTY BECAUSE THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY THERE THE BARRIERS
OF ENTRY ARE VERY HIGH. AND SO
THEN HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT AND
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON ISSUES RELATED TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS ON THE
PREVENTION SIDE NOT FOR FOLKS
THAT ARE ALREADY EXPERIENCING
THAT BUT HOW DO WE MAKE IT
EASIER FOR SOMEBODY TO HAVE AXES
. HOW TO A RENTAL UNIT AND I
THINK THAT ULTIMATELY IS THE
HEART OF YOUR BILL. AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IN
TERMS OF. COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE THOSE
COUNTRIES- THOSE ACCESS TO ENTRY
AS EASILY AS IT IS AVAILABLE.
AND EVEN MORE SO YOUNG PEOPLE
GET CAUGHT UP WITHOUT CREDIT
CARDS WHEN THEY FIRST ENTER A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SETTING I
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS AT EAST LA
COLLEGE. THE FIRST THING THAT I
ENCOUNTER WITH SOMEONE TRYING TO
GET ME TO GET A VISA AND BEFORE
I. BEFORE I EVEN KNEW IT I WAS
ALREADY AND THAT. AND SO BY.
NINETEEN MY CREDIT SCORE BECAUSE
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
CREDIT AND FINANCIAL LITERACY
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS
AVAILABLE IN MY COMMUNITY. I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE IMPACT OF
ALL OF THAT MEANT TO MY FUTURE
AND MY ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO-
RENT AN APARTMENT AT CETERA AND
IT TOOK SOME TIME- TO LIKE
REBUILD MY CREDIT. SO YEAH I
THINK WHAT IT THE CONVERSATIONS
AROUND FINANCIAL LITERACY AROUND
EQUITY AROUND RESOURCES AROUND.
US SYSTEMS THAT DON'T THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY EQUAL TO ALL.
IS A LARGER CONVERSATION- IN
TERMS OF HOW WE PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD. AND HOW ULTIMATELY WE
HELP FAMILIES IT'S NOT. AN END
ALL BE ALL LIKE A CREDIT SCORE
IS A REFLECTION OF A OF A STAMP
IN SOMEONE'S LIFE IT IS NOT A
REFLECTION OF THEIR WHOLE LIFE.
BUT WE USE THESE REPORTS TO KIND
OF PAINT A PICTURE WHETHER IT'S
GOOD OR BAD OR IN BETWEEN. AND
ULTIMATELY THERE ARE FAMILIES
OUT THERE STRUGGLING THAT SIMPLY
NEED AN OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK
AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT'S
WHAT WE HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH. AND
GOVERNMENT SO JUST WANTED TO
STATE THAT FOR THE RECORD I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU. MISS QUIRK-SILVA-
AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I
KNOW YOU'RE WORKING IN THE
SPACE- QUITE A BIT THIS BILL
DOES BRING UP A LITTLE BIT OF-
MIXED FEELINGS BECAUSE ON THE
ONE HAND OF COURSE I WANT TO SEE
PEOPLE AND THIS BEST THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP THAT ALREADY
HAS IF YOU WANT TO SAY ABOUT
YOUR IN THEIR HAND I WOULD NOTE
THAT SOMEBODY THAT ACTUALLY GETS
INTO A VOUCHER IN THEIR HAND-
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A- MANY
TIMES YEARS OF BEING ON A LIST
TO GET THIS PARTICULAR VOUCHER.
AND VETTING IT'S NOT LIKE YOU GO
TO SOCIAL SERVICES AND THEY'RE
JUST HANDING THEM OUT NO THERE
IS A VERY LENGTHY PROCESS BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND IN THIS IS WHERE
I MEAN SOMETIMES WE'RE WE'RE
DOING THIS AT THE DIETS BUT
SOMETIMES THERE THERE ARE THE
UNINTENDED QUAN CONSEQUENCES IN
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- YOU
MENTIONED- WHICH IS IF THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE A CREDIT.
REPORT THEY'RE GOING TO USE
SOMETHING ELSE. AND IS THAT IN
TURN GOING TO BE THE SAME
BARRIER WHICH IS WE KNOW IF YOU
PULL A BANKING RECORDS FROM
SOMEBODY WHO'S REALLY IN A
VULNERABLE POPULATION THEY MAY
NOT EVEN USE A TRADITIONAL
BANKS. WE KNOW THAT THEY MAY
NOT- HAVE A CREDIT AS WE SAID
CREDIT CARDS. BECAUSE THEY MAY
BE MONTH TO MONTH HAVING
LITERALLY AS WE KNOW SOME FOLKS.
THAT AREN'T DISABILITY THEY
LITERALLY GET ELEVEN HUNDRED TO
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS MAYBE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED- A MONTH. AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
THOUSAND DOLLAR SAVINGS SO THIS
IS REALLY KIND OF A PUSH AND
PULL BETWEEN PROTECTING THE
INVESTORS. WHO ARE WHETHER
THEY'RE- SMALL INVESTORS ARE
LARGER INVESTORS. APARTMENT
RENTALS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SOME TYPE OF
PROTECTION BUT ALSO GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY- FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO HAVE A
VOUCHER NEED TO USE IT AND I
WILL DID WAS VERY STRUCK BY
THAT. A REPORT FROM THE SIDE
BELIEVE IT WAS A SACRAMENTO BEE-
THAT CAME OUT MAYBE A MONTH AGO
ABOUT THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO
LITERALLY HAS A VOUCHER IN THEIR
HAND AND CANNOT USE IT IN
REMAINS HOMELESS AND THAT'S ONE
STORY. SO I'M DOING A LOT OF
SPEAKING HERE BUT IT IS A
CONFLICT BETWEEN TWO. TWO
EMERGING GROUPS AND HOW DO YOU
BALANCE THAT SO I AM. LISTENING
TO THE TESTIMONY I'LL KEEP
LISTENING AND- YOU KNOW BUT IT'S
A DIFFICULT DECISION FOR THOSE
OF US WHO ARE IN THE SPACE
WANTING TO SEE PEOPLE HOUSED.
BUT ALSO KNOWING THE REALITIES
THAT IF ONE GROUP- IS GOING TO
LET SOMEBODY INTO THAT UNIT AND
THEY CAN'T USE A CREDIT REPORT
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND ANOTHER
WAY IN IS THAT GOING TO MAKE IT
EVEN HARDER. NO I AGREE WITH
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA- BUT RIGHT NOW.
APPLICANTS ARE BEING ASKED FOR A
CREDIT REPORT AND OTHER. RECORDS
IT'S NOT EITHER OR- RIGHT AND
TODAY RIGHT. CREDIT THAT HAVE TO
PAY A FEE FOR THE CREDIT REPORT
THEY GET IT THE CREDIT THE
LANDLORD GETS THE CREDIT REPORT.
BANK RECORDS HE'LL LOOK AT THE
WHOLE PROCESS IT'S NOT. CHOOSE A
OR B. RIGHT I'M SO IT IS BEING
DONE RIGHT NOW BUT THIS BILL IS
ONLY FOCUSED ON THE CREDIT
REPORT AND THE FEE. RIGHT AND WE
DID NOT INCLUDE EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT A LANDLORD CAN USE TO MAKE
A DECISION. RIGHT TO WORK WE'RE
WE'RE OF TARGETING- SO THERE'S
STILL OTHER PIECES OF
INFORMATION THAT THE LANDLORD
TIME OR OR PERSON OWNING THE
PROPERTY. IT'S LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THE SAXBY STORY. OF
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT. HAD A
HOUSING VOUCHER IN HAND AND
COULDN'T. FIND A PLACE AND SPENT
YOU TO OVER FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ON THE CREDIT REPORT FEE. EIGHT
AND THIS IS JUST ONE WAY. TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MISTER
CALLER IN THE MISTER WARD. THANK
YOU- YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS A
RUN A CRISIS AND A CRISIS- IS
LEADING TO A LOT OF PAIN AND
SUFFERING- AND WE NEED TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY AND THE
REALITY IS AS A SUMMER
QUIRK-SILVA INDICATED FOR
SOMEONE ALREADY HAVE ULTRA
QUALIFY FOR SOME KIND OF
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDY. THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH SO MANY HOOPS AND- IF
YOU'RE GOING TO REQUIRE
SOMETHING OF THOSE APPLYING TO A
BRAND YOU HAVE TO APPLY TO
EVERYONE YOU CAN'T. DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A VOUCHER AND SO YOU KNOW
THE REALITY IS THAT. THERE IS A
PUT I MEAN I THINK A- SOMEONE
RENTING A PROPERTY I THINK THEY
CAN PRESUME THAT SOMEONE WHO
QUALIFIES. FOR A VOUCHER.
QUALIFIES FOR A REASON. MY
FATHER FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
BEEN RUNNING OUT HOME TO SOMEONE
ON SECTION EIGHT. I'M A GREAT
FAMILY THAT TEN YEARS AGO
COULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN INTO THAT
HOME IF IT RELIED UPON THE OTHER
TRADITIONAL THINGS YOU'RE GONNA
LOOK AT. WHAT IS YOU GET OUT OF
IT HE RENTS ARE BELOW MARKET HE
GOES GOOD GIVING IT TO A FAMILY.
THAT NEEDS IT BUT HE ALSO GETS
FOR ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
APPROXIMATELY OF THAT MONEY
EVERY A VERY REGULAR CHECK. FROM
THE GOVERNMENT HE DOES LEAVE AT
THE VERY LEAST IS THAT STABILITY
THERE AND THEN THE FAMILY HAS
COME UP WITH THE REST OF. THE
DAY. YOU KNOW IF HE WAS GONNA
SHOOT THAT FAMILY LIKE ANY OTHER
PERSON THE PRIVATE MARKET COMING
IN THERE'S NO WAY THEY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN AT HOME SO WHY DO WE
CREATE THESE PROGRAMS. THE
BRIDGE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
STOCK ON THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY
TO ACTUALLY USE VOUCHERS OVER
PAYING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
NATIONALLY FOR. EVEN HER STATE
ALONE WE SPEND SO MUCH MONEY BUT
AND YET THE PROBLEM WE WONDER
WHY THE PROBLEM PERSISTS. AND IS
BECAUSE THE BARRIERS ASK STOCK
UPON THE CUMULATIVE. AND SO
ULTIMATELY WHAT IS THAT
INFORMATION TELL YOU THAT YOU
DON'T ALREADY KNOW BY THE FACT
THAT SOMEONE HAS QUALIFIED FOR A
VOUCHER. YOU KNOW THAT THEY IF
THEY HAD THE VOUCHER THAT. IS
GOOD THAT IS FOR A REASON AND AT
THE END THAT WERE COMING
TOGETHER AS A SOCIETY AND SAYING
AS A PUBLIC POLICY MATTERS. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO COMBINE SOME OF
OUR MONEY. AS A SOCIETY. AND HOW
OUT THIS MAY. THAT I. WE'RE
PAYING A LOT MORE AS A- TO HAVE
THEM HOMELESS OR ON THE VERGE OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND SO IT DOESN'T
IMPACT THE ABILITY FOR THAT
PERSON. OR THAT THAT FAMILY TO
BE ABLE TO PAY RENT. OR DOESN'T
GET THE IN THE CREDIT SCORE BY
ITSELF DOES NOT GIVE THE
INDICATION. OF THE LIKELIHOOD OF
THAT PERSON TO BE ABLE TO PAY
RENT. IF YOU'RE ADDING IT WITH
THIS VOUCHER THE SUBS IF THEY
HAVE. A IS IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
GIVE. AN ACTUAL PICTURE OF THE
RISK ASSESSMENT. BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT'S ALREADY DONE THAT
RISK ASSESSMENT. FOR YOU. AND SO
AT THE END OF THE DAY LOOK YOU
KNOW- WE HAVE TO. IT IS ABOUT
TWO DIFFERENT. KIND OF COMPETING
INTERESTS SOME EXTENDED END OF
THE DAY THE POP OF THE PUBLIC
POLICY NEEDS. OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS. DICTATES THAT WE DO HAVE
A SOMETIMES PICK SIDES. AND ATM.
AND THE FACT THAT. IT'S ALWAYS A
GOOD IT JUST WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IT AS AN EVEN BATTLE- IN AND I
HATE TO USE WOULD BATTLE BUT
EVEN COMPETING INTERESTS. THAN
THOSE THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMES ARE ALWAYS GOING TO LOSE
OUT THE POT THE POOR. THOSE
LIVING IN POVERTY ARE ALWAYS
GONNA LOSE. IN THE BACK OF IT IN
THAT EQUATION. AND WE HAVE TO
DO. MORE THAN WE'VE BEEN DOING
TO MAKE IT JUST A LITTLE BIT
EASIER FOR SOME. OF THESE
FAMILIES TO GET A TO GET INTO
HOUSES. THANK YOU. MR WARD.
THANK YOU- I- GIVEN THIS BILL.
BIT OF STUDY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING IN
FOR IT- I RECOGNIZE THAT AND
WE'RE TRYING TO BE FAIR IN AND
HOW WE GO ABOUT MAKING OUR
RENTAL DECISIONS. ON THAT WE
WANT- YOU KNOW BUT WE WANT TO BE
FAIR IN IN IN ALL OF OUR TOOLS
ARE RIGHT IN FRONT OF US. AND
SO- ON ONE HAND I WAS THINKING
ABOUT- YOU KNOW IF. WE DON'T
WANT TO DISCRIMINATE BASED ON
THE FORM- SOURCES OF INCOME OR
WHETHER THAT IS BALLOTS OR OTHER
OR OTHERWISE- AND WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO COMPARE APPLICANT
APPLICANT IT'S NICE TO HAVE A
FULL SET A FULL COMPLEMENT OF
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO A
FAIR. AND FULL COMPARISON- BUT I
DO SIDE WITH MINE I'M CALLING
FROM SAN JOSE RAISES LIKE. THE
EXACTLY THE RIGHT POINTS THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ALSO- BEEN
THROUGH A LOT OF SCREENING A LOT
OF. TIME TO BE ABLE TO EVEN
QUALIFY FOR SOMETHING IN THE IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO YOU KNOW THE
MONEY IS THERE YOU KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE FINE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE MADE WHOLE- BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS MOVE FOR
TODAY MOSTLY BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER-
IMPORTANT AND HELPFUL
LEGISLATION IT'S ALSO MOTION.
MOTION THIS COULD BE A REALLY
GOOD TOOL- ARE CALLING FROM
ORANGE COUNTY HAS A REALLY GOOD
TOOL IN MOTION I'M WORKING ON
REUSABLE SCREENING- REPORTS AS
WELL THAT YOU KNOW SOMEHOW
BETWEEN ALL THESE ACTUALLY MIGHT
BE- SYMBIOTIC. OR OR OR OR WORK
OUT SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT BETTER FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE
HORRIBLY BURNED RIGHT NOW- AND
ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND I MEAN
SHUT OUT OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES-
AND I WANT TO AND I WANT TO. GET
THERE WITH YOU- ENCOURAGED TO
HEAR- THERE WAS TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT ORGANIZATIONS ARE ARE
WORKING. WITH MY OFFICE I
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT YET- BUT I'M
MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS- SO I THINK-
ANTENNA MIGHT I BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE- SO THAT WE CAN ALL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS-
COMPLEMENT. OF BILLS TOGETHER
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH YOU ON THAT ALL THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU MISTER SAID. THANK APART SO
YEAH THIS IS A I THINK I A
BANDAID TWO OF A LARGER PROBLEM
WE ALL KNOW THE LARGER PROBLEM
IS WHEN YOU RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
FIFTY PEOPLE ONE APPLY FOR ONE
APARTMENT AND HALF OF THEM MIGHT
HAVE VOUCHERS OF. YOU KNOW WITH
A WHOLE RANGE OF A 50% OR A 100%
OR WHATEVER AND SO THAT MAKES IT
REALLY DIFFICULT BUT A LOT OF
ALL THE LANDOWNERS OUT THERE THE
- THEY'RE NOT ALL THAT BIG
CORPORATIONS THEY'RE NOT ALL THE
HUGE APARTMENT BUILDINGS THERE
LOT OF MOM AND POP FOLKS THAT
OWN HAVE OVER THEIR YEARS- BEEN
ABLE TO ACQUIRE TWO OR THREE OR
FOUR PROPERTIES. AND THOSE
PROPERTIES ARE THEIR LIFELINE
THAT'S THEIR INCOME AND IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT INCOME AND THEY
DON'T HAVE A GUARANTEE OF THAT
INCOME- DAN THEY TURN INTO
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUFFERING TRYING
TO- YOU KNOW DO EXACTLY WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE IS JUST TRYING TO
SURVIVE. AND THEY DO USE THESE
TOOLS AND THAT'S ONE OF THEIR
TOOLS IS DOING A CREDIT REPORT
AND THEY DON'T ALWAYS RELY JUST
ON THAT CREDIT REPORT THAT'S
KIND OF A SNAPSHOT OF THE
OVERALL HISTORY BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE TO LOOK AT. GATHERING SOME
OF THE DAY AND THERE'S NOT AS
MUCH DATA AS THEY NEED BEFORE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A CREDIT REPORT
THEN THEY'RE GONNA WANT A BUNCH
OF THESE OTHER THINGS BUT IF
THEY HAVE A CREDIT REPORT THAT
SAYS THAT THIS IS KINDA IFFY ON
THE CREDIT REPORT BUT BOY
THEY'VE HAD A GREAT JOB FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS. THEY'RE MAKING
UP FOR IT OVER HERE AND THAT
BALANCES IT OUT AND THAT HELPS
BRING THAT SECURITY TO A
INDIVIDUAL LANDLORDS- THAT HAS
DON'T DOESN'T HAVE THE ROOM TO
HAVE SOMEBODY NOT PAY HALF THE
RENT AND THEN TAKE ANOTHER SIX
MONTHS. TO EVICTING AND TRY OR
NOT BE ABLE TO VICTOR ALL AND
JUST HAVE TO EAT IT- THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT DATA THAT
TO ABILITY- SO- I. IT'S A TWO
THAT. IS NECESSARY FOR SOME. AND
IT'S USEFUL FOR SOME BUT IT'S
NOT ALWAYS RELIED ON AND I WOULD
I WOULD HESITATE TO TAKE IT
AWAY. AND SAY. WE'RE NOT GONNA
ALLOW CREDIT REPORTS- IT NO
MATTER WHO IT IS WHETHER IT'S A
SUBSIDIES OR IT'S A NON
SUBSIDIZED PERSON- THOSE CREDIT
REPORTS ARE PART OF THE TOOLS
FOR ESPECIALLY SMALLER-
LANDLORDS TO BE ABLE TO. ENSURE
THEIR SURVIVABILITY AND- AND
THEY DO HAVE FLEXIBILITY THEY
HAVE A LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY BUT
THIS HELPS THE I THINK THINGS
LIKE THIS WILL. ENCOURAGE THEM
NOT TO BE AS FLEXIBLE. BECAUSE
THEY THEY DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE
TOOLS THEY NEED AND SO THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE SAFE PLACE
AND THAT SAFE PLACE ISN'T ALWAYS
SOMEBODY HAS A SUBSIDY. AND DOES
SO THAT THAT WORRIES ME IN THAT
RESPECT AND THE YOU KNOW THE BY
MY LAST COMMENT IS. THE BIGGER
PROBLEM IS WE HAVE FALLEN
WOEFULLY WOEFULLY BEHIND. IN IN
BUILDING. HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
WHETHER THEIR APARTMENTS
TOWNHOMES SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
WHATEVER AND IN THAT PROCESS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS AND- WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING IT IN A MANNER THAT
WILL SPEED DATA. OR MAKE THAT
BETTER AND THAT'S WHERE OUR
FOCUS IS BECAUSE IF WE CAN GET
IT TO ONE PERSON HAS- YOU HAVE
FIVE PEOPLE APPLYING FOR AN
APARTMENT INSTEAD OF FIFTY. FIVE
I THINK A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
KIND OF WRITE THEMSELVES IN THE
MARKET IT JUST'S TO WHAT PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD IN THEIR VOUCHERS CAN
COVER BUT IF IT'S ANYTHING LESS
THAN A 100% EIGHT IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR LANDLORDS TO GET
BEHIND THAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT SOMEBODY IS FINANCIALLY
CAPABLE TO KEEP. KEEP THEM
SURVIVING. THANK YOU I AGREE
WITH. SOME OF WHAT YOU SAID
RIGHT WE ARE NOT TARGETING ALSO
SOME- AND- YOU KNOW I JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT- BUT- THIS
LIKE I SAID IT'S VERY NARROW-
IT'S SOMEONE WITH A VOUCHER.
THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
GET. THE SOME OF THE RENT OR
MOST OF THE RENT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. RIGHT I I'M A
LANDLORD I'M A VERY SMALL I HAVE
ONE UNIT- I RELY ON THAT INCOME
GREAT AND DOT OF UNFORTUNATELY
DURING OPEN. THEY WERE ABLE TO
PAY BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A
VOUCHER SO I WASN'T GETTING
PAID- BUT IN THIS CASE- THIS IS
SOMEONE THAT IS APPLYING LIKE
THE MEMBER FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SAID. THEY'RE NOT JUST HANDING
THEM OUT AT THE SOCIAL SERVICES
CENTER RIGHT YOU GO THROUGH
VETTING- AN APPLICATION PROCESS
TO EVEN QUALIFY AND HOPEFULLY
GET THAT VOUCHERS SO THEY'VE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH HOOPS. TO
EVEN GET THAT VOUCHER IN THEIR
HAND AND THIS BILL IS ONLY FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
ALREADY WENT THROUGH THOSE HOOPS
AND HAVE THAT VOUCHER IN HAND IT
IS FOR NO ONE ELSE. RIGHT SO I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT
. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD AND THE
CONVERSATION ON THE DIRE CITY
WE'VE DISCUSSED A NUMBER OF
THINGS AND ALWAYS HAPPY TO HEAR
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW ON
THESE BILLS- YOU'RE TRYING TO
TACKLE TOUGH ISSUE- BUT IT'S
ADMIRABLE AND THAT THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT NEED HELP THE MOST. I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HERE IS A CREDIT
REPORTED MEANINGFUL PREDICTOR OF
SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO PAY WHEN.
THEY HAVE GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES
TO MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS RIGHT IN
THAT SENSE I DON'T THINK THE
CREDIT REPORT IS A MEANINGFUL
PREDICTOR OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY I THINK THE SUBSIDIES
MEANING. MEANINGFUL PREDICTOR OF
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY BUT I ALSO
HEAR THE QUESTION UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BUT I WANT TO SEE
THE BILL MOVE FORWARD- OUT OF MY
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I TINK IT'S A
WORTHWHILE CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE- I'D- ARE WE WERE
LOOKING FOR MOTION AND- SO MOVED
SECOND. OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THIS
CONVERSATION R. LIKE I SAID THIS
IS A VERY. NARROW YOU KNOW
BARRIER THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND NOT. ANY BILL THAT
WE BRING FORWARD IS NOT SOLVING.
OUR HOUSING CRISIS RAY AND BUT
IF WERE ABLE TO HELP SOME PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY. QUALIFIED FOR
A HOUSING VOUCHER AND HAVE IT IN
HAND AND WANT TO BE HOUSED- THEN
THIS IS WHY WE SHOULD DO THIS
AND I ASK THAT. YOU WOULD YOU
ALLOW THIS TO CONTINUE AND LET'S
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND-
AND- YOU KNOW BY VOTING FOR IT
TODAY YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE ALREADY-
SUPPORTED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT ON THIS-
AND I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS TODAY. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN JUDICIARY
WICKS FIVE. I SEYARTO SAY ARE NO
CARILLO. HI GABRIEL. KALRA KALRA
I. KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. WARD OR
DIE. THE BILL DOES NOT PASS-
IT'S ON CALL I'M SORRY WE'VE GOT
A COUPLE KILEY ABOUT SOUTH
KOREAN ARE. GIVE. LET'S GO NOW
TO MISTER JONES SAWYER.
YOUR BRING. CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE THE BAND THE BOX
HOUSING ACT I LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK AND I'M ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT THE NUMEROUS
AMENDMENTS. CALIFORNIANS WITH A
CRIMINAL HISTORY ARE CONSTANTLY
MARC WITH THE SCARLET LETTER
THAT BLOCKS THEM FROM GETTING
THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK AND
REUNITING WITH THEIR LOVED ONES.
THIS BILL WILL BAN THE BOX
PREVENTING RENTERS FROM
INCLUDING QUESTIONS REGARDING AN
APPLICANT'S CRIMINAL HISTORY ON
THE INITIAL ROUND OF
APPLICATIONS WHILE SEEKING
HOUSING. AS IT STANDS TODAY WE
PUNISH THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED INCARCERATION FOR
BEING HONEST ABOUT THEIR PAST
WHEN TRYING TO SECURE HOUSING AT
A TIME WHEN OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
SPECIFIC TERROR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR TERM AND
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY-
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS OF
COLOR 61% REPORT DIFFICULTY
FINDING HOUSING MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE RATE OF OTHERS. HERE ARE A
FEW THINGS TO REMEMBER WHEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE FIRSTLY
MOST HOUSING APPLICATION HAPPY
AND OFTEN FORMALLY INCARCERATED
FOLKS ARE HAVING TO SHELL OUT
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FIFTY
DOLLARS EVEN A HUNDRED DOLLARS
ONLY TO HAVE APPLICATION THROWN
INTO THE TRASH. BECAUSE OF THEIR
CRIMINAL RECORD EVEN WORSE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS FACE CRIME FREE
HOUSING POLICIES THAT EMPOWER
RENTERS TO EXCLUDE THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVED POPULATION FROM
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH ACCESS TO
BETTER SCHOOLS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. ACCORDING TO THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES ARTICLE SOME
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTORS OFFER TRAINEE TO
RENTERS OR HOW TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
WITHOUT SUFFERING LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES. I'M OFFERING AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE TO
GIVE FORMERLY INCARCERATED A
PATH TO LOOK TO LIFE SUSTAINING
HOUSING WHILE. THANKS TO THE
WORK OF COMMUNIQU OF THIS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THIS BILL BUILDS ON
AN ALREADY EXISTING REGULATIONS
ADOPTED LAST YEAR BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CARE- EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. THE BILL PROVIDES
NECESSARY CLARITY FOR RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS OF THEIR
OBLIGATION UNDER THESE
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WOULD NOT
PREVENT OWNERS FROM REQUESTING A
BACKGROUND CHECK. REQUIRED THAT
AN OWNER PRESENTED IN DETAIL THE
FINDINGS OF A BACKGROUND CHECK
THEY DEEM SUFFICIENT FOR DENIAL
WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF RECEIPT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL GRANT
APPLICANTS THREE DAYS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION INCLUDING
EVIDENCE OF REHABILITATION
REFERENCES AND OTHER PERTINENT
INFORMATION. MY BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT SOMEONE'S PAST DOES
NOT UNDULY IMPEDE HIS OR HER
FUTURE WHILE MUCH WORK HAS BEEN
DONE TO PROMOTE EQUITY IN THE
HOUSE IN SPACE. MANY BERRIES
REMAIN ESPECIALLY BARRIERS THAT
HINDER THE ABILITY OF THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED TO FIND
HOUSING. IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO BE A STAT OF SECOND CHANCES
PERFORMING INCARCERATED WE HAVE
TO BE WILLING TO GIVE THEM A
FAIR SHAKE AND THE ALREADY
UPHILL BATTLE OF INSURING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. AS BY NOON
YES AND I BELIEVE MANUAL GOLF
GOMEZ OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION COALITION ONE OF THE
COSPONSORED BY JOINING ME TODAY.
THE PROVIDES TESTIMONY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU AND I THINK WE HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS MANUAL GOMEZ ON
THE PHONE OPERATOR.
PARDON ME MISTER GOMEZ IF YOU
ARE CALLED IN AS A CO HOST FOR
THE CALL YOUR LINE SHOULD BE
OPEN. IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT MR
GOMEZ HAS DIALED THEN AS A- A
SPEAKER ON THE COLD TO JUST A
MOMENT. WHAT WHY DON'T WE GO TO
OUR WITH THE WITNESS HERE IN THE
ROOM WE'LL DO THAT FIRST AND MR
GONNA COME AS IF YOU'RE
LISTENING PLEASE DIAL IN FOR AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE TO BE
A PRIME PRIMARY WITNESS AFTER WE
HEAR FROM. A TESTIMONY HERE. A
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. HI MY NAME IS
AS FUNNY AS AND I'M HERE WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
APOLOGIZE I HAVE WORKED IN
ADVOCACY AND DIRECT SERVICES-
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
I'M AT THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION SINCE MY RELEASE. FROM
INCARCERATION OF IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND- THE INADVERTENT
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE DO NOT PROPERLY HOUSE.
INDIVIDUALS COMING HOME. HOUSING
IS A FUNDAMENTAL NEED FOR
EVERYONE AND CONSIDERING
FORMALLY INCARCERATE PEOPLE ARE
TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
HOMELESS WE ARE NO DIFFERENT. A.
R. C. IS ACUTELY AWARE OF WHAT
PEOPLE RETURNING HOME NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY. AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THE COMMUNITIES IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. STILL IT BECOMES NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO SO WITHOUT
ACCESS TO STABLE HOUSING.
SOMEONE COULD NOT BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT EDUCATION WORK OR FAMILY
REUNIFICATION IF THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY WILL BE LAYING THEIR
HEADS IN A DAY. A WEEK. OR A
MONTH FROM NOW. SHE HAS MET HAVE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE TAKEN PART IN
OUR TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
SERVICES. AND WE PROVIDED THEM
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO FIND
THEIR FOOTING. THEY FIND QUALITY
JOBS AND CAREERS WHILE BEING
ABLE TO SAVE MONEY. THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
RECONNECT WITH THEIR FAMILIES
YET WHEN IT COMES TIME FOR THEM
TO HAVE THEIR OWN HOUSING THEY
ARE UNABLE TO DO SO WHAT THEN.
DO THEY GO TO THE STREETS. DO
THEY RETURN TO A COMMUNITY THAT
IS DEEMED UNSAFE OR UNHEALTHY
FOR THEIR PROGRESS. ALL OF THEIR
UPWARD MOMENTUM IS SUDDENLY
STIFLED. AND AT RISK OF
REVERTING BACK TO SURVIVAL MODE
. THIS BILL GIVES PEOPLE A
CHANCE FIRST TO BE SEEN FOR WHO
THEY ARE NOW NOT FOR WHO THEY
WERE WHEN THEY COMMITTED THEIR
OFFENSE. AND IT ALLOWS THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO GROW
AND FIND INDEPENDENCE. THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE RESULT
OF YEARS OF NEGOTIATIONS AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS YEARS THAT PEOPLE
RETURNING HOME FRANKLY DON'T
HAVE. THIS BILL ALLOWS LANDLORDS
T KEEP THEIR TIME TO ME THEY
STILL GET TO SEE APPLICANTS
FINANCIAL INFORMATION CREDIT
HISTORY AND LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION. EVERYTHING ONE
WOULD NEED TO DETERMINE IF
SOMEBODY WOULD MAKE A GOOD AND
RELIABLE TENANT. IF AFTER
CONSIDERING ALL THOSE FACTORS
THEY STILL WANT TO RUN A
BACKGROUND CHECK THEY ARE ABLE
TO DO SO. BUT THEY MUST ADHERE
TO THE REGULATIONS ENACTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. ONE OF
WHICH IS NOTABLY THE SEVEN YEAR
LOOK BACK PERIOD. PEOPLE WHO
WERE CONVICTED OVER SEVEN YEARS
AGO HAVE PUT IN THE WORK TO
REHABILITATE YET BECAUSE A
QUESTION IS POSED THERE OFTEN
TIMES OVERLOOKED. THEY HAVE THE
LOWEST RECIDIVISM RATES AND
THOSE RATES DROP EVEN FURTHER
WHEN THEY HAVE STABLE HOUSING.
SO BY DISALLOWING LANDLORDS TO
ASK ABOUT SOMEONE'S CRIMINAL
HISTORY ON THEIR APPLICATION
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
APPLICANTS WHO ARE UNLIKELY TO
KNOW ABOUT THE REGULATIONS ARE
COMPELLED TO GIVE LANDLORDS
INFORMATION THEY OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE INSIGHT TO. ALLOWS
THEM THE DIGNITY AND ABILITY TO
APPLY FAIRLY WITHOUT JUDGEMENT
OR SHAME. THEY ARE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND IF WE BELIEVE
IN SECOND CHANCES AND BELIEVE IN
FORGIVENESS THEN WE MUST CREATE
POLICIES THAT REFLECT SUCH.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
DESERVES AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
HEALTHY AND STABLE LIVES AS
RESIDENTS RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. I URGE IN A VOTE FOR
THIS FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AN OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
MANUAL GOMEZ NOW ON THE PHONE AS
A PRIMARY WITNESS. EMELEC.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MUHAMMAD I AM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS A FULLY
DISABLED MILITARY VETERAN AND A
GRADUATE STUDENT. I AM A FATHER
TO TWO BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN A
HUSBAND AND A MEMBER OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. I HAVE
SPOKEN COMMANDS FROM MY PREVIOUS
COURT DECISIONS IN THE PAST.
EACH DAY SIR MY COMMUNITY TO
REMEDY THE HARM THAT LED ME TO
SERVE TWO YEARS IN PRISON. I
SHIELD MY CONTROL MORE AND WAS
RELEASED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. UPON RELEASE A
RELATIVE ALLOWED ME AND MY
FAMILY TO RESIDE IN A SMALL
COMPUTER CLOCKS. IT ALLOWED MY
FAMILY TO BE TOGETHER IT WAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE CONDITIONS AND
NEVER SUPPOSED TO BE PERMANENT.
I BEGAN SEARCHING FOR A NEW HOME
FOR US AT LEAST RECENTLY
ACQUIRED EMPLOYMENT AS A CASE
MANAGER. AND HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPLEMENTAL INCOME AS A
DISABLED VETERAN. MY SPOUSE IS
AN EDUCATOR FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT EDUCATION I
MET ALL THE REQUIREMENTS OF I
HAD THE EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATE
REPUBLICATION. OR INCOME WAS
STABLE AND IN SOME CASES OF
SURPLUS FOR TURNS TO INTO
ACQUIREMENT. YEAH EVERY TIME
SOMEONE SAW THAT I HAD BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. I WAS
DENIED. IT WAS DEVASTATING I
POVERTY WE HAVE TO LOOK TO
MICHAEL. IN ALONG SIMILAR LIKE
THIS HAVE A LOT ME TO USE THE
HOUSE THAT WAS. AND HEALTHIEST
MY TO. BECAUSE THEY THE MOST. TO
ME. PEOPLE SHOULD ENCOURAGED
GROW THIS WAY BUT THE COUNTY
WHEN HE'S BEEN. STILL EXIST.
AFTER BEING THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PROPERTIES WE FOUND A- OFFERED
BY. PARTY MY BACKGROUND WILL
DISCUSS ANY CLICK I FELT THAT.
ON IS EVERYTHING ME BECAUSE
DIDN'T HAVE. THE LEADING OPTION
. OUR FAMILY. A HOME. AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE HAD BEEN
AFFECTED I CAME HOME. TO HAVE A
LOT OF LEVEL TWO SEE ME WHO I
AM. FIRST AMENDMENT BE-
COMMITTEE. AND BECAME DISABLE
MOTOR. FATHER TOOK. LOCAL
MCCARTY YEAR OLD BOY INTRODUCED
. A CALL EDUCATED IN THE GOOD.
GRADUATES AND SOMEONE WHO EXPECT
COMMUNITY LEADERS. IN MULTIPLE.
THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN FOR MY ONE
AS AN- SPECIAL WHICH TEACHER.
ORANGE COUNTY IN A ONLY IS ALSO
WHO IS INCARCERATED. NOBODY HAS
BEEN SEVEN YEARS MICHAEL VICK
THIS BILL WILL ME AND OTHERS ME
COULD BE SEEN AS A PEOPLE ARE
NOW. IN AUSTIN FOR TO HELP THAT
IS. SUITED FOR OF. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
GO TO ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE. OKAY
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIST WHO
WOULD WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN TERRIBLE YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. GOING TO GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME
THANK YOU YOUR HONOR LIVE CALL
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION HOPE
AND REDEMPTION FEE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO FULLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE THIRTY. HELLO MY NAME
IS DAVID ROSE FROM- CORPORATE
REDEMPTION LEFT COURT WITHOUT
THAT RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
I'M CALLING INTO STRONG SUPPORT
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU. FIND ONE TWENTY SEVEN
. YES HELLO MY NAME'S STEPHEN
CRISTINA ON A LIGHT COLD FRONT
OPEN TENSION TEAM AT THE END
CONSERVATIVE COALITION AND I'M
CALLING TO STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B. TWO THREE EIGHT THREE THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT. BLIND
TWO NINE. HI MY NAME MICHAEL
MENDOZA WITH THEIR SCENES
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE EIGHT
THREE THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
NINE. PERFECT GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. FIND. ONE TWENTY ONE.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MIGUEL
GARCIA WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION BILL SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE THIRTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHEN ABOUT
THE LIVE I AM- FROM ARC AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE. THANK FINE
BY ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON. JUST A MOMENT. WHY LIKE TWENTY BUCKS. WHEN
YOU GO. TO YOUR WE WANT ME TO
MOMENT PLEASE WHY ONE POINT
NINE. PERFECT. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX IN LINE IS
NOW OPEN PARDON ME ONE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
GOD. ONE THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
BY ONE THIRTY SIX A LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CELINA CHIEF
AND I AM THE MANAGER OF POLICY
AND ADVOCACY AT THE INTERESTS OF
THE COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANKS VERY MUCH
BYE. ONE ONE THIRTY THREE. I'M
HERE BECAUSE MY MONEY WAS
COMMITMENT WERE I'M WITH A ARE
SHE'D OPEN RETENTION TEAM I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU. BY. ONE THIRTY TWO. THEY
WERE TO BUY WHAT THEY ARE C. I'M
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHT THREE. BY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. HI I'M DESTINY
GRAY WITH A R. P. AND ARMSTRONG
THE COURT A. B. TWO THREE EIGHT
THREE. FIND ONE THIRTY SEVEN.
GOODMORNING MY NAME IS APPROACH
BROWN AND I AM WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE EIGHT
THREE THANK YOU. YEAH THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU WE WILL
BRING IT NOW BACK TO THE ROOM-
FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY. OKAY
I ANY FOLK MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE I WISH TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO A AB. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE. OKAY OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
pREGISTER OPPOSITION TO TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION ONLY
PLACE. PRESS ONE MILLION ZERO.
FINE. NINE BY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI YES- GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CLEAN
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WOULD PROPOSE WHAT
MENDED POSITION RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING OF THE THANK YOU FOR. I KNOW SEVENTY. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THAT BRAND WITH
THEIR AND READING THE SOCIO
TROUBLING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE OUT
TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE DICE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. BILLS AND
SECONDED MISTER SARATOGA. SO I'M
A LITTLE STRUGGLING WITH THIS-
NUMBER ONE AND I MAKE NO IS A
SMALL VERY SMALL JUST LIKE- MISS
QUIRK-SILVA VERY SMALL
LANDLORDS. SINGLE UNIT. I RUN
BACKGROUND CHECKS THEY'RE EASILY
AVAILABLE ON. THINGS AYE WHITE
PAGES PREMIUM- YOU CAN GET
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS ON
ANYBODY AND I DO THAT WHEN THEIR
PEOPLE ARE COMING TO DO WORK AT
THE HOUSE TO MAKE SURE THAT. YOU
HAVE. READ IT AND I DON'T USE
THAT NECESSARILY AGAINST THEM
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR THE RENTAL
PART OF IT SINCE I HAVE A IT
TAKES MORE OF A TOWN HOME AND
YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE AROUND IT.
AND YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR WHO
MOVES IN. AND SO YOU KNOW I WILL
I YOU KNOW WILL HAVE AN OPEN
DISCUSSION AND IT'S I THINK IT'S
BETTER TO HAVE THAT OPEN
DISCUSSION. BEFORE THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF DOING AN
APPLICATION FEE AND ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS AND THEN FIND THAT
THE LANDLORD IS TOTALLY
INTOLERANT. OF SOME OF THE
OFFENSES THAT THEY DO BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT MAY NOT BE
INTOLERANT OF SOME. THEY CAN
LOOK AT THAT AND SAY ADDED LEARN
THEIR LESSON THEY'RE NOT DOING
THAT ANYMORE BUT THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE THE YOU HAVE TO
STRUGGLE AS A LANDLORD. AT TO
SAY OKAY YOU KNOW I'M GONNA TAKE
A CHANCE ON THIS AND SOME OF
THOSE ARE- PEOPLE ARRESTED FOR
DRUG DEALING- BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT THE ASSOCIATION
WILL. CERTAINLY HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE FOR- YOU KNOW CHILD
MOLESTATION THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS- AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. YOU LOOK FOR
SOME OF THOSE BECAUSE OF THAT
START HAPPENING IN THE UNIT
YOU'RE RENTING- THE BUCK STOPS
ON YOU. SO AS A LANDLORD I'D
RATHER HAVE THAT CONVERSATION UP
FRONT. AND I KNOW NOT ALL ARE IS
MAYBE OPEN MINDED TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND NOT- NOT.
IMMEDIATELY DISMISS SOMEBODY
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WE
DO NEED PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
REHABILITATE REHABILITATE
THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO DO SO.
AND IF YOU CAN BE HELPFUL ALONG
THAT PATH THAT'S AWESOME- BUT
YOU STILL NEED. IT FOR ME YOU
NEED TO HAVE THE TOOLS TO DO
THAT. AND IN TAKING AWAY TOOL
AND HAVING IT COME LATER IN THE
PROCESS. TO FIND A PLACE THAT
WHERE THEY ARE TOLERANT OF
WHATEVER IT IS THAT IS ON THEIR
CRIMINAL RECORD BECAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA FIND IT ANYWAY. SO NOW I
HAVE TO ORDER ONE. SO THAT'S WHY
MAN AND OPPOSETHE BILL IS
BECAUSE I JUST DON'T THINK. IT'S
GOING TO BE USEFUL- AND THAT
PLANNERS CAN ALREADY GET IT THAT
DOESN'T THEY DON'T HAVE TO ORDER
ONE UP FROM FROM THAT. THE
TENANT. AND IT AND I WISH. THAT
MMHM MOST LANDLORDS WOULD. WOULD
TAKE THE TIME. AND EFFORT TO
REALLY LOOK AT SOMEONE. THAT
PERSON. UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THEY
CHECKED THAT BOX. IN A SEAT.
PERFORMING CARCERI. THROW THROW
IT AWAY. YOU KNOW PEOPLE LIKE
GANDHI. MARTIN LUTHER KING AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS
. PROBABLY WOULD BE RENT TO. I
pWELL YOU KNOW WHO HE IS NOW BUT
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE GIVEN HIM
THAT OPPORTUNITY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS SAY GIVE ME OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW YOU THAT ARE NOT ONLY
HAVE I DONE MY TIME AND PAID MY
DEBT TO SOCIETY BUT I MIGHT BE.
A MAILER TO TRADE MAKE IT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR I NOW HAVE A GOOD I DON'T
OR BRING UP THE PREVIOUS RIGHT
NOW FOR GOOD CREDIT RECORD OVER
SEVEN YEARS I'D I NOW CAN PAY MY
BILLS AND MAKE OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL THESE
OTHER FACTORS. NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT MY CRIMINAL PAST AND I
JUST THINK SECOND CHANCES ARE
IMPORTANT- I GREW UP WHERE MY
GRANDMOTHER'S USED TO SAY YOU
CAN YOU NEVER GET A SECOND
CHANCE TO MAKE A FIRST
IMPRESSION. UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
A LOT OF TIMES THE WAY THINGS
ARE SOCIETY. THIS BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE FORMERLY INCARCERATED. AGAIN
WHO WOULDN'T. PAGE ASSIST THEIR
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND
NOW ARE PROBABLY SAFER THAN
SOMEONE WHO'S NEVER GONE TO
PRISON WE NEED WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM THAT SECOND CHANCE THIS IS
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT. SO I
WANT TO- APPRECIATE. SHARE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK IN THIS SPACE AND
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
THE WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
I KNOW- CHANGE IS HARD FOR FOLKS
BUT THIS IS THE TYPE OF STUFF WE
SHOULD BE DOING HERE- IN
GOVERNMENT AND WE HAVE A MOTION
THE SECOND BEFORE WE DO THE ROLL
CALL- OBVIOUSLY I'M SUPPORTING
THE BILL WANT TO SEE MEDICARE
BUT ALSO ON A FEW ANY OTHER LAST
CLOSING REMARKS- PICTURES MY
CLOSING. THANK RIGHT THANK YOU.
THE MOTION. TO PASS TO THE- AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
FIFTY SHADES WICKS. I SEYARTO.
WE ARE THE NO. CARILLO AEREO I
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. HI NO CORE.
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD FOR TI. THE
BILL'S THANK MISTER JONES SAWYER
EIGHTY THANK YOU AND IT WANT TO-
OPEN UP THE. BILLS FOR
ADDITIONAL VOTES TO ADD ON. IF
MY THIRTY CONSENT CALENDAR- YES
SIR THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLACE
WE HAD TO BILLS ITEM NUMBER ONE.
EIGHT WITH THE- EIGHTY NINE
READING ON- ITEM NUMBER ONE A.
B. SIXTEEN FIFTEEN TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN HUMAN
SERVICES ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY NINETY FOUR TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY. THIS IS CONSENT CONSENT.
ALL FIVE THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER- TO- AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. THIS IS A SEPARATE ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS A CURRENT MEMBER BRIAN
SPEAKING. AND THE RECOVERY I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. ASSEMBLY
MERCALLI NO. SB SIXTY TWO. THE
ITEM NUMBER THREE- A. B.
NINETEEN TEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY. MY BECAUSE WE KNOW. YEAH
OF THE BILL THE YEAH THE BILL'S
OUT NOW RIGHT CORRECT YEP. THAT
IS- SIX TWO TWO. I'M ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB NINETEEN OF FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. AMERICA
THE I. B. EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT- NUMBER FIVE COURSE WAS
CONSENT NUMBER SIX OF AB TWENTY
TWO THREE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY.
SUPERVALU CUSTOMER QUIRK-SILVA.
I. FIVE FIVE TWO THAT BILLS OUT
. AND THAT CONCLUDES THE ADD ONS
MA'AM WE'RE NOW ON RIGHT NOW-
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WILL ALLOW
QUALIFIED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS TO EFFECTIVELY
STREAMLINE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AS INTENDED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
SB THIRTY FIVE WAS A LANDMARK
EFFORT TO INCREASE OUR HOUSING
SUPPLY BY STREAMLINING THE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR HOUSING
PROJECTS IN LOCALITIES THAT ARE
FAILING TO MEET THE ARENA GOALS
UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MUST ESTABLISH
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS AND
STREAMLINED APPROVALS FOR
DEVELOPMENTS THAT MEET THOSE
STANDARDS. HOWEVER AMBIGUITIES
IN THE LAW HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED
TO DE RAIL DESPERATELY NEEDED
HOUSING PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT
MAKES ONE CLARIFYING CHANGE TO
ADDRESS AN EMERGENT LOOPHOLE IT
CLARIFIES THAT IF A PROJECT
APPLICATION HAS ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT MEETS THE OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS. THEN THE JURISDICTION
MUST NOT DETERMINED THAT THE PER
PROP THAT THE PROJECT CONFLICTS
WITH THEIR OBJECTIVE STANDARDS
ON THE BASIS THAT APPLICATION
MATERIALS WERE NOT INCLUDED WITH
THIS CHANGE AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT QUALIFIED
OR QUALIFYING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED AS
INTENDED. TO THE CHAIR MY
WITNESSES MICHAEL LANE FROM SPUR
. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALL BE
BRIEF- MICHAEL IN WHIPER A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. SB
THIRTY FIVE HOUSING APPROVAL
STREAMLINED HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS BOON TO THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS HELPING TO BRING NEW HOMES
ONLINE MORE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY WHILE RESPECTING
LOCAL ZONING AN OBJECT DESIGN
AND DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL PROCESS STAYS FOCUSED
ONE DOCUMENTS TO DEMONSTRATE A
PROJECT CONFORMS WITH THOSE
OBJECTIVES STANDARDS AND AVOIDS
DILATORY PAPER CHASES UNRELATED.
AND NOT GERMANE TO THE
MODIFICATION REQUEST AT HAND
CODIFYING THIS CONCEPT THAT
EXISTS IN EIGHT CITIES SB THIRTY
FIVE GUIDELINES. THIS
CLARIFICATION WILL ENSURE THAT
SB THIRTY FIVE FUNCTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR- SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE COME TO THE
MIKE. A DIFFICULT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. HI DAVE- THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION STRONG SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATED WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE THAT WISHES
TO REGISTER THEIR- SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WANTED SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK AND ARE THERE ANY-
PERSONS- FROM THERE ARE OPPOSING
THE BILL THAT WISH TO BE A
PRIMARY WITNESS I. DON'T THINK
WE HAVE ANY. NONE OKAY WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE ROOM
ANYBODY OPPOSE THE BILL- PLEASE
COME UP TO THE MIKE AND REGISTER
YOUR OPPOSITION. GIVEN THAT
THERE AREN'T ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES AND-
OPEN HIM UP GO ANYBODY THAT
OPPOSES THIS BILL. DO YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IN. NO ONE
KNEW SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ALL RIGHT THEN WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DÍAS FOR ANYBODY
IN MY COLLEAGUES UP HERE WHICH
TO COMMENT HAVE QUESTIONS. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY WARD WANT TO
COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR RIGHT I
KNOW THAT WE IT'S A LONG HEARING
BUT THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL IN
THE SENSE THAT- IT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME WE'VE GOT
TO GET YESES. TO PROJECTS AND
WE'VE GOT TO GET THEM MOVING
THANK YOU. VERY SEVEN MOTION BY
WARD- TO PROVE AT SECOND. BY
MISCREANTS. SO. BRING BACK GO
AHEAD MADAM SECRETARY. OKAY DID
YOU WANT TO CLOSE MISTER GRAYSON
I'M SORRY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU KNOW WE GO. OUR
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WICKS. WEEKS I SEYARTO I DON'T
KNOW WHY CORREO. GABRIELLE HI
APRIL I KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY I QUIRK-SILVA HI FOLKS WHO
LIVE WORK. OR DIE ISRAEL THREE I
AND THE BILL EIGHT ZERO OKAY
THAT'S OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
. I NEXT UP WE HAVE AB TWO THREE
THREE FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. MADAM CHAIR WHEN YOU ARE READY
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
THE STAFF. I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MEMONS OUTLINE OF THE
ANALYSIS TODAY ON A. B. TWO
THREE THREE FOUR CALIFORNIA AS
WE ALL KNOW- CURRENTLY HAS A GAP
OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION HOMES-
THAT WE ARE THAT AS A GAP OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION HOMES- FOR
STRUGGLING THAT WE AFFORDABLE
HOMES THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
STRUGGLE TO FIND- WITH ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HOMELESS ON THE STREETS
AT ANY GIVEN NIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA MANY OF US SEE THAT
ON OUR STREETS AS WE GO BACK TO
OUR DISTRICT AND IT'S IN EVERY
COMMUNITY- ACROSS THE STATE.
WELL THE MOST SIGNIFICANT BEAR
TO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A LACK OF
PUBLIC FUNDING LAND USE POLICY
ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITS THE
AMOUNT OF UNITS THAT CAN BE
BUILT HERE IN CALIFORNIA A. B.
NINETY S. R. IN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY FORMER CHAIR CHIU
AMENDED STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW
TO ALLOW 41100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS UNLIMITED
DENSITY FOR DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN
ONE HALF MILE OF A MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP OR HIGH QUALITY BUS
CORRIDOR. THAT BILL PASSED OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A. B. TWO
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR BUILT
ON RECENT IMPROVEMENTS TO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
ALLOWING A 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO RECEIVE
AN ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE FROM THE
LOCAL AGENCY ADDED HEIGHT AND
DENSITY OF THE PROJECT IS
LOCATED IN URBANIZED LOW V. M.
T. AREA. THE BILL DEFINES A LOW
BEAM TEARY AS AN URBANIZED AREA
WHERE THE EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT GENERATES VMT PER
CAPITAL PER CAPITA THAT IS BELOW
85% OF AYE THE REGIONAL V. M. T.
PER CAPITA OR CITY VMT PER
CAPITA. THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WILL BE
RELEASING MAPS WITH REGIONAL BMP
CALCULATIONS AT THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING. ORGANIZATIONAL LEVEL
IN THE COMING MONTHS. THESE MAPS
ARE BASED ON LOCAL TRAVEL
DEMANDS MODELED. MODELS
DEVELOPED BY JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE PRODUCED THEIR OWN MAPS VMT
THE BILL DRESSES THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT
FURTHER. THAT FURTHERS
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS BY INCREASING THE UNIVERSE
OF SITES FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED. ALL OF MY
WITNESSES HERE SELF IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AND LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT FROM THE COMMITTEE. YOU. YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS WEARING A WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM WERE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON THE PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING- THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
STATEWIDE HOUSING PLAN
SPECIFICALLY LESS AS AN
OBJECTIVE OF THE STATE QUOTE TO
ENCOURAGE NEW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN EXISTING
COMMUNITIES TO REDUCE VMT AND
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESSING
HOUSING NEEDS. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR DOES BOTH BY
STRENGTHENING DENSITY BONE AT
THE DENSITY BONUS PROVISION AT
THAT MS WEEKS JUST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS JUST NOTED THAT
CURRENTLY ALLOWS A 100%
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS TO BE
BUILT MORE DENSELY AND WITHIN A
HALF MILE MAJOR TRANSIT STOP. BY
EXPANDING IT TO LOGIN T. AREAS
THESE ARE AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO DRIVE AS FAR OR AS
MUCH TO GET TO SCHOOL WORK OR
OTHER DAILY DESTINATIONS BY ITS
VERY DEBT DEFINITION- LOW BM
TEAM MEANS THAT THE DEVELOPMENT
WOULD HAVE A LESS THAN
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON GHG
EMISSIONS. NOT ONLY IS THE
REDUCTION A CRITICAL STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVING OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS IT ALSO PROVIDES
OTHER HEALTH EQUITY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN LOVE B. M. T. AREAS
IS ASSOCIATE WITH EVEN DEEPER
VMT REDUCTIONS BECAUSE LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS USE LOCATION. EFFICIENT SPACE MORE
EFFICIENTLY. THIS IS A SMART
POLICY BILL THAT PROVIDES NO NEW
FUNDING OR STREAMLINING OR
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO THE
DEVELOPERS BUT WHAT DOES
IS ALLOW COMMUNITIES THAT WANT
MORE HOUSING TO MOVE AHEAD WITH
HIGHER DENSITY. DEVELOPMENT IN
THE VERY AREAS WHERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS MOST NEEDED FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DO ITS PART. ON
BEHALF OF THE ONE MILLION LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS LET CURRENTLY
LIVING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
THE MILLIONS MORE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF THIS HOUSING. WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
NEXT SO IN THIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
NEVADA MERRIMAN POLICY DIRECTOR
AND I'M PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR O BEHALF OF
MID PENN HOUSING CORPORATION AT
MID PENN WE OWN MANAGE OVER
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED AFFORDABLE
RENTAL APARTMENTS. AND HAVE A
PIPELINE OF NEARLY A DISH AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE THOUSAND HOMES
THROUGHOUT ELEVEN COUNTIES IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO AND MONTEREY
BAY AREA. LAST THURSDAY MID PENN
HOUSING BROKE GROUND ON KEY TO
CROSSING A TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE UNIT INNOVATIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY.
ENVISIONED TO SERVE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND
OTHER SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATIONS
INCLUDING MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THIS
COMMUNITY WAS DEVELOPED IN DEEP
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF SAN
MATTEO AS IT IS ON LAND THAT'S
OWNED BY THE CITY. IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING PREVAILING WAGE
JOBS FOR ABOUT FORTY BUILDING
TRADES AND MEETING AN AMBITIOUS
SUSTAINABILITY GOAL WITH ITS ALL
ELECTRIC APPROACH. IT WAS AMONG
THE VERY FIRST PROJECTS TO BE
ENTITLED USING STATE LAW TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE. SENATOR WAS EXCITED TO
UTILIZE THIS NEW ENHANCED
DENSITY BONUS AS THEY HAVE A
HUGE LOCAL NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOMES. BUT LIMITED SITES THAT
ARE UNDER CITY CONTROL TO
DEVELOP. SAN MATTEO BROUGHT THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MID PENN AND
EMBRACE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL AS A TOOL THAT WOULD
HELP THEM MAXIMISE SCARCE AND
PRECIOUS CITY RESOURCE. THEIR
LAND. THE REVISED ENTITLEMENT
PACKAGE. WITH A NET OUT OF SIXTY
ONE HOMES FOR A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE WAS
SUBMITTED AND PROCESSED QUICKLY
WITH THE PROCEDURE STILL
REQUIRING DISCRETIONARY ACTION
BY THE PLANNING COMMISSION AND
CITY COUNCIL. THE COUNCIL
PROVIDED THEIR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND WAS PROUD BEYOND MEASURE
FORMER SAN MATTEO MARY JO
GOETHALS SAID IN A STATEMENT WE
HAVE OVER TWO THOUSAND UNITS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE AND
WITH THE HOUSE OF COMMUNITY THAT
MID PENN THIS BUILDING. WE'RE
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERY INCOME LEVEL. BY EXPANDING
THE DENSITY BONUS PROVISION TO
LOW V. M. T. AREAS AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
MORE COMMUNITIES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS CRITICAL TOOL.
LIKE CEMETERY DID. AN INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN AREAS THAT OFFER CONVENIENT
ACCESS TO JOBS RETAIL AND
SERVICES ALLOWING OUR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS TO DRIVE LESS TO REACH
THEIR DAILY DESTINATIONS. AND
THE STATE TO REACH ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MID PENN'S EXPERIENCE
MOVING CONCEPT INTO ACTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE ROOM AND I SEE A LINE OF
PEOPLE I ANTICIPATE THAT THEY
WERE COMING UP TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL SO. COME ON UP. NAME
WHERE YOUR ORGANIZATION YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND-WHETHER YOU'RE
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL. CHRIS
ARE ARE NOT BEHALF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT. LAWLER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. SYNDICATES THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. MY CLAIM
WAS BURNED STRONG SUPPORT. HE
ROOM DÍAS OF THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT. I
DON'T HAVE IN A CAR BOMB HAVE
CALIFORNIAN BE IN SUPPORT. TODD
DAVIS WITH A HOUSING ACTION
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT. NEVER
CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. RIGHT IF
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN GET- ANYBODY WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON THE LINE
TO EXPRESS THAT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO.
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YES HI THE
PHILADELPHIA CRANK HERE ON
BEHALF OF ALL HOME IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN FINAL
CALL ANYONE WISHINGTO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LINE ONE EIGHTEEN. AS WELL
ARE QUITE OUT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOMEBUILDING ALLIANCE
WHICH INCLUDES BECOMES UP AND
FELL BUILDERS AND FOR THE
QUALITY OF THE COURT THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THEN THAT BRINGS
US TO ANY OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES DO WE HAVE ANY ON THE
PHONE LINE OR IN THE ROOM. YES
MA'AM. SHE REGISTRY OKAY. OKAY.
WELCOME THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN- OFF OF BELL AND THE TO
THE COMMITTEE I'M I'M SUSAN
KIRSCH DIRECTOR OF CATALYST FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR CAME FROM
HOMELESS FOR LOCAL CONTROL SO I
APPRECIATE THIS CHANCE AS MUCH
AS I SEE MOST OF YOUR MANY OF
YOUR LOOKING AT YOUR CELL PHONES
TO BE ABLE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THIS BILL AND WITH
APPRECIATION THAT ALL OF US ARE
WORKING SO HARD TO BE ABLE TO
FIND WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN TRULY
FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ESPECIALLY WHO
ARE WAGE EARNERS OR WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR CAPACITY WAIT TO.
EARN WAGES SO I STARTED OUT IN
LOOKING AT THIS BILL LOOKING AT
THE PART OF THE STAFF REPORT
THAT SAID THIS IS BUILT ON THREE
PREVIOUS KIND OF LEGAL ACTIONS
AND THE AUTHOR MADE REFERENCE TO
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE WHICH
WAS INTO NINETEEN AND IT GOES
BACK TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN
THE FIRST DENSITY BONUS LAW WAS
PASTOR INJURED INTRODUCED SO WE
NOW HAVE TWENTY FOUR YEARS A
DENSITY BONUS LAWS THAT HAVE
BEEN TWEAKING THE PROCESS OF
CITIES BEING ABLE TO BUILD
HOUSING. FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
REALLY NEED IT AND HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT HOW WHAT IS THE MEANS
WHEREBY WE DO THAT SO WHAT ARE
THE RESULTS OF THESE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS WE HAVE INCREASED HOUSING
COSTS NCREASE LAND COST
INCREASE LABOR COSTS LESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE
INCREASED INVESTMENTS COMING IN
TO BUILD HOUSING WE HAVE
INCREASED HOMELESSNESS AND.
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS THAT GO
WITH THAT. TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF.
AND WE'RE GETTING ANOTHER BILL
WHICH IS CALLING FOR DEVELOPERS
TO BE ABLE TO CALL THE SHOTS. IN
THE STAFF REPORT THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE OF GIVING THE
DEVELOPERS THE CHANCE TO NAME
WHAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES. IMPACTING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. SO WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT THE DEVELOPERS ARE ABLE
TO DO. GET THE CONCESSIONS AND
THE BONUSES AND THOSE BONUSES
ARE COMING ON THE BACKS OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHERE THE CITY
STILL NEED TO PROVIDE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS THE
EXPANSION COSTS. AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THAN ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE CALLED ON TO BE ABLE TO
FUND THAT EXPENSE. THIS BILL
GOES FURTHER INTO DETAILS OF
LANGUAGE THAT IS NOT REAL EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE IT GOES INTO THE
NUMBER OF UNITS THAT HAVE TO BE
BUILT AS YOU KNOW AS LOW AS FIVE
WHICH MEANS THE- FIVE OR 10% OF
THAT MEANS THERE'S REALLY HARDLY
ANYTHING COMING. THE H. C. D.
REPORT- OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO HOUSING PLAN. IS A
VERY SIMPLE LOOK AT WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS IT IS LOOKING AT A
SUPPLY DEMAND PROBLEM AS IF
PRODUCTION IS GOING TO BE THE
ANSWER TO THAT. IT IS MISSING
WHAT MANY MANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OTHER GROUPS
ARE SEEING IN TERMS OF MULTIPLE
CAUSES AND MULTIPLE WAYS TO
RESOLVE THE HOUSING.
AFFORDABILITY PROBLEM SO WITH
THAT I ENCOURAGE YOU TO STOP
TWEAKING MORE BILLS WE DON'T
NEED TWENTY FOUR MORE YEARS OF
TWEAKING BILLS LIKE BONUS BILLS.
WE NEED DEEPER ANALYSIS OF WHAT
ARE THE PROBLEMS AND HOW DO WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO FIND THOSE
SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. SO DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT WISHES TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER WEST CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE OPPOSED LESS A MINUTE
POSITION WILL FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO. WORK OUT OUR
ISSUES THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
YOU'VE ALREADY GIVEN US. THANK
YOU. RIGHT THERE'S NO OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO DO THE EIGHTEEN T.
PHONE LINES YOU CAN OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
RIGHT NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE.
ONE FORTY SIX. A PARTY THROWN AT
YOU WITH PARTS YOU. AND IF YOU
KICK ME BAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF AB CUTE
THREE THREE FOUR THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FORTY FOUR. YES ISRAEL ORDER
WITH THE CATALYST ORGANIZATION
IN AYE OPPOSED. TO THREE THREE
FOUR. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
VERY GOOD THEN WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF FOLKS HAVE QUESTIONS GO
AHEAD. I THINK THIS YEAR AND
THANK YOU ARE SURE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- YOU KNOW BUT I
KNOW THE TIME AND I WAS ON THE
COUNCIL SOUNDS A OFTENTIMES THE
RED- YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS WONDER
LIKE WALL. WHY IT WHY ISN'T CA-
WITH PARTICULAR DEVELOP BUILDING
IS DIVIDEND SEASON POSSIBLY
COULD ESPECIALLY IN AREAS LIKE
IN THERE THERE'S CERTAIN AREAS
OR MAKE SENSE. CERTAIN AREAS
WHERE IT DOESN'T AND SO I THINK
THAT HAVING- THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO. BUILD A HIGHER DENSITY
IN THE PLACES THAT MAKE SENSE I
KNOW PLACES ARE CERTAINLY AND
BIGGER CITIES THEY GO TO A VERY
INTRICATE. IN A SPECIFIC PLANS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU WERE
DETERMINES THE CORRIDORS WHERE
DOES MAKE THE MOST SENSE BUT
SOMETIMES- YOU KNOW THERE THERE
THERE ARE STILL OBSTACLES TO AS
I THINK THIS LEASE. WHO'S ASKING
THE RIGHT. TO BY. INCENTIVE TO.
IMPOSE AROUND THSE TRANSIT
AREAS WITH THE TO THE TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENTS WHAT HAVE
YOU AND- TRANSIT NODES WHICH IS
AT SUCH A HIGH PRIORITY. I THINK
FOR SO MANY COMMUNITIES IN ORDER
TO. INSURE BUILDING IN THE RIGHT
PLACES AND BUILDING AS DENSELY.
AS WE CAN AGAIN WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE AND NOT JUST **** NILLY.
BUT IN IN THE QUARTER IS WHAT
MAKES THE MOST SENSE- AND I
LEARN MORE. BOB CAN RECENTLY
ABOUT SOME OF THE- CONCERNS FROM
FRIENDS OF BUILDING TRADES AND
CERTAINLY. I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO ALSO TO EVER EXTENT POSSIBLE
HELP FACILITATE. CONVERSATIONS
THAT REGARD I THINK THAT THAT
THERE ARE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING WITH OUR
FRIENDS- FROM LABOR IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT. WHEREVER WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE GOOD
QUALITY JOBS I KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT TRADITIONALLY BEEN AN AREA.
WHERE WHAT WHERE BOND SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE ESPECIALLY
BEEN INSERTED BUT THAT BEING
SAID BY HAVING A LOT OF.
CONVERSATIONS UP IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ANGLES I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT- AND- WE NEED
TO HAVE AND SO- YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE. THE DAUGHTER BRING
IN THE BILL FORWARD- AND YOU
KNOW HOW COULD HELP FACILITATE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FOR BOTH
WITH OUR- HOUSING ADVOCATE
COMMUNITY AND BUILDING TRADES
AND OTHERS- BUT THAT. MAY HAVE
CONCERNS OR OR OR- QUESTIONS.
ABOUT IT. A RESIDENT MOTION.
THERE NOT BEEN- OPENED YET. DID
YOU BOOK OKAY OKAY WE HAVE A BY
MISTER A SECOND BY MISCREANTS- I
DO HAVE A QUESTION AND I THINK
MY QUESTION CAN BE DIRECTED AT
ONE OF THEIR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. SO I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- I'M A
LITTLE HUNG UP ON THE PARKING.
SO OF HELP HELP ME ALLEVIATE
THAT THAT PROBLEM. YOU SAID YOU
HAD EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED UNITS
CORRECT SOMETHING LIKE THAT-
THAT WAS IN THAT UP BUT- WELL
THEN SHECAN COME UP TO. DO YOU
ALAUSA QUESTION NOW SO YOU CAN
CONSIDER IT. THEY ARE THERE YOU
HAVE ESTIMATES OF HOW MNY OF
THOSE EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED UNITS
THE PEOPLE THAT INHABIT THEM OWN
VEHICLES. DO YOU HAVE ANY OF
THAT TYPE OF DATA AVAILABLE. SO
IT'S DEPENDENT ON THE POPULATION
THAT WE'RE SERVING OUR FAMILY
PROJECT AND SAN MATTEO IT WOULD
BE TYPICAL TO HAVE APPROXIMATELY
ONE TO ONE RATIO. OKAY BECAUSE
WHAT I'M GETTING AT IS I'VE
NEVER BEEN TO ANY APARTMENT
COMPLEX WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
VEHICLES SO IF THERE IS A
REDUCED AMOUNT OF PARKING THAT
NEEDS TO BE- GIVEN TO A ARE ARE
SUPPLIED FOR A PART A UNIT- AT
YEAH I WOULD I WOULD. BE MORE
INCLINED TO AGREE WITH THAT-
YES- YOU HAVE A LOOK LIKE YOU
HAVE SOMETHING AT. MY I DON'T
KNOW I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY A
BIT THE BILL DOESN'T. CHANGE
MUCH IN THE PARKING INCENTIVES
OF DENSITY BONUS BILL IT DOES
SOME TECHNICAL CHANGES SO THERE
IS A CLEAR IS THAT CLEANS UP THE
DEFINITION. OF SORT OF THE 100%
AFFORDABLE PROJECTS THAT QUALIFY
FOR THE EXISTING PARKING BENEFIT
AND THEN IT DOES LOWER THE AGE-
FOR THE SENIOR PROJECT AT SENIOR
FOR DOUBLE PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
THE ALL OF THOSE THAT HAVE LIKE
THE LOWER PARKING MINIMUMS MUST
ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE STILL NEAR
MAJOR TRANSIT OR FOR THE SENIOR
PROJECTS HAVE. ALTERNATE
TRANSPORTATION MODALITY IS
CONNECTED TO THE PROJECT THE
LIKE A CARRIAGE PARA TRANSIT
OPTIONS. YEAH I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT PART OF IT
BUT- SO THIS DOES NOT PROHIBIT
THE IMPOSITION OF ANY VEHICLE-
PARKING RESPECT OUR STANDARDS
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES. THERE ARE
IT'S A 100% RIGHT OR DOUBLE. IT
THE- THE BILL AND THE BILL
ITSELF DOESN'T CHANGE WHAT IS
ALREADY IN LAW WHICH DOES THE
EXISTING WHY DOES HAVE- NO
PARKING MINIMUMS FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE WITHIN A HALF MILE
TRANSIT. SO FOR IT TWO HUNDRED
UNITS IN THE DENSITY BONUS THING
IS LIFTED TO UNLIMITED BASICALLY
AND THEY BUILD SIX HUNDRED UNITS
THEY JUST EXACERBATE THE ISSUE
RIGHT THREE TIMES AS MANY.
VEHICLE PROBLEM IS WHAT I'M
GETTING AT WE NEED SOME PARKING.
BECAUSE BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY
DO PARK. AND IT'S ALL OVER THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND IT'S ALL OVER
THE STREETS AND WHEN THE STREETS
ARE FILLED WITH CARS. THEN
THAT'S A SAFETY ISSUE FOR KIDS
THERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD PEOPLE
CROSSING THE STREETS- SO IF THE
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE ARE ARE
VERY WELL. YOU KNOW. THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET TO THE HEART OF
THE PROBLEM BUT- SOMETIMES WE GO
A LITTLE TOO FAR AND WHEN WE GO
THAT FAR. WE CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS THAN THAT THEN- WE ARE
TRYING TO- ADDRESS SO.
UNDERSTOOD MATT MASSIVE AMOUNT
YOU CAN SAY ONE MORE THING. I'M
OFTEN- SO I THINK ALSO KIND OF I
HEAR I HEAR YOUR CONCERN AND I
THINK FREQUENTLY WHERE MIGHT BE
MORE OF THE CHALLENGES WHEN
THERE'S A PARKING MAXIMUM THAT
SAT RIGHT WHICH WOULD PROHIBITA
DEVELOPER AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM GOING BEYOND THE MINIMUM.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF AND OF
NEVADA WANTS TO PROVIDE SOME
EXAMPLES OF HOW FREQUENTLY DID
THE DEVELOPER DID EVEN DESPITE
THAN THAT. THE BILL THIS IS THE
EXISTING LAW MIGHT SAVE AND
THERE ARE NO PARKING MINIMUMS.
FREQUENTLY A DEVELOPER WILL
STILL PROVIDE FAR AND ABOVE THAT
MINIMUM BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE COMMUNITY
WHAT THEY KNOW THAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS IN ORDER FOR THE
PROJECT TO BE APPROVED. SINCE
DENSITY BONUS DOESN'T SORT OF
STREAMLINED ACTUAL APPROVAL
PROCESS IN THE PROJECT STILL HAS
TO BE APPROVED. IF THEY GO TOO
FAR. YOU KNOW. THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE OTHER CHALLENGES SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S HELPFUL TO YOU TO
HEAR FROM YOU LATER ADD. YES
THANK YOU- SO IN PRACTICE IN THE
ANSWER THAT I GAVE PREVIOUSLY
THE ONE TO ONE PARKING RATIO.
THIS PRETTY COMMUNITY A MIX OF
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS SO THE
DENSITY BONUS THEY DID
ADDITIONAL SIXTY ONE UNITS THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO BUILD. DID NOT
HAVE PARKING BUT THE ORIGINAL
UNITS DID. AND IT IS DONE IN AN
AREA WHERE THE CITY HAS AN
ADJACENT GARAGE SO WE WERE ABLE
TO KIND OF LOOK AT OTHER
RESOURCES WHERE WE CAN DO SOME
SHARED PARKING. AND THEN THAT
THE NEW UNITS ARE FOR PRIMARILY
. EITHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR-
THE CITY OF SAN MATTEO HAS MANY
. ADULT CHILDREN WHO HAVE AN
INTELLECTUAL AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES WHO TYPICALLY DON'T
DRIVE IT THAT IT'S TYPICAL THAT
THEY'D NEED ZERO CARS ASSOCIATED
BUT THEY DO HAVE AVERY HIGH
DEMAND FOR THAT SO BY A LAYERING
IN DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS- YOU CAN
CREATE SOMETHING THAT'S MORE
SUSTAINABLE THANK YOU. I KNOW
DEVELOPER ONCE TOLD ME THAT YOU
CAN'T RENT OUT A PARKING LOT. SO
SO YEP PARKING LOTS ARE NOT.
CONDUCIVE TO A- A PROFITABILITY
IN FACT THEY'RE ONE OF THE
DRAINS ON BEING ABLE TO BUILD.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE IS A
NEED ANALYSTS IF IN ESPECIALLY
IN CALIFORNIA PEOPLE DRIVE.
GONZALEZ TO IT AND THEY WANT TO
DRIVE TO THEIR NET RELATIVE'S
HOUSE IN TWO CITIES OVER THERE
GONNA DRIVE. AND SO THEY ALL
MOST OF THEM HAVE CARDS AND SO
WE NEED TO MAKE THAT
ACCOMMODATION- AND THAT MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT IN THIS TYPE OF
SITUATION SO. ANYWAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR GUYS INPUT ON
THAT AND- GONNA BRING IT BACK-
BELIEVE ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY
OTHER ADDITIONS. IF NOT. I WILL
ALLOW YOU TO GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
THANK YOU MEDICARE P. **** THAT
QUESTIONS- THE COMMENTS
APPRECIATE ART CHAIR OF LABOUR
COMMITTEE OFFERING HIS HELP AND-
HAVING MORE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR FRIENDS OF THE BUILDING
TRADES I WELCOME THOSE I WANT TO
WORK WITH. OUR ALLIES THERE- AND
HOPEFULLY GET THE NICE STRONG
BILL THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT.
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THAT THE SECRETARY
GO AND CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE- AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. HI FREAKS I'D SAY
ARE DON'T KNOW. YOU KNOW.
CARILLO ARE YOU ALL RIGHT
GABRIELLE I'M REALLY KALRA.
KALRA KILEY. WORKS TO. THANKS TO
BUY LORD. FORTY FIVE. COOL. LET
ME. ALL RIGHT THAT MAY OUT FIVE
ONE. MANY REYES RESET TANK HERO
. OKAY EVERYONE LAST BILL- AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN- THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO STAY CLOSE SOME
LOOPHOLES THAT WE HAVE
DISCOVERED IN THE TENANT
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ALSO KNOWN BY ITS
NUMBER IS AB FOUR CD TWO OF
WHICH I WAS A JOINT AUTHOR- AND
HELPS AGAIN WITH OUR PREVIOUS
CHAIR DAVID CHIU TO GET THAT
BILL OVER THE FINISH LINE THAT
BILLS A LANDMARK BILL IN THAT IT
GAVE EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS
PROTECTION AGAINST RENT GOUGING
AND FRIVOLOUS. EVICTIONS HOWEVER
SINCE ITS IMPLEMENTATION A
SERIES OF EVICTIONS HAVE
OCCURRED THAT ARE CLEARLY
OUTSIDE THE INTENT OF THE
ORIGINAL BILL AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO- WE ENUMERATED A NUMBER IN
IN THAT BUILDING THAT
NEGOTIATION AND IN THE DEAL WE
ENUMERATED A NUMBER OF
JUSTIFIABLE CAUSES FOR
TERMINATION. OF A RENTER'S
TENANCY THOSE INCLUDED AT FAULTS
CAUSES FOR THINGS LIKE CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY ON THE PROPERTY. IT
ALSO INCLUDED NO FAULT CAUSES
WHEN THE TEN IT DID NOTHING
WRONG BUT THE PROPERTY OWNER
WANTED TO EXERT THEIR PROPERTY
RIGHTS- AND REALLY THREE MAIN
INSTANCES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HERE ONE WAS- THE MOVER WANTING
TO. MOVE THEMSELVES OR A FAMILY
MEMBER INTO THE UNIT- THE SECOND
IS WANTING TO SUBSTANTIALLY
REHABILITATE THE UNIT IN A WAY
THAT MADE IT TEMPORARILY.
UNINHABITABLE AND THE THIRD IS
WANTING TO TAKE THE UNIT OFF THE
RENTAL MARKET. WHILE THESE NO
FAULT CAUSES BURKE READ TO AS
REASONABLE. WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING TO ON THE GROUNDS ON THE
GROUND AS PROPERTY OWNERS.
EXPLOITING LOOPHOLES BY
TERMINATING TENDENCIES FOR THE
CAUSES I JUST LISTED BUT NEVER
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
THE ACTION. THAT IS THEY GET THE
TENTATIVE ACTED BUT THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY THEN MOVE IN OR IF THEY
MOVE IN ITS FOR. A DAY A WEEK
SOMETHING OF THIS NATURE- THEY
THEY THAT THERE'S A SENTIMENT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
REHABILITATE THE UNIT BUT IT'S
NOT A SUBSTANTIVE
REHABILITATION- OR THEY SAY
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE THAT RENTAL
UNIT OFF THE MARKET BUT THEN
WEEKS LATER. THEY MOVE MORE
TENANTS IN. SO WE NEED TO PUT
MORE PARAMETERS AROUND THESE
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT WERE NOT
REALLY DEFINED IS CLEARLY IN THE
ORIGINAL BILL AND I WON ALSO SAY
WE'RE KEEPING THE CORE TENETS OF
THE BILL AND WE HAD VERY GOOD
AND I WAS PART OF THEM.
NEGOTIATIONS WITH ATTENDED
COMMUNITIES WELL AS DEPARTMENT
CESSATION AND THE REALTORS- BUT
AT THROUGH THE COURSE OF TIME WE
REALIZE THERE ARE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFIED- IN THE COURSE OF THAT
LANDMARK DEAL THAT WE CREATED
AND THAT IS THE GOAL AND INTENT
OF THIS BILL. SO THAT'S THE GOAL
IS TO REALLY- HELP DEFINE IN
MORE SPECIFICITY- A STRONGER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THIS
MEANS- I WELCOME. CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION I THINK WE
PRODUCE BETTER. BILLS WHEN WE
HAVE DIVERSE CONVERSATION
DIVERSE VOICES- AND SO WITH
THAT- WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR- WITNESSES TO THIS TO- SELF
ADDRESSED THEMSELVES AND PROVIDE
MORE PERSPECTIVE ON THIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SARAH STEIN
HEIMER AND I'M IN A HOUSING
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL SERVICES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN
TWENTY THREE. CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES INCLUDING HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION AND MOST OF
THE COUNTIES NORTH OF HERE UP TO
THE OREGON BORDER. WHILE WE
REPRESENT AND LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE ON A BROAD RANGE OF CIVIL
LEGAL ISSUES ACCESS TO STABLE
HOUSING AND EVICTIONS ARE THE
NUMBER ONE THING THAT PEOPLE
CONTACT US ABOUT IN EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT WE WORK IN. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN BECAUSE IT'LL CLOSE
LOOPHOLES IN THE TENANT
PROTECTION ACT THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN OUR CLIENTS LOSING
THEIR HOMES DESPITE THESE NEW
AND IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS IN THE
STATE. ONE SUCH A LOOPHOLE IS
WHEN A LANDLORD SERVED A NOTICE
OF TERMINATION STATING A FAMILY
MEMBER INTENDS TO MOVE IN. RIGHT
NOW THE ACT DOES NOT REQUIRE
LANDLORDS TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO WILL MOVE
IN AND HOW LONG THE FAMILY
MEMBER WILL LIVE IN. THE RENTAL
HOME. THE ACT ALSO DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE FAMILY MEMBER TO
LIVE IN THE RENTAL HOME FOR ANY
SPECIFIED PERIOD OF TIME. THIS
LEADS TENANTS IN THE IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION OF TRYING TO DETERMINE
IF THEY ALLEGE REASON IS REAL OR
A PRETEXT FOR ANOTHER REASON.
TENANTS HAVE NO WAY TO CHALLENGE
THE REASON THE LANDLORD ALLEGES
WITHOUT RISKING AN INFECTION. A
JUDGMENT AND A MONEY JUDGMENT
WHICH HAS SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
FOR TENANTS AND MAKES IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT IF NOT POSSIBLE
TO RENT NEW HOUSING. WE HAVE
SEEN CASES WHERE THE TERMINATION
WAS BASED ON THE ALLEGATION THAT
THE OWNER WAS GOING TO MOVE IN
BUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES STRONGLY
SUGGESTED THE OWNER NEVER DID
SO. IN ONE CASE OUR CLIENT LIVED
IN AN APARTMENT COMPLEX WITH
ABOUT THIRTY APARTMENTS. THE
FAMILY MEMBER WHO ALLEGEDLY
PLANNED TO MOVE INTO THAT ONE
APARTMENT OUT OF THAT LARGER
COMPLEX LIVED OUT OF STATE.
OWNED A HOME IN THAT OTHER STATE
AND WAS A LICENSED REAL ESTATE
AGENT IN THAT STATE. THE FAMILY
MEMBER HAD ACTIVE REAL ESTATE
LISTINGS SUGGESTING THEY
CONTINUED TO WORK IN THAT STATE.
OUR CLIENT MOVED OUT OF THE
HOME. AND AFTER HE DID SO THE
FAMILY MEMBER CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACTIVE REAL ESTATE LISTINGS OUT
OF STATE. SUGGESTING THINGS
REMAINS IN THAT OTHER STATE. IN
ANOTHER CASE OUR CLIENT LIVED IN
A SMALL MULTI COMP MULTI FAMILY
COMPLEX HE RECEIVED A NOTICE OF
OWNER ME THEN. AND REPORTED THAT
HIS NEIGHBOR RECEIVED THE SAME
NOTICE HIS NEIGHBOR MOVED OUT IN
RESPONSE TO THAT NOTICE AND THEN
SAW THE MANAGEMENT COMPANY.
HOLDEN OPEN HOUSE TO RE RENT THE
NEIGHBOR'S APARTMENT THE NEXT
WEEK. WE HAVE ALSO SEEN
LANDLORDS. EMPTY ENTIRE
APARTMENT COMPLEXES AND RAISE
RENTS AFTER SERVING LONG. TIME
TENANTS SUBSTANTIAL
REHABILITATION NOTICES. THESE
NOTICES MOST OFTEN PROVIDE NO
INFORMATION OTHER THAN TO SAY
THE LANDLORD INTENDS TO DEMOLISH
OR SUBSTANTIALLY REMODELED THE
HOME. IN A RECENT CASE OUR
CLIENT WHO IS A SENIOR AND BIT
BEDRIDDEN DUE TO PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES FACE THE LOSS OF
HER HOME SHE HAD RENTED FOR SIX
YEARS. THE OWNER GAVE ALL OF THE
TENANTS AT THE COMPLEX THIS
NOTICE SAYING THE OWNER WILL BE
REMODELING. THERE WERE NO
CURRENT PERMITS ON FILE WITH THE
CITY ALL REPAIRS THAT WE
OBSERVED AT THE COMPLEX WERE
COSMETIC. SUCH AS PAINTING OR
MINOR REPAIRS THAT DID NOT
REQUIRE TENANTS TO MOVE OUT. OUR
CLIENT DID NOT MOVE OUT BECAUSE
SHE PHYSICALLY COULD NOT ALL
OTHER TENANTS AT THE APARTMENT
COMPLEX DID MOVE OUT IN RESPONSE
TO THAT NOTICE. OUR CLIENT
SETTLED OF. WE REPRESENTED OUR
CLIENT IN THE ADDICTION LAWSUIT
AND DISCOVERY SHOWED. THAT ALL
OF THE REPAIRS PLANNED AND DONE
DID NOT RISE TO LEVEL OF
SUBSTANTIAL REMODELING. THE
OTHER UNITS AT THAT COMPLEX ARE
NOW RENTING 440270% MORE A
FRIEND THAN THEY WERE AT THE
TIME OF THE NOTICE. WE STRONGLY
ASK YOU TO SEE A SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN THE
SECOND WITNESS IN FAVOR OF YOU
CAN KIND OF KEEP IT SHORT YES
SIR BURN THROUGH A LOT OF THE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRYAN
ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF. THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ONE OF THE
SPONSORS AND- I'M AMONG OTHERS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY WAS AT THE
TABLE DURING THESE NEGOTIATIONS.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE FINAL
POINT TO SIR PAUL THE STRINGS
TOGETHER ASTHMA STEINER. IS
DESCRIBING WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS
A BRIEF PROBLEM WE ARE NOT
CHANGING THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WERE
PRESERVING THAT IF THE OWNERS
TRULY MOVING IN. THEY CAN AFFECT
IF THE OWNER TRULY NEEDS TO- ASK
TESTAMENT OFFER SUBSTANTIAL YOU
HAVE THAT REMAINS A COST IF
THEY'RE EXITING THE RENTAL
MARKET. THAT REMAINS BECAUSE
WHAT THEY CAN'T DO IS PROFESSOR
KATE THEY CANNOT PROVIDE A FAKE
REASON. TO EVICT THE TENANT
ESCAPE THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
LAW AND RAISE THE RENT AND
DISPLACED TENANTS AND- WE
BELIEVE THE PROVISIONS AND
THEIR- SIMPLY SAY. A TO US THAT
WHAT YOU SAY IS TRUE AND IF IT'S
TRUE. THEN EVERYONE MOVES ON BUT
IF IT'S NOT TRUE. EITHER THE
TENANT SHOULD NOT LOSE THEIR
HOUSING OR THE SHOW THE RIGHT TO
COME BACK AND THOSE ARE REALLY
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE LAW AND MAKE IT
REAL. AND FOR THOSE REASONS-
WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE.
EVICTIONS OF THIS NATURE AND WE
EXPECT TO SEE MORE- IN THE NEAR
FUTURE AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
WOULD URGE AND I'VE FOUGHT TO
CLOSE THOSE LOOPHOLES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT
WISHES TO REGISTER AND THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. COME TO
THE MIKE. PRESERVAR NUMBER HAVE
A HOUSING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ON ALL OUR BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL HOUSING LAW PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. SKINNER IS ALWAYS WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY A CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
. RIGHT IT APPEARS THAT WAS THE
END OF THE LINE FOR IN IN THE
ROOM SO- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO REGISTER.
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND
I REMEMBER IT'S JUST YOUR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND YOUR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WILL GO TO LINE.
ONE FIFTEEN. AND ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SASHA HARDEN WITH THE
INNER CITY LAW CENTER THE COURT
. FIND. ONE FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ANDREAS RAMOS WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN THANK YOU. BY ONE FORTY
FIVE. BY ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I GO TO LINE
ONE OH NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WHEN
I GO BACK TO LINE ONE FORTY FIVE
AGAIN. YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I
WON FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO ONE L. TWO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
OPERATOR THAT BRINGS US TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
YOU KNOW PROCS THE MIKE UP HERE. YET TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
I CAN DO THAT I CAN TALK FOR
LONGER EXCELLENT. I HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- ASKING
FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY I'M AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN. OBVIOUSLY
AS THE AUTHORS INDICATED. SEEMS
TO CLOSE LOOPHOLES BUT IT DOES
MORE THAN THAT- AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IS THE BILL THAT-
THAT THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO
CHANGE THAT WAS BROUGHT FORWARD
BY OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TENANTS AND LABOR GROUPS.
ORGANIZATION DID COME TO THE
TABLE AND WE STRUCK SOME BALANCE
IN THE BILL THAT WAS HISTORIC
FOR A RENTAL PROPERTY
ORGANIZATION TO TALK ABOUT RENT
CAPS AND JUST CAUSE EVICTION
WHAT WE DIDN'T DO OR WHAT THE
BILL DID DO IS LEFT. A BASS LINE
IN PLACE RELATING TO- JUST
BECAUSE IT LEFT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE ABILITY TO DO
WHATEVER ELSE THEY WANTED TO ADD
AND THEY ARE DOING THAT TODAY.
AS YOU KNOW AS SOON AS- AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PASSED THE
PANDEMIC HIT THIS BILL HAS NOT
TAKEN FULL EFFECT- IF WE'VE SEEN
SOME OF THESE CHANGES- AT LEAST.
BY WAY OF WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL- HONESTLY WE HAVE
NOT HEARD OF SOME OF THESE VOTE
THE CHANGES THAT THEY'RE MAKING
THOUGH GO BEYOND FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO YOU CAN'T MOVE YOUR MOTHER
IN NEXT DOOR IF YOU ALREADY LIVE
THERE YOU CAN'T MOVE YOUR
STUDENT INTO A HOUSE. IF THEY
WON'T LIVE THERE FOR AT LEAST
THREE YEARS BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
COLLEGE AND THEY WOULD MOVE OUT
AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
SO THIS BILL DOES MORE THAN JUST
CLOSE WHAT ARE PERCEIVED
LOOPHOLES. WE DON'T THINK IT'S
IN TIME TO DO ANYTHING BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC TENANTS SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN MOVED OUT ANYWAY
WE HAD PROTECTIONS IN PLACE- SO
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT
WAYS TO AFFECT THAT- SO WHAT
THOSE REASONS WERE ASKING FOR
YOUR NO VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO REGISTER OPPOSITION IF YOU DO
COME UP TO THE MIKE AND DO SO. I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY SCRAMBLING TO
THE MIKE SO WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
IT UP FOR- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANYBODY WHO IS IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB. TWO SEVEN ONE THREE. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME SPEAKING OPPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. NINE
YES GOOD AFTERNOON- ADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OFREALTORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. ANYBODY MR GABRIEL.
YEAH I THINK YOU MISTER RIGHT
TURN THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR
B. FORD THIS BILL I'VE I'VE
SHARED WITH HER THAT I AM
STRUGGLING WITH THIS ONE AS
WELL- AND I'M STRUGGLING I THINK
BOTH FINE. PROCESS IN ON
SUBSTANCE HERE- AND YOU KNOW
FROM A PROCESS PERSPECTIVE ON
IBM. YOU KNOW WE HEARD FROM FROM
THE AUTHOR AND FROM THE
WITNESSES ABOUT HOW CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
WELL AS I THINK YOU DESCRIBED A
MADAM CHAIR IS A LANDMARK DEAL-
I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
CHARACTERIZATION THE- OPPOSITION
WITNESS SAID THAT THEIR HISTORIC
COMPROMISES MADE BY THE- BY BY.
LANDLORDS I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT I WAS FRANKLY SHOCKED WHEN
THEY AGREED TO- TO GO NUDE
NEUTRON THAT BELL. AND WHAT'S
GIVING ME PAUSE HERE IS IT FEELS
LIKE WE'RE GOING BACK AND
CHANGING THE TERMS OF A
CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED DEAL- IN A
WAY THAT I'M NOT SHORT. IS
WARRANTED AND WHEN PEOPLE COME
TO THE TABLE IN GOOD FAITH IN
NEGOTIATING GET TO A PLACE I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL. FOR ANY HISTORIC
FOR THE STATE AND DID A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS AND THEN IT FEELS
LIKE WE'RE GOING BACK. AND MAYBE
IN SOME WAYS PUNISHING THOSE WHO
MADE CONCESSIONS TO- TO COME TO
THE TABLE NINE I AM ALSO
STRUGGLING. ON THE SUBSTANCE
HERE. AM I THINK AND MR GUSTER
DESCRIBED THIS AS AN ISSUE OF
PROOF- AS I LOOK AT THE DETAILS
IT GOES FAR BEYOND THAT. RIGHT I
MEAN WE'RE LOKING HERE WE'RE
SAYING. I'M IN OWNER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO MOVE IN WITH NINETY
DAYS AND STAY FOR AT LEAST THREE
YEARS I CAN IMAGINE A SCENARIO
OF SOMEONE IN MY DISTRICT. WHO
OWNS A DUPLEX WITH THAT THEY
LIVE IN SOMEONE ELSE LIVES
UPSTAIRS THEY HAVE A- CHILD
COMING BACK HOME ONCE TO GET IT
TO YOUR MASTER'S DEGREE CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE. THEY COULD
EVEN MOVE THEIR CHILD BACK INTO
THEIR UNIT. OR OR THAT HAVE TO
NOT RENT A PLACE FOR YOUR KEEP
THEM THERE EVEN IF THEIR CHILD
WHEN GOT AT. A JOB IN ANOTHER
PLACE SO THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO ME
LIKE AN ISSUE OF PROOF THIS
SEEMS TO BE CHANGING.
SUBSTANTIVE ELEMENTS OF THE DEAL
AND SO FOUR WERE REALLY TRYING
TO GET OUT HERE AS A PROOF
QUESTION AT FIRST I THINK IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE A REMEDY
HEARING WE HEARD TESTIMONY FROM.
MR STEIN ABOUT HELD. BY LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS ARE
SUCCESSFULLY LEAD LITIGATING
THESE CASES IF WHAT WE NEED IS
MORE MONEY FOR LEGAL AID. I'M A
THOUSAND PERCENT- IN SUPPORT OF
THAT. BUT LET'S CHANGE THE
STANDARD OF PROOF BUT TO GO BACK
AND SAY YOU'VE GOT TO LIVE IN
THE APARTMENT FOR THREE YEARS.
YOU'VE GOT A MAIN GET PERMITS OF
YOU CAN DO ANY. WE NEED SEEMS TO
ME SEEMS THAT WE'RE GETTING AT.
WE'RE GETTING AT THE FUNDAMENTAL
ARCHITECTURE THAT DEAL. IN A
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY- AND
THEN THE OTHER THING I'D ASK FOR
JUST- IN LOOKING IN THE- THE
ANALYSIS HERE THERE WAS. IT SAID
THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THE
PROPERTY OWNERS ARE DOING THIS.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THAT GIVEN
WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC PEOPLE SHOULD BE MOVED
OUT ANYWAY SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
IF THERE'S ANY DATA OR RESEARCH.
OR ANY METRICS OR STATISTICS
THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE ABOUT HOW
FREQUENTLY THIS HAS BEEN
HAPPENING. IF WE HAD A RENTAL
REGISTRY WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- SO I'LL
LET SOMEONE ELSE ADDRESS THAT
THE DATA AROUND WHO'S WHO'S SORT
OF DEALING DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WITH FOLKS ARE HAVING THIS
EXPERIENCE- I WILL SAY YOU KNOW
WHEN WE CAME TO TERMS WITH THE
DEAL WE SAID. A NO FAULT
EVICTION WOULD BE. YOU KNOW AN
OWNER WANTS TO MOVE IN RIGHT AND
SO IF AN OWNER WANTS TO MOVE IN
IS ONE DAY FARE AND THEN THEY
CAN PUT IT BACK ON THE MARKET. I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THAT
IS TO ME THAT'S A DEAL POINT
THAT'S CERTAINLY BEEN NEGOTIATED
I I'D HAVE TO EXPECTED. CA WANT
TO AGREE TO THAT IF YOU SAID
THEY HAVE TO LIVE FORTHREE
YEARS AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING US RIGHT NOW SO
IT DOESN'T TO ME THAT FEELS LIKE
AN IMPORTANT DEAL POINT. THAT
WE'RE GOING BACK AND REWRITING
AFTER THE FACT WHAT I THINK I
THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS WE DIDN'T
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE WHAT MOVING
MEANT RIGHT AND THAT'S PART OF
THE PROBLEM IS ONCE WE'VE- THE
BILL. ONCE THE LAW HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IS. IT IS ESSENTIALLY BEEN USED
AS A LOOPHOLE TO EVICT PEOPLE
AND THEN TO BUMP UP THE RENT AND
BRING INTENDED SAID AND SO I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT. IN MY OPINION ADDING
MORE DEFINITION TO A PRE
EXISTING DEAL SO MAYBE THREE
YEARS ISN'T FAIR. WE SHOULD GO
SHAPE THAT WE SHOULD. WE SHOULD
SIT DOWN AT THE TABLE AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE THINK COULD WORK
AND I WELCOME THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. YOU KNOW
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ONE DAY AND
THREE YEARS MAYBE IS WHERE WE
WOULD LAND ON THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S MY HOPE IS THAT THE
CONVERSATION CAN KEEP GOING. AND
WE CAN SAY WHAT DOES SEEM FAIR
FROM YOUR GUISES PERSPECTIVE.
YOU KNOW TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
AROUND. YOU KNOW ENSURING THAT-
IF AN OWNER IS TRULY MOVING IN
THEN THEY'RE REALLY MOVING IN.
AYE AYE AYE CHAU I SUPER
APPRECIATE THAT I MEAN I GUESS
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS. IT EEMS TO
ME LIKE THE DEAL POINT WISE WILL
LEAVE THIS QUESTION UP TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT PART OF IT WAS NEGOTIATED.
AND I GUESS I WOULD SAY SECONDLY
FROM A PROCESS PERSPECTIVE.
GIVEN THE WAY THAT FOLKS STRETCH
TO CREATE CRAFTER THIS IS START
DEAL. I WOULD I WOULD THINK
THAT. THE RESPONSE WOULD BE TO
GO TO THEM FIRST AND SAY HEY. WE
THINK THERE'S A HANDFUL OF
UNSCRUPULOUS FOLKS OUT THERE AND
I WAS MOVED BY MISTIMES
TESTIMONY I THINK IT SOUNDED
LIKE. REAL SCUMBAGS OUT THERE.
CAN WE WORK WITH YOU ON A- ON A
FIX TO ADDRESS PEOPLE WHO ARE
CIRCUMVENTING AS- AND- IT AND I
WISH THAT THAT HAD HAPPENED
FIRST RATHER THAN. JUST COMING
HERE AND SAYING. WE'RE GONNA
ROUTE GO BACK. CHANGE THE TERMS
HERE AND ADD THIS THREE YEAR
THING WHICH- TO ME THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT. YEAH AND I AND I
ALSO AND LET. MISTER JUSTICE
BECAUSE WELL- AND I THINK
THAT'S- PART OF THIS PROCESS
RIGHT AND- AND- RESPECTFULLY THE
OPPOSITION LETTER DIDN'T REALLY
ALLOWED ANY OTHER. COUNTERPOINT
RIGHT IT WAS. JUST SORT OF A
BLANKET OPPOSITION. MY HOPE IS
WE CAN CONTINUE THE NEGOTIATIONS
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH YOU I THINK
THAT'S- THE- THAT'S WHAT THIS.
PRODUCT POLICY PROCESS IS FOR.
WE HAVE ALREADY OPENED UP
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. WE DIDN'T
TWENTY TWENTY. WE RENEGOTIATED
SOME OF THOSE TERMS ALREADY. SO
I DON'T THINK THE LANGUAGES IN
SICILY SACROSANCT. I THINK WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS. FINE TUNE
AND AS WE IMPLEMENT LAW WE HAVE
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING KIND OF.
WHAT IS WORKING AND WHAT IS NOT
WORKING. AND I AND LIKE I SAID I
WELCOME THE CONVERSATION AND I
HOPE THAT THAT'S A PLACE WHERE
WE CAN GET IF WE CAN. GET THE
BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
IT'S IMPORTANT. AND I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE. THE PURPOSE OF STATION
BUILDERS. REALLY CAME TO THE
TABLE AND THAT PROCESS AND I
WANT TO RESPECT. THEIR WORK IN
THAT IN PERSPECTIVE DECISIONS
THAT THEY MADE. AND THE FACT
THAT I THINK THEY ALSO HAD TO
MOVE THEIR CONSTITUENCIES
CONSIDERABLY. FOR THAT AND SO
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M I THINK I'VE
NOTICED SOMEONE WHO WELCOMES
THOSE TYPES OF CONVERSATIONS SO
IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE CAN KEEP
DOING AYE AYE I APPRECIATE THEM
AND IN TURN I THINK PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING IT REACT TO IS
THE CHARACTERIZATION THAT THIS
IS A PROOF ISSUE. THREE YEARS
DOES NOT STRIKE ME AS A
PROFESSION. THAT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL DEAL POINT. AND TO
HAVE IT REPRESENTED THAT WAY.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING. NO I HEAR
THAT AND I THINK- I CAN SPEAK
FOR MYSELF I'M- VERY WILLING TO
NEGOTIATE ON THAT. THEN IF I MAY
JUST WRITTEN RESPONSE. I'M WELL
I WAS TRYING TO CUT MY REMARKS
ON MR GABRIEL BUT I DO. I DO
THINK IT IS A PROBLEM A PROOF
AND RIGHT NOW WHERE WE ARE. IS
AS MISS NINE ARMORED TESTIFIED.
IN A SITUATION WHERE LANDLORDS
CAN SAY ARE MOVING AND- AND
NEVER MOVE AND IT'S A HEAD FAKE.%
SO HOW DO WE- HOW DO WE MEASURE.
THAT THEY ARE TELLING THE TRUTH
THAT THEY ARE. IN GOOD FAITH
INTENDING TO MOVE IN. WELL
CERTAINLY NUMBER ONE. THEY
SHOULD MOVE IT. NUMBER TWO. THEY
SHOULD REMAIN IN OCCUPANCY FOR
SOME AMOUNT OF TIME SO I THINK.
THAT IS THREE YEARS THE RIGHT.
METRIC RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ZERO.
SO SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ZERO AND
THREE YEARS. WOULD SUBSTANTIATE
THAT THEIR GOOD FAITH REASON WAS
IN FACT A RECENT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE- THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AIMING
FOR. AND I THINK IF THAT'S THE
POINT WE HAVE A VERY WELL
DEVELOPED BODY OF LAW ON THE
STATE FOR HOW WE DO PREFER RIGHT
WE HAVE SHIFTING BURDENS WE HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS OF PROOF WE
HAVE EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO.
DIFFERENT THAN SAYING. YOU HAVE
TO LIVE THERE FOR THREE YEARS.
SO IF IT'S REALLY A PROBLEM OF
PROOF. LET'S GO LOOK AT THAT AND
COME UP AND I THINK WE COULD NOT
GET OUT IN FIFTEEN MINUTES
HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO PROVE.
THAT YOU REALLY WERE MOVING IN.
AND THIS IS IN A PRE TAX BECAUSE
WE DEAL WITH THAT AND A WHOLE
BROAD. ARRAY OF CONTEXT. BUT TO
SAY YOU HAVE TO LIVE THERE FOR
THREE YEARS. THAT IS NOT A
PROFESSIONAL AND NOT AND NOT
REALLY FRUSTRATES ME. ACTION ON
THAT BUT- HOW. HOW POST TALK TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT. HER
GOOD FAITH INTENTION WAS REAL
AND THAT'S THAT'S ALREADY COMING
OUT OF THAT THERE WAS RELEASED
ON. BUT WE DO THAT IN THE
APPOINTED CONTEXT ALL THE TIME.
I'M RIGHT I MEAN WHEN IT IS THIS
A PRETEXT OR SOMEONE FIRED FOR
DIFFERENT REASON I MEAN WE HAVE.
THIS IS NOT. A UNIQUE PROBLEM TO
THIS AREA OF LAW. THIS IS WHY
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OPPONENTS. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION.
ANYBODY ELSE MISS KOREA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THE AGAIN FOR
THE DISCUSSION ON THE BILL I
WILL HAVE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
AND SENTIMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
UP IN THE VALLEY HAS ALSO
EXPRESSED IN YOU AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS IS ALL
I'M REALLY CURIOUS AS TO THE
IMPACT TO SMALL MOM AND POPS I
KNOW FIRST CONVERSATION ABOUT
DUPLEXES I'D LIKE TO KNOW THE
IMPACT TO. A HOMEOWNER THAT HAS
A FOUR PLEX- AND REALLY JUST THE
IMPACT TO EVERYDAY PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY THE MUCH A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF HOUSING. HAS A
HOME A DUPLEX AND EIGHTY YOU FOR
SMALL UNITS ON THE PROPERTY
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT HUGE
APARTMENT COMPLEXES WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE SMALL RESIDENTIAL. THE
UNIT THAT WE WOULD HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON TO- R. ONE ZONING
ARE TWO OR THREE OR FOUR. AND
I'M I AM CONCERNED. THAT WE MIX
THESE SITUATIONS ARE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HUGE HOUSING
COMPLEXES WITH SMALLER UNITS-
AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW
FAMILIES IN MY COMMUNITY WOULD
BE IMPACTED TO US WELL AND AS
YOU CONTINUE TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FORWARD- THOSE ARE
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT. I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT THE CONVERSATION FROM
FORWARD. BUT IF WE DON'T GET TO
A GOOD PLACE BY THE TIME THAT
OBVIOUSLY THIS REACHES THE
FLOOR. THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION YEAH NO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND AGAIN I
THINK THE- THE GOAL HERE IS YOU
KNOW. WE MADE A DEAL THAT SAYS
OWNERS CAN MOVE IN. WE JUST
WANTED SURE THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT WE MADE A DEAL THAT SAYS
YOU KNOW- IF THE PLACE NEEDS TO
BE YOU KNOW REHAB. THAT TENANTS
CAN BE EVICTED IN AT NO FAULT
AND THE PROPERTY OWNER HAS THE
RIGHT TO DO THAT. WHICH IS
ENSURING THAT THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS RIGHT- SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THINGS OR TRY TO TACKLE HERE
LIKE I SAID I WELCOME THE
NEGOTIATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
IT AND MY HOPE IS WE CAN GET THE
BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE IN ORDER
TO DO THAT. RIGHT SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
BOTH THE PURPOSES STATION THE
REALTORS AND OTHERS- HAVE A
VESTED INTEREST IN THIS BECAUSE
I ALSO UNDERSTAND WITH THE
LANDLORDS HAVE GONE THROUGH OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS RIGHT. AND
A LOT OF THEM ARE MOM AND POPS
AS YOU SAID WHO THIS IS THIS IS
THEIR FOUR OH ONE K. OR THEIR
PENSION FUND RIGHT THIS IS NOT.
YOU KNOW- THEY'RE NOT SITTING ON
A HUNDRED UNITS OR TWO HUNDRED
UNITS THEY OWN A DUPLEX. YOU
KNOW THEY'VE SPENT THEIR LIFE
BUILDING UP EQUITY THERE THIS IS
WHAT THIRD THIRD DRAWING ON FOR
THEIR RETIREMENT SO I THINK WE
WANT TO BE FAIR. THIS IS ONE
ENSURE THAT- YOU KNOW THAT THE
TRUE I THINK INTENT IS HONORED
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO TRY
TO PROVIDE DEFINITION AROUND. HI
ANYBODY ELSE. AND THEN MR
GABRIEL YOU CAN FOLLOW. GO AHEAD
AT THE RISK OF MAKING MY
COLLEAGUES EVEN HUNGRIER SO I
JUST WANT TO. SAY YOU KNOW-
MADAM TRY I DEEPLY APPRECIATE
YOU AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE THE TERM ARE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND OUT OF DIFFERENCE
TO YOU AND RESPECT FOR YOU IN
THIS NEW CHAIRMANSHIP I'M GONNA
VOTE TODAY TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TO ALLOW US TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION- I'VE SEEN YOU BE A
SKILLFUL DEAL.MAKER NEGOTIATOR
AND I'M I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND A WAY TO
BRING FOLKS TO THE TABLE- BUT I
DO WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH YOU OFFLINE ABOUT SORT OF
YOU KNOW HOW THIS BILL WORKS
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET
OUT WHAT IS THE EVIDENCE OF HOW
WIDESPREAD THIS IS BECAUSE
BEFORE WE GO BACK AND- BLOW UP.
WHEN EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
THINKS AS A LANDMARK DEAL- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE REALLY
THINK THAT THREAT SO LET'S I
WILL VOTE TO MOVE THE BILL FOR
TODAY BUT LOOK PART OF THOSE
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT MR GABRIEL.
MISS QUIRK-SILVA- AGAIN THANK
YOU TO FOR. TO THE AUTHOR BUT
ALSO TO THE OPPOSITION AGAIN
THIS IS ONE OF THESE BILLS THAT.
I THINK IS DIFFICULT FOR THE
MEMBERS HERE IT ISN'T THAT WEEK
WE WANT TO. ENSURE THAT THERE
AREN'T- PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY AT THIS VERY
VULNERABLE TIME. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT TOO MANY OF THE
PROTECTIONS. FOR RENTERS. HAVE
NOT- THERE ARE MANY MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO BE IN LINE
TO GET SOME OF THAT RENTAL
PROTECTION WHICH IS GOING TO
COMPOUND. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. NOW THAT BEING SAID- TOO
OFTEN WE FIX ONE THING. AND
THEN. LIKE I SAID IN MY EARLIER
COMMENTS. MANY TIMES. ADD
ANOTHER. BURDEN SO. I WILL ECHO
MY- REMARKS TO. MY COLLEAGUE. TO
THE LEFT HERE WHICH IS. AGAIN
YOU KNOW WE LEARN THINGS AT
THESE HEARINGS. SO EVEN IF WE-
FEEL LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF
KNOWLEDGE OF THE BILL WE HEAR
DIFFERENT- TESTIMONY AND THAT
COULD VERY WELL CHANGE HOW WE
INITIALLY FILL SO AGAIN I WILL
SUPPORT IT COMING OUT BUT I
REALLY HOPE THAT THERE'S QUITE A
BIT OF WORK THAT CAN BE DONE. SO
THAT IN FACT THIS CAN GET
THROUGH THE FLOOR AND GET THE
SUPPORT YOU WANT. THANK YOU AND
WE ALSO SPENT A PERIOD OF
SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS.
PRIVATE SECRETARY- CALL THE ROLL
I WILL- YOU KNOW WHAT WE NEED A
MOTION AND WE NEED A SECOND. THE
MOTION BY MISTER KALRA. SECOND
BY MISTER WARD I'M GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN JUDICIARY
WICKS HI I SEYARTO NO NO CORREO
RELY GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. A
FEW YEARS AGO- WARD. BOARD I.
EIGHTY FOUR. FIVE ONE OKAY THAT
MOTION IS OUT. AND THAT PASSES
FIVE ONE ALSO I NEED TO DO A
CORRECTION ON AB TWO THREE THREE
FOUR IT DID GO OUT SIX TO ONE
NOT FIVE TO ONE. I WAS
DISTRACTED SORRY DIDN'T LOAD ON
THE- ABOUT. TEN TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE FOR THIS ONE SORRY.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. I
THINK SHE VOTED I. SO THAT
MEASURE GOES OUT SIXTY ONE THEN
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA IS
THAT. HI HI HI THANK YOU. ALL WE
ARE GETTING THAT MEASURES OUT
SIX TO ONE. OKAY YEAH.